the following is a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
players were in attack mode at the u.s
juniors and senior championships in
saint louis hunters became the hunted in
an extremely decisive round giants are
waking in the senior section with
shabalov and gorovich winning their
first games and larry christensen taking
down his competition for the top spot
there's a new number one in the juniors
with christopher yu winning his game to
steal first place chasers are in hot
pursuit but sophie morris suzuki
continues to dominate the field winning
her fourth straight game each event as a
sole leader but for how long round five
of exciting chess
coming up next
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back everybody to day five of
the us juniors and seniors chess
championships held at the st louis chess
club we start the day at the entrance of
the beautiful forest park in front of
the st louis rocks sign well the players
before the rest day are ready to rock it
on the chessboard let's go to the studio
and start this exciting round
everybody back to saint louis missouri
the capital of chess in america this
couple of hot weeks of july we have
three national championships for you the
us junior u.s junior girls and u.s
junior are being played for here at the
saint louis chess club to bring you all
of the action of these marathon games
i'm grand master alejandra ramirez with
grand master yes sir sarah juan
alejandra as always a great pleasure to
be with you and christian calling the
action it's already round five we're
past the halfway mark it feels like time
passed very quickly and it's because we
have had tons of games truly hello
everyone and thank you for joining us
for our live coverage of these national
championships i must say that something
snapped yesterday and there was
incredible amount of victories some
kind of undeserved but anyway we'll
leave it at that uh alejandro do the
honors and tell us the standings let's
start before let's do that let's take a
look at our live shot of the playing
halls everybody's coming in everybody
gets wanted to make sure that there are
no electronic devices that would be
against feeder regulations no exceptions
here everybody gets wanted
yes indeed
and then the standings for the girls as
we see nick getting laundry
in the girls sections we have a miss
perfect sophie boy suzuki with four
points out of four has just been
dazzling
she won a very nice victory yesterday
against alice lee taking advantage of
the young players blunder alice by the
way a bit of a disappointment of a
tournament so far
out of four with the pre-tournament
favorites jennifer and talia one point
in trailing by one point and in the
junior standings in the juniors we also
have a clear leader actually we have a
clear leader in every section in this
one it's christopher you that won a
brilliant game yesterday against andrew
hong with the black pieces with the
black pieces and taking advantage of his
opponent's lack of understanding in the
french meanwhile he is chased by a young
and ferocious but somewhat lucky
abhimanyu mishra who got gifted a full
point in round three by another player
that's doing surprisingly bad wender
liang and then the seniors in the senior
section again we have a clear leader in
this one as well and it's larry
christensen he took down maxine dulugi
yesterday to take over the lead of the
event but he is followed very closely by
a certain dimitri gurvich two and a half
points for him absolutely and uh our
format for these three national
championships it's a ten player round
robin in each section it's a classical
time control of chess 90 minutes for the
first 40 moves 30 minutes for the rest
of the game and a 30 second increment
from your move one no draw offers are
allowed before the 30th move and there
is the traditional scoring system of one
point for a win half a point for a draw
and no points for a loss
and a beautiful day in st louis here
central west end the players are
arriving and by the way the chess club
here in st louis you can tell is
expanding they have this new entrance
where
where the
tournament has moved and there's a
little wave of the hand by shabba
shabadaba one of the legendary players
here in this event let's take a look at
our schedule we have a round every
single day except tomorrow tomorrow do
not tune in tomorrow the players will
not be here we won't be here right and
we need our rest day the players need
the rest day as well considering the
games that we saw yesterday absolutely
and we have christian
in studio uh to drill down and tell us
about another gladiator christian good
to see you my friend good to see you
guys and uh great to be back in the
studio casting the games of the best
juniors as well as the best legends that
we have here on american soil and we've
been looking at a lot of very intriguing
players but one that i definitely have
my eyes on especially after yesterday is
the rating favorite in all three events
the top rated player in all three events
that is young a wonder liang what a
spectacular player these guys and look
at him he's getting ready for his match
up he is definitely looking for revenge
after a very difficult start 19 years of
age grew up in madison wisconsin he
currently attends and leads the
university of chicago chess team this
player at the university of chicago
managed to amass an incredible team he
came into this event as the highest
rated player 26-25 and that is the
feeder rating not his invitational
rating who is actually which is actually
over 2700 he is also the two-time world
use youth chess champion and those
championships are not easy to come by
liang is also the second youngest us
player ever to achieve the international
master title and the third youngest to
achieve the gm title which he
accomplished at the ripe age of 14.
that's quite incredible we know nowadays
with all these youngsters uh arriving at
the gm title around 12 years of age he
might be considered all nevertheless age
14 grand master title quite an
accomplishment he's also three time
champion at this event in 2017 2018 and
2019 and
look at him his focused composed
collected and ready to come back in this
tournament after a very difficult start
in the first three rounds
wow christian so accomplished and so
young extraordinary really really
amazing
do the honors what can our viewers
expect in terms of pairings alejandro
for the girls we actually have great
pairings in the girls we have this match
of a perfect miss perfect
she is the one to watch she will be
having the white pieces against ellen
orange is gonna try to get that five out
of five cement her lead meanwhile the
people that are following her closely
jennifer you with the three points is
playing a tough one against ray yang yan
who won her uh miraculously saved her
game yesterday after winning uh her game
the previous round she sits on two and a
half points dalio cervantes with three
is going to try to catch up with sophie
by playing with the white pieces against
gracie prasanna
and in the juniors let's take a look at
this as we have also some huge matchups
exactly in this section but i'm going to
have my eyes on abby manu misha with
three points against andrew hong with
two and a half you could also argue look
the listener for you christopher he's
playing against balaji da gupati who
comes off two victories in a row right
he bounced back from that loss against
andrew hung in round two then won two in
a row now sits on plus one that's a
great match and
two versus one the
jacobson versus liang i mean
pre-tournament those guys look at them
getting ready for
focus there this is christopher you
against dagupati our early leader
christopher use really showing excellent
chess
not as reliant on one style over another
he really seems more of a universal
player and let's take a look at the
pairings in the seniors
again some great matchups we're
expecting yes but i think i'm gonna have
my eyes on the leader larry christiansen
playing a classic matchup against joel
benjamin how many times have they been
teammates have been rivals over the
board as you can see big larry
having a good tournament so far against
joel who surprisingly lost against igor
yesterday i know and i was so
disappointed not in the way he lost or
you can always lose but in the fact that
he didn't go for rook takes d2 it was
just it was just crying to be played
alexander chabaloff coming off a victory
goes up against dmitry girvich who's
currently in second place yeah both of
them won their games uh yesterday so i
think that's a big one to watch
absolutely and again the fight is
getting wanted
andrew hong is
very tall but also very young
he's always been a tall kid though
it's funny to see some of these players
rise up in the rankings i actually met
andrew hong when he was i want to say
eight years old
so it's been
i've known this guy for like a decade
exactly he's
last year actually he started i think
with minus four or something along those
lines
zero out of four yes he had a very rough
patch and then he came back after that
now this year he starts off blazing hot
cooled off a little bit after yesterday
but let's see what he brings to the
table today difficult game against
lots and lots of fighting going on here
what are they fighting for
alejandro in the u.s junior girls let's
take a look at the prize fund twenty
thousand six hundred dollars in this one
six thousand goes to first four thousand
per second and three thousand per third
but we have to remind our viewers that
this is a qualifier for the us women's
championship to be held this year in
october here at the single stress club
to repeat the winner of this event will
play in october in october of this year
that's right and on top of that there's
a ten thousand dollar scholarship for
first place not only here in the juniors
but also in the group not only the
juniors but in the junior girls as well
thank you to
dwayne barber and the us chess dwayne
and susan barber for helping out and us
chess trucks for matching those prices
and in the juniors on top of that twelve
thousand dollars per first eight
thousand per second five thousand for
third and the seniors well they're
getting the big price point seventy five
thousand dollars for them including a
twenty thousand fat check for first not
bad but no scholarships those
scholarships well seniors if they ask
nicely i think we can get them some
scholarships and by the way they are
underway the players have started their
their round five christopher i noticed
knight f3 and c4 inviting this d4 we'll
see
if um his opponent takes up the
challenge where would you like to go i
like to go with miss perfect it's
perfect let's start right there
absolutely sophie you gotta have a you
always have to pay respects to the
person that's
for sure for sure and she is playing on
the white side against alan ellen wang a
open sicilian
i tell you it's nice
whoops bishop d3 now that's
i mean i'm just so used to seeing knight
c3 as a kind of automatic
i've
i'm a little surprised by bishop d3
doesn't that just allow knight c6 in the
easy equality or
what am i missing
this is of course it's theory but i i
always thought it was the second best
move i
i agree
like knight c3 so automatic i just don't
even know
about this i'm thinking knight c6 and if
you take well she's playing quickly so i
guess she has some idea and she has
played knight c6
the thing is normally
what this opening battles are about is
kim
white play e5 here e5 is a very annoying
move because this knight doesn't have
that many great squares you go to d5
have the analysis board on yeah the
players are playing quickly i just got
to say i love these uh
film shots of these videos of the
players at the board i think uh the
production team is doing a great great
job big shout out perhaps just using
some kind of kg move order trying to get
her opponent outside of theory
she saw something in the databases maybe
maybe there's something new on this line
so i'm not i'm not very familiar with
this move bishop d3 even though i've
been playing e6 sicilian my entire life
you mentioned e5 the desirable e5 early
doesn't work because there's a double
attack queen a5 check picks up the bond
but the move castles does introduce the
threat of e5 and black has several ways
of dealing with she can play e5 she
could play d6 and she could play d5 i
think
all of those moves maybe even queen c7
is possible although uh what would you
play here
if
you had black's position probably d5 d5
and kind of inviting maybe i don't know
this kind of a french
french defense type of uh game even
though
i mean i am somewhat familiar with these
structures knight d7 i know that when
the pattern is on a6
this line is yeah and then i have my
knight on season three as well i've got
an extra time you got an extra tempo
right you've wasted the move a6 it's
even worse than a waste actually i found
out that the more analysis i did on this
variation the more i realized that
actually this bishop on a6 is important
exactly and if you can trade it off via
bishop a6 you solve all your problems
instantly but if you got your opponent
on a6 it's not easy there's other ways
of playing of course c5 d4 c5 c4 but if
you want to play it with an exchange of
the bishops you don't want your pawn
there so it's a little bit of a better
version and ellen wang does go for the
variation of d5 and you can see sophie
very well prepared
she's just listed out knight d2
and
in this case we would be expecting
bishop e7 and a very quick castles now
they were still in the girls let me just
check in
on the game between rue yang yen and
jennifer
you
[Music]
oh this is a anti-marshal but with d3
huh knight c3 okay
all right knight c3 it's a line it's not
the main line but it's a stretch of the
imagination but it's a line i see that
uh many times after you've provoked d7
d6 i've seen them play both a2 a3 knight
to d5 just to avoid this knight a5
business and i played this myself after
bishop g4 i played this against
tomaszewski in the world cup of 2013
with the white pieces we ended up in a
draw okay uh but it was
back then in 2013 this was uh a tavia
did you get a pull i didn't i did get a
pool and the moment i had a pool i made
like a stupid strategic decision i had
to defend the rest of the game don't
hate that one
hate that and then where's talia i want
to find talia's game before we yeah
before we jump to
the other players here we go
oh another what gracie
um
samish a samish king's indian
and after knight e2 kind of a different
approach than the bishop e3 c5 bishop e3
b7 b6 i must say i'm not a big fan of
this move for black
um
it's been played before apparently i i
don't know it at all right uh i suppose
the idea is that if you get into these
benoni's then the move b7 b6 is okay i
don't know about that though i'm not
sure either right because you're trying
to get b5 in one move right if we
compare that line that we were looking
at like d5 e6 we've actually seen this
in this tournament with i believe three
rochelle wu against sophie was like this
with h5
yeah right
which is a clear extra tempo for white
yeah i think i do too
so okay well we'll keep our eye on this
and uh let's jump over to christian
and what have you got your eye on well
i'm looking at uh the juniors uh games
guys because i've been touting a
wanderer as one of the prospects not
only of junior chess here in the united
states but also chess as a whole uh u.s
chess as a whole and
definitely in this one he has a big test
against brandon jacobson and if he wants
to come back in the tournament and
potentially make a run for the
championship he needs to pile up and
string some victories together and
yesterday good start against carissa
with the white pieces but today a big
test with the black pieces against
another player that is definitely in
shape brandon jacobson who's coming off
of uh two wins with the black pieces in
the joko piano the joko piano expert if
you want to put it this way and today he
starts uh as white with the catalan
inviting bishop to b4 of course bishop
to e7 is uh also an option everything
pretty much is an option detail c4 is an
option here c6 everything you can play
bishop to b4
bishop to d2 knight to d2 has been tried
recently especially uh by a young player
named daniel dubov and uh he gives up
this pawn and then we know that magnus
carlsen also took uh some ideas from
daniel during the world championship
match against jan nepomnyashi so knight
bd2 is definitely making a resurgence in
the game of chess in this particular uh
situation in the catalan but bishop to
d2 remains the main line bishop to e7
bishop to g2 castle
castle knight bd7 so he's not taking on
c4 he decides to uh just simply build up
his position on the queen side develop
all of his pieces and later on
potentially focus on a different type of
plan and that is potentially with the
move c7 to c5 later on so c6
b6 as we can see he's developing his
pieces bishop to b7 is not on the board
yet we do see that white is nursing a
space advantage right now in this type
of structures white is going to have a
space advantage now the question is how
easy will it be for black to be able to
break in the center with the move c5 if
you can manage and time it well this
break with the move c5 then black is not
going to have absolutely any
difficulties another way in which you
can play this position and i believe
this is why he's thinking right now is
in fact go bishop to a6
try to put some pressure on this
diagonal specifically on the pawn on c4
couple this with the idea of rook to c8
later on in the game and then see uh
five pointing at the pawn on c4 so let's
see what he decides to do bishop to b7
makes the most sense to me and now
white according to uh the theory right
now e4 and by the way none of that was
played
i was going to wait for bishop to b7 e4
and now i saw this move hidden uh among
other mainline moves rook to c8 is one
of the main lines dxe4 but i did see
this move also offered by the engine
knight to h5 it has been played nine
times and i was looking through the
names uh in that base i couldn't
recognize many of them i would assume
these were all correspondence games but
it does seem like a wonder decides to
start immediately with a move knight to
h5 now the difference is if you do go
to e3 this pawn is no longer on e4 so
you're going to have to spend some more
time to break uh with e4 bishop to b7
can be played in this position but e3
was played quite quickly by his opponent
brandon jacobson inviting this trade on
f4 my guess is that if you do take on f4
i'm probably going to take with the e
pawn
taking with the g pawn also makes some
sense because after that you're going to
try to create some difficulties on the
g5 for the black king but taking with
the e pawn also has its strategic perks
and that is it creates a very inviting
square for the knight on e5 i'm going to
land that knight on e5 i'm going to try
to set up my initiative that way and
maybe at some point i'm going to be able
to bring this rook rook to e1 rook to e3
g4 and then look to h3 potentially
hinting at an attack on the king side
very intriguing position let's see what
a wonder decides to do if you said a
with a move knight to h5 it does feel
like you have to say b with knight takes
a f4 maybe not in this particular moment
maybe you can still wait bishop to b7
rook to c8 but at some point you will
have to take on f4 and change the pawn
structure very very complex middle game
coming your way in this one thank you
christian yeah this is actually a
position the one that we just saw
between no wonder that we saw here at
the same louis chess club not too long
ago see how theory develops pretty
quickly we actually saw that in the game
between nicolas theodore with the white
pieces against yu yang yi uh in the
summer classic a toast strong 2700
player right and nicholas was actually
winning this one but the chinese player
escaped with a draw nice i wanted to say
it's a day of sacrifices upon sacrifices
in the seniors as i'm looking at the
game between vladimir
kopian and igor
i'm going to get his last name wrong
help me with igor's last name malnitsky
one more time please malinitsky i think
the k is silent
are you sure about that no
[Laughter]
but it was so
authoritatively stated i did
you got me so once again malnitsky
without its keys we'll ask him when he's
here all right very nice uh a nimzo
sicilian uh a very rare rare guess at
these uh exalted levels everybody plays
knight c6 e6 and or d6 the early knight
f6 is frowned upon
by modern theory because of this move
knight c3 now when i was playing against
the chess engines they just didn't know
what to do i would play knight take c3 d
take c3 e6
they would play some silly moves and
eventually when i played d5 they never
played on facade they put the i know it
was terrible
and i would win very easily but this
move e7 e6 i've always called it the
nimzovich gambit in the sicilian and i
never thought it was that good for black
and yet the books i read
thought that black could get away
with
this position and i i remember studying
it
uh as a kid and i was like always
waiting for somebody to play it against
me because i knew what to do nobody
played again
i mean oh this thing was just not
popular at all nobody played take the
names off i think these books always lie
to you right like i've been waiting to
like do this uh fisher rashevsky dragon
i played the dragon with black with
white with gray
never had an opportunity of throwing
that in nobody falls for it and why did
i say it's a a day of gambits because in
the uh shabala
versus a dimitri garvich game we're
seeing yet again another gambit of a
pawn by black this is in the starage d4
taresh
this bit this gambit has been around
forever it feels like at least although
i have to say it's gotten
popular only recently
like i wouldn't say two three years yeah
most people just kind of like shied away
from it i don't know but they didn't
believe it they didn't believe it but
recently you see a lot of people
actually throw in this gambit and
actually a lot of white players straight
up refuse it
um
modern theory right and i wanted to turn
it over to christian with
the most salient question i could
possibly ask
is white gonna die with a full tummy if
he takes the pawn on b7 christian
taking on b7 i think is supposedly not
correct right right if i remember
correctly the theory and i think i
played this with uh the black pieces as
well
taking on b7 was never on my radar and
almost nobody takes on b7 exactly but
you mentioned a day of gambits and we
have another gambit in one of the big
games of today's round and that is
christopher you versus uh balaji
dagopatia gambi that they haven't seen
in a very long time the blumenfeld
gambit right check this out so they
started off with already knight to f3 d5
c4 d4 and now we know e3 is one of the
main lines but you can also start with
the move b4 now at this point black has
a lot of options including the move g5
quite a funny looking one g5 is a move
g5 is definitely a move and i have to
say probably one of the best moves in
this position if you do take on g5 then
i follow it up with e5 black gets a lot
of counter play for the last pawn in
general you're not supposed to take on
g5 you're supposed to play something
along the lines of g3 and black is going
to continue with g6 leading up to a very
complex middle game but c5 is another
one of the most topical lines in this
position and now e3 came on the boards c
takes before sorry take on e3 first take
on e3 c takes b4 and now we enter into
the blue and fell gambit i remember
looking at this many many years ago i
think nissipanu played it once with the
white pieces and him being my compatriot
i decided to kind of look at this
i didn't find too much but it's
definitely a fun position to play
christopher you seems to be quite
confident with his chances right now he
played the move a3 and
looking at the time situation he
definitely surprised his opponent again
the bloomfield gambit hasn't been seen
at the top level
at all in the last few years
it was sporadically seen every couple of
years in one two top level games and
then it disappears right this is usually
how it goes so this one quite
interesting now
another intriguing question uh that i
just realized black had an option at
this point in the game between uh
brandon jacobson and a wonder is to
actually pick up the piece trap the
bishop trap the bishop with the move g5
if you go bishop to e5 then i can
potentially go f6 right and the bishop
is trapped now
you can start by taking on d5 as white
now if you do respond with the natural c
takes d5 bishop to c7 finally i got an
extra square save my bishop and i'm
going to be i'm going to be just fine g5
is actually going to be a weakness in
the positional liability for the black
king so
after c takes d5 the question is what if
i just simply continue picking up at the
bishop but now i can just continue with
queen take c6 this is already my second
pawn
let's keep that in mind targeting the
rook immediately if you go rook to b8
then i can go d6 i can even take another
pawn on e6 later on most likely i'm
going to get another one on f4 that's
going to be four pawns for a piece and
the king is quite in shambles and my
position and my structure is extremely
compact at this point as white
especially if i manage to take on f4
with the g pawn it's not looking uh like
a good position for black definitely a
sound sacrifice for white and i don't
think a wonder is going for that and he
did not he played the move bishop b7 c
takes d5 on the board this is what we
have right now if you do take
with the c pawn you're inviting bishop
to c7 so now it's a big decision for
black
you either take on f4
and accept the change of the structure
or you take with the e pawn and i'm 100
sure you want to play this movie in the
position because with the bishop already
committed on b7 at some point you're
going to have to go c5 try to open it up
like that and that's going to invite a
change in the structure and why
potentially getting a strategical
advantage playing against the hanging
pawns and we know that sometimes goes
bad in um white's favor so let's take a
look and let's wait to see how a wonder
is going to continue this one definitely
once again a very
big and important match-up between these
two youngsters in this round two of
their pre-tournament favorites but i'd
like to quiz you a little bit more on
that peace sacrifice position because i
didn't like the move rook b8 and he took
only uh on d5 with the e pawn it seems
like and he did it rather quickly yes uh
the the piece sacrifice with g5 i didn't
like the remove rook v8
g6 bishop six is amazing i thought it
was a tempo um can i take the rook you
can definitely take the rook yeah
okay
so
i guess and we're going to play this one
how many pawns do you get for a whole
round
it's going to be how many four i guess i
guess i take on e6 yes
and i move my king mm-hmm
yeah and then maybe knight to e5
wow
huge complications it does seem like i'm
going to get an exchange back somehow
yeah so knight takes e5 seems to be the
main move right now
now you have to go back you cannot go
bishop city yeah because the nicest
knight right so you have to draw back
with the knight i can pick up the rook
wow take back whoa i have to move my
bishop yes yes bishop to f6 probably
right even though it seems like f takes
c3 is the only move that maintains some
sort of a balance in the position
first take on e3 take and then bishop to
b for a very complicated battle and i'm
sure white had some ideas in terms of
theoretical knowledge in this position
crazy
crazy and by the way brandon
still blitzing out his moves he just
played this move h4 he definitely knows
what he's doing dang yeah yeah well stop
that puts the kibasha on g5 for sure you
see i told him yesterday that he's
playing against the wonder and he told
me no no i'm playing against andrew hong
and we're good friends
i was right that's actually true just
getting in the i was right part i like
that but this is the position we've seen
before we actually saw it in that game
that we mentioned between theodoru and
yu yang yi so nothing new under the sun
here after age four yeah yeah h4
yeah was played in the uh classic and
the classic here in uh lewis once again
database doesn't seem to be updated
there is a game between sh okay i i have
nice uh just doing a quick uh check
around i have the game of max
uh delugey and nick the fermion uh i
london system lazy man's chess by maxim
he's developed his bishop to f4 he's
getting ready to castle
uh nick had an earlier game i think
against igor where he kind of handled it
oh well yeah yeah yeah the first round
right he got almost a decisive advantage
yeah exactly well an advantage for sure
uh going to our um leader larry
christensen joe benjamin versus larry
christensen very very traditional queens
gambit declined
being played by larry again
i mean this is like the old school
knight b8 to d7 b7 b6 before
playing the move knight d7 as a more
modern approach but uh i played this all
my life so
like last year
yeah there you go
1920s and 30s vladimir kobian is being
offered this pawn
as mentioned queen takes d5 again i
looked at this stuff as a teen and
nobody i never got a chance to play it
but i do believe that queen takes d5 uh
is advantage white we will see
and what have you been uh eyeing
alejandro well just before we go
anywhere else yes uh i just want to show
you what happened in the game between
christopher you and balaji exactly
balaji decided to counter
with the move e5 which has been played
only once uh between ituri saga and
girlfriend
that's a very serious game that is a
blitz game indeed but it just goes to
show psychologically that these
youngsters they don't really want to
defend no they want to get the
initiative back right okay take my pawn
back i want to get some uh some fresh
air for my bishop right potentially
after bishop to d6 get some tempes in
the position for my pieces they don't
like to play under the initiative they
like to have the initiative and
psychologically perhaps christopher's
decision to go with the bloomfield was
the right choice right now the engine is
saying that white is already having a
pretty significant advantage what is the
point what if i just take this point
that is a very good question
it will have to be answered because i
can guarantee you christopher is going
to look at that juicy pond juicy central
pawn and he's going to be like yeah i'll
take it sure i'll play the blumenfeld
gambit um
with equal pawns sure why not well it is
such an important pawn after all i don't
see a better move than bishop d6 by the
way bishop d6 is probably the best and
now i can
reinforce it with d4 or probably just
knight
i would maybe take the knight in that
case and then maybe take on d1 and white
structure but knight f3 and you've got
this big big center coming yeah i have
four
yeah i have to do something like bishop
g4 i feel like i'm
uh as black
i've got to go hyper aggressive after
using the e5 i'm not a fan i know this
is a line with the colors reversed and
the knight already let's say on f6 yes i
know that's a line but that's different
but that's different you're up in the
important tempo because i say so
um this is a one tempo situation in this
type of opposition all right well keep
an eye on that one just checking in on
carissa
uh the only lady in the uh juniors and
what the heck is she doing she's playing
like at least a woman's chest right
the black lion reversed i think is what
we call this
i always call it the hippo hippopotamus
yeah and the hippo too yeah
okay you but i'm i'm of course know it
more from
the uh
perk move order right right as black
where you get something like this and
then you end up playing
e6 knight d7 isn't the black lion with
e5
maybe um you guys keep counting these
things names but i have never heard of
the black lives
matter like i got a book man man i'm
good i mean i'm googling this i i i i'm
spending uh spending on my money
no chess
chess just just black lives carissa on
the white side just a second hold on let
me refresh my board she's doing okay
let's call it the hippo then she's doing
a hippo as white she just played the
move a3
intimating that rather than playing b3
she's about to play bishop b2 b4 and
bishop b2
um sometimes
christian
when things have gone wrong
you kind of go on tilt a little bit you
you you're doubting your openings are we
seeing this with carissa this is early
of course well i mean
she did that uh against uh ana
uh at last year's u.s championship okay
if you remember correctly with the black
pieces and she got a completely losing
position right managed to win that game
i remember so
and she didn't have a great start very
similar to what she's uh doing right now
i think she was on minus one
after four rounds and after that she won
i think five in a row or something along
those lines but the point being whenever
she's under pressure in terms of uh
result
it does seem like she goes for these
type of situations in which she simply
just tries to outplay her opponents and
um well this is a good chance for her
because she is playing a struggling
player that is pedro espinosa the lowest
rated player in the event only half a
point
for him uh this is a battle for who's
going to be able to come back into this
event exactly by the way if you look at
pedro's position as black
let's say he plays the knight c6 move
fred reinfeld who wrote
a hundred books on chess a hundred books
on chess
many of the beginner books
he would describe this development from
black's point of view right now as
perfect ideal development you bring the
knights out you have your central pond
duo and you bring your bishops to these
original diagonals so somewhere fred
reinfeld is saying you see you see i
taught you how to play chess
but i never got these positions i was
either black or white
i would never
my my bonus would never be so
cooperative that i would make such a
development uh scheme uh did you ever
get a development scheme like that uh
how about you christian i mean did you
ever see the perfect fred reinfeldt set
up um so which one is that with knights
the way that pedro is developing you
know knight on c6 i don't have something
right right
the central pond duo
that's right yeah that's what happened
when i was maybe i don't know 10 years
ago
like 80 years of age something along
those lines you're not expecting to see
it in the national championship that no
no no no not after that oh great and
also i'm not 100 sure i mean i know as
uh beginners you're thought that you
should place your pieces like that i'm
not sure how accurate that actually is
yeah it's actually not i'm not very
convinced about it at all
excuse me but i spent like three bucks
at the um used bookstore and i mean i
i've paid good money to learn how to put
my pieces
i'll pick up the receipt
from myself
refunds at those used bookshops i i also
tell my uh very novice students that
they should place their pieces like this
once again i'm not so sure uh that i'm
convinced about my teachings in this
regard
nice but you're not getting your money
back
tuition was paid for all right i see you
had that nimzog gambit and you were
doing some research what have you
discovered by the way what did you
discover about the black lion okay the
black lion i googled this yes the black
lion variation is not an opening itself
rather it's a mix of both philidor and
pierce defense systems
it goes like knight f6 knight bd7 d6 e5
ah
i don't know man i don't believe in this
what
[Laughter]
it's a thing i'm telling you i got the
book man i got the book uh sorry uh
christian you were about to tell us what
your research
showed in the gambit oops i wasn't
researching anything i saw it behind you
i thought i was just going through the
games and trying to see where the action
is okay and um i stumbled upon this pawn
on a3
by andrew hung in the joko piano and i
was like how did this happen right how i
usually see the pawn all the way to a5
to meet a white pawn on a4 right but i
almost never see this pawn land on a3 so
i was kind of curious to see how did
this happen
he decided to go with a5
a4 this expansion on the queen side very
early on expansion on the queen side
generally when i see this position there
is probably a bishop on d7 but he
decides to uh just simply go like this
bishop to b5 attacking the pawn on a4 he
has to play the move a3 otherwise you
just lose that pawn right b4 bishop to
b6 and by the way it does seem like
there's still some games in the database
one of them is duda versus geary from
2019
that probably is uh the top-level game
rager versus anton guiharo so there's
been some discussions in this position
knight way uh e7 preparing the move c6
followed by knight to g6 and try to uh
strike back in the center with d5
bishop to a4 knight to g6 bishop to b3
rook to e8 queen to c2 this is the
current position that we have on the
board and i'm very surprised to see that
abimany has barely spent any time right
one hour and 29 minutes for abby money
one hour and 15 minutes for andrew hong
um i don't know how to feel about the
position i think it's still quite
complex i understand that pawn on a3
looks good for the moment but could
potentially become a liability later on
in uh a potential end game rook to b1
rook to b3 if that bishop moves away
from a b3 you can imagine all sorts of
scenarios uh resembling that situation
so
intriguing game absolutely
double edged thank you christian for
that
just looking at the
junior games that one with the pawn on
a3
does
look very strange i'm looking again at
the game of christopher you
versus palaji
i was thinking
queen a4 check knight f3 i understand is
a kind of an automatic move but queen a4
check i kind of want to wrong foot you a
little bit if i can
and
also
end up trying to win a pawn
so the idea is if i can get you to play
knight d7
and then i'll drop back with my knight
i've
i've taken away maybe an annoying move
bishop to g4 i've stolen
this option from you
um
your your your take about the move queen
a4 check alejandro something you like if
you play bishop d7 of course i'm going
to take it no and then i'm going to feel
like i i've saved it yeah i'm very happy
about that right right no i i feel that
97 seems the most logical i would spend
some time looking at 96 trying to make
it work right it doesn't seem to me that
it does if we can show the audience c6
absolutely you kind of start wondering
if you can't take one cc can you go
queen h4 check right but it feels that
i'm just too
threatless like i take on g3
you take less threatless you take back
takes g3 because i don't have time to
take on h1 okay king d1 and i was hoping
you know like some check on f3 or
something but
you're you're not scaring me with your
warface
i know uh
threatless i i remember uh
viktor korchnoy saying that was a
toothless
what is it threatless i don't know
that's crazy do i go bishop d7 here
dang
the game is still still goes right wow i
don't know if it's good for me or not
but that's a game it's wild okay
the queen a4 check did uh catch my my
drift
something christopher is actually
thinking about too because otherwise you
just play knight f3 automatically right
without kind of
not not even thinking about it yeah you
did mention by the way in this bloom of
bloom and tell gambit with colors
reversed the knight is already on f6 and
that makes such a huge difference right
because you're castling one turn you're
spreading knight e4 you're threatening
knight g4 it's a lot of things that you
can do with this extra tempo
it really can change the character of
the position when we think about
positions in chess we normally
characterize them in one of two ways
open
close
positions in the opening that are very
open that means that pawns are not
abound that pawns are not really like in
this position right where
this is a close position because pawns
are just
eight versus eight versus eight you
can't really get the bishops out you
can't really get the knights out it's
it's hard to do anything in the center
there's a close position right tempe are
not as important exactly in positions
where
everything blows blows up when you have
activity on every side of the board
tempi are very important and in this one
with christopher you yeah i mean this is
clearly an open position and i can't
find it it's the third one thank you it
was like
clicking through the mall yeah and it's
a it blowed open it blowed open it's
already open and it's clear that every
temple will be imported in this position
that's why we think that the position
with the knight on f6 and the knight not
on f6 it's a different evaluation
altogether that means that the reverse
blumenfeld
playable player this one less so yeah
all right and uh christian back over to
you uh what what has your attention i'm
looking at this game between rueyang and
uh jennifer eu quite an important game
for the standings absolutely especially
for uh jennifer who had a pretty tame
start but after that she managed to win
two games in a row so definitely on a
roll and we know that once she starts uh
stringing those victories together we
remember what happened in the u.s
women's championship when she finished
with 10 out of 11 incredible score now
let's take a look at what happened in
this one this is a rui lopez a very long
line of the rui lopez uh this is where
the big ramification comes knight to d4
is one of the main lines from what i
remember knight to a5 also makes a lot
of sense in this position and i believe
this is what i play
i will have to recheck my fire but i do
believe that i play knight to a5 c5 and
then get the bishop back to e6 one of
the things that i always shy away as
black was specifically this type of
structures after knight d4 bishop takes
d4 take on d4 knight to d5
it just always seemed to me
like black doesn't really have a clear
chance of actually winning or actually
getting more than just a draw in the
position and in fact the structures are
not easy to handle and it always seem
like white maintains a
slight edge from a structural point of
view and this is exactly what we're
seeing right now e5 came on the board
upon sacrifice
uh
it's probably going to be regained that
pawn you're going to restore the
material balance bishop take c5 doesn't
make a lot of sense because after knight
takes c5 take on e5 and then queen to e2
it does seem uh like white is getting
its pawn back also you can start with
the move queen to e2 first now
the difference between knight takes e5
and queen to e2 first is that right now
rook to f5 is actually going to be met
with g4
and you no longer have the extra square
g5 for the rook with the knight still on
f3 so i do think that queen to e2 and
i'm going to be able to regain this pawn
on e5 after i do that
you're going to have a backward spawn on
e6 that i'm going to be able to target
also the pawn on c5 is going to become
immediately a liability because i will
have either the queen or a rook on e5
targeting that pawn as soon as uh one of
them lands there so e5 i like this move
i like this transition proposed by white
most likely we're going to see d takes
c5 and now the question arises
are you going to focus on regaining the
pawn on e5 back or are you going to try
to just simply
put this knight on e4 and play for a
strategical edge let's wait and see what
whites decides to do in the position
nevertheless
i'm looking at the position i know the
way jennifer you likes to play very
aggressive chess right and i don't see
as many pieces left on the board this is
not her style this is why i'm a little
bit concerned about her chances in this
game nevertheless jennifer and by the
way she took with the bishop on e5
now queen tuito i think is quite
important to be played by rue yang if
she wants to maintain on edge
intriguing i know that ding laren
likes to play those black structures but
here we have a production team
giving us a perspective of the playing
hall alejandro as they stroll around
what a wonderful job they did with this
playing call to think about
about a year ago this was actually a
vodka bar and they transformed it into
this beautiful playing hall absolutely
took over the entire building in fact
there was restaurants yeah as well
remember the bumble
bee the beehive the beehive right yeah
we had brennans and we took over the
whole thing
and the juniors get to see their faces
in on the wall because of course we have
the
portraits of everybody that plays a
national championship here not just the
national championship exactly but i'm
missing the group photos
they're behind
um not larry c but behind max delugey
you get an idea of what you're just
saying the portraits yeah of the players
of the class of 2021 let's say but i
want to see the group photos the group
photos oh the ones that we have upstairs
right yeah those are really really nice
bishop takes e5 your take on the
jennifer
uh
uh
uh
the game of jennifer you for just a
second it's a little drier than jennifer
wants it to be yeah i think with it's a
strange opening choice in general
because i don't remember jennifer
playing an e4 e5 e4 e5 player i thought
she was a night off player okay but
um
whatever surprised this brought i don't
think it was too successful because the
reason what i
what i wanted to ask you was the idea
that christian mentioned queenie to
rook not just fine do it do it do it do
it do it yeah yeah yeah uh and i wanted
to ask you like
excuse me but
i
i've always thought that these exchange
sacrifices
let's say
you know if i could maintain that's a
big if right
yes
if i could stop you from playing f4 get
keep my bishop on e5 that's a huge if
it's a great oh let's go but what if you
but if i don't let you what if i play
queen e4 yeah immediate immediately the
thing is you just can't avoid f4 that's
right if i play g5
it's a little hardcore yeah well i
wanted to keep my bishop you know knight
takes e5
knight takes e5 but this is a bit
strange yeah because knight takes e5 if
we can put that on the you do have rook
f5 yeah it allows black to play rook f5
after which i think you don't actually
get that pawn back not that white should
be worse it's not that easy to win the
player i mean because you can play g4
but then again no no you don't know
you are leaving some weaknesses behind
and it's pretty clear that jennifer
will will
one of the best moves you can possibly
play right here right now would be the
move g4 back to g2 so g4
yeah g4 comes with uh
some a consequence by the way how is
miss perfect doing that's an important
question uh let's take a look at that
game
uh this
yes this was the sicilian bishop d3 then
what do you call them apples
please right what does leeches call it
sicilian defense french variation
because that that does not help
that that almost fits actually right
yeah yeah strangely right because it's a
french structure
against three against three on queen's
side yeah but you have four or four bl
for black i don't know three verses
three three and three on the queen side
and the king side for white yeah and
then black has this four and either the
isolated a and c or the two with a and b
so this is actually a known french
structure uh more than a sicilian
structure and everything i know about
the structure is the black is completely
fine sure two bishops outweigh
the
split split pawns yes especially because
you get a point in the center that if
this baby gets rolling it's pretty
dangerous from sophia's point of view
i mean she's got a kind of an easy idea
though she wants to play bishop b2
rook d1 and on a good day immediately
take away the two bishops and that's the
thing right this is the battle of
strategy right
so we'll we'll keep a close eye on that
one and we'll ask christian uh where
would you like it to take us well a very
interesting game the is developing
between maxim lugi and nick defermion
because uh once again maximum dougie
came with his usual london system we
know that he played only london in this
event and an intriguing response came
from nick the fermion uh throwing his
opponent out of the book as soon as move
two with this move b6 and it didn't seem
like he knew exactly what to do knight
to f3 d6
and we're seeing this battle for the
move e5 if black manages to get the move
e5 and put some pressure on uh the
center as well as the bishop
f4 is he's going to have a very decent
position now let's see where we are
right now knight to d2 bishop to f3 and
queen to c8 i like this move
don't exchange and allow my queen to get
involved into play and then potentially
land on c6 put the kibash on your
position on the queen side you don't
want to see that queen to c8 i really
like this move inviting the trade on my
terms as black i will take on b7 after
that i will go b5 start attacking your
pawn structure putting some pressure i
like what i'm seeing from black nick the
fermion seems to be in full control in
this position and maxim uh lookie one
hour and fifteen minutes well he's
generally quite a fast player especially
in the positions that he enjoys are
playing and i don't think this is one of
them e5 by the way is on tap it's coming
very soon i don't think he's very happy
with the outcome of the opening he
certainly doesn't look at that as for
sure
are you doing on f4 what are you doing
on f3 i'd like to turn our attention to
the game of zoetang versus rochelle wu
why because it's a trumpovsky
on the board you know whenever we get
these uh
new and different uh openings d4 knight
f6 bishop g5 you got to pay attention uh
maybe it's a zoe special i don't know
what but check what she did you know i'm
a gm i have a gm next to me so about
time i ask maybe i'll ask google right
who's trumpfowski
i do not right
i'm sorry i don't i don't know how he
got attributed to him and who he is
where he's from i mean i don't know
anything about this why we got christian
here
no no no that's right we have alejandro
with the google situation there i see
but look what zoe did man she just
rushed her h-pawn up the board uh the
ginger gm would be proud of her harry
the h bond she's opened up the h file
for herself she's planted her night on
the f4 square
she wants to castle and i assume
she wants some kinds of sacrifices with
rook h6 and knight takes g6 why not and
uh
checkmate yeah exactly i see i feel like
rochelle
is on the back foot coming out of this
opening and i think uh zoe surprised her
looks nice for white
i mean as soon as you castle and
double up i mean it's a pleasant
sacrifice right right
i didn't sacrifice
oh that is bad news i thought that
actually white is upon down no no no no
no no
[Applause]
no no bad news that is bad news uh quick
check in on alice lee anybody who has
their own uh you know channel i mean got
my respect and you do it at 13 alice pal
pawn palace
um well i must say i like uh white's
position here central pawn duo in the
middle of the board what's not to like
white's for choice
alice is not getting the position she
wants trompovsky
you got it according to a book uh
shout out to edward winter he's a great
chess historian i went down there's a
little bit of a rabbit hole but the
opening was apparently named after
octavio cicero trompovsky one-time
brazilian champion played it often in
the 30s and 40s
that's off to october absolutely hats
off to edward winter too i love his uh
website chess history dot com it's it's
just fascinating uh the chess history
and it is an enormous enormous chess
history you can get lost there totally
like like the whole weekend goes to the
weekend
it's not it's not a few hours
i feel like you go through the fridge
you grab a beer and like it's like four
a.m and if you pick one you're reading
about the most random chess historical
facts but you're mesmerizing you're
really mesmerized brazilian speaking of
chess history guys today's the 50th
anniversary there you go the beginning
of uh the fisher versus pesky match july
11 1972
wow where were you 50. i remember very
vividly actually because i was in
virginia beach virginia my family was
moving from virginia beach virginia to
seattle virginia beach virginia was
marvelous for me i was a surfer
lifeguard
and when i went to seattle it was like
winter
it wasn't the summer it was a cold wet
winter
and then uh
i was stuck indoors and that's how i
became a chess player
the the good old school if it's too cold
outside we must play chess right it was
raining it was too you can't go out and
go running or anything play play
football so and then it just happened to
be bobby fischer versus boris baskey and
i was stunned at how
fascinating
chess was i just like fell right into it
right away and uh fortunately i had a
group of friends who liked to study the
games and i would
analyze with them great stuff 50 years
wow 50 years a long time it sure went by
fast what where no what were you asking
what was i doing in the 1972 match
my dad was graduating in high school
dude
i get it i get it that was like four
years of age
look what i have to deal with over here
folks it's pretty tough it's it's tough
okay um
now now i got thrown off where was i
going jennifer you i just wanted to yeah
she did end up playing rookie one and
not going for that uh
queenie two i think she wants to put a
rook in front of her queen pardon me
rook in front of her queen with rook to
e4 um
great compensation
but
i don't see this as being any advantage
white though like let's say i play rook
f5
like i play rook f5 you play rookie four
and everybody just builds up right
what you're saying is that we're just
gonna get stuck exactly
yeah you you you actually accelerated
where i was going but we just get stuck
you kind of see it coming i think that's
the issue when you're at gm and you
think okay there's three pieces for each
side
and all three of these pieces have a
very obvious best square right
right yeah like what black only has one
half open file you put everybody on the
half open file right and then white
house one half open file you're doing
everybody the other half open file and
you just and then you kind of still and
then you kind of get stuck right because
even the end game as long as you don't
mathematically lose a pawn right
draw it's just a draw yeah okay we'll
keep our eye on that game uh what about
larry christensen and the seniors uh
let's take a look how has he looked at
another in a while actually
declined
by the way queen's gambit declined with
queen c2 oh my god uh
most often as c takes d5 bishop d3 but
queen c2 rook c1 is another move
old school
takes takes takes takes
bishop d3 h6
i don't know this knight takes d5 but
okay
but it's interesting that larry ends up
playing h7 h6 because right here one of
the three
is h6 for free because everybody plays
bishop h4 and you get the same position
with the additional tempo of h6 that did
not happen instead we have this position
first
blush
white's a little bit better or i mean
better development rooks are already
connected it looks like a nicer version
of the usual right the usual is some
kind of tension c5 d4 in a queen's
gambit right white's better developed
than usual
knights on d7 and e7 don't cause a great
impression no and
well on the other hand you did simplify
a pair of bishops but yeah and how do
you
improve a position one of the i remember
i think i kind of fell for some
some weird thing where i thought i was
doing really well
and uh winning
and i got hit with this oh god i felt
like such an idiot happens right
so you don't get the brake d5 but you do
get to play bishop e4 and bish bishop
check
i i always thought that was very
sophisticated
and then you get your king your
opponent's king to go to the h8 square
does it ever matter though never never
but with understanding you make the move
and it never turns out to be anything
much that you force the king to hha
that's just great stuff proper technique
right but the proper technique uh but
you said you wanted to see the game of
shibala i wanted to see the game about
kopian but it actually didn't go
anywhere uh i was hoping
yeah with igor i was hoping he took the
pawn on d5 but he didn't he shied away
from the complications oh no yeah a bit
unfortunate so now we have this isolated
pawn position which is
it's just a game a black spine it almost
looks like one of those knight d2 french
fries
but a terrible version for white right
yeah nothing special
you know you've still got to decide what
this dark square bishop is going to do
how
how is this piece going to get effective
i know you're going to play rookie one
but black's play is very quick very easy
as well for
rooks rush to the center
and bishop to g4 so i think igor
uh tricked vladimir out of the opening
and is a fine position i think sometimes
it's just the move orders right you
present the challenge
as white you're not super comfortable
taking on a challenge that you know your
opponent just looked at and you probably
haven't looked in like 35 years
so maybe not the time to dust the old
theory
exactly and he decides to go for a
position in which he's not better let's
be honest he's just not better he's
wasted the advantage of white but in
return he's obtained a playable position
absolutely and again let's go to the
game of shabbalah versus
mr gurvich
uh mr gurvich is sacrificed upon and i
see that this is all
in the databases i mean how deep
do our databases go night back to c6
that's a curious little move right well
you played knight e5 and then you
retreated it right back
huh it does have a threat
unlike you know
vaguely isolated the pawns knight takes
d4 pawn
queen takes e2 is actually
a piece right so you need to do
something three
knight takes pawn takes
notice that this rook is pinning the
knight and queen takes e2
that's an easy
that's an easy piece to blunder i don't
think he will of course i mean but it is
uh
um
why
knight five queen e5 i know but i think
i think i think d2 is hanging at the end
right bishop takes f5 queen takes f5 oh
thank you bishop h2 and queen and rock
on c8 is not hanging right
i didn't see that
but i knew you didn't buy it
you don't you don't hang the rooks
and you can throw queen d6 check
exciting stuff uh here suddenly
your queen is not trapped of course
queen takes d2 it's actually annoying
right it's not only not trapped it's
actually quite annoying because it's
sort of like it gets into your position
yeah not like how do you how do you get
it to go out christian we're going to
turn it over to you we're having too
much fun on our end what have you been
uh looking at i've been having a lot of
fun uh as well looking at this position
and ways in which it could develop and
once again my speech was uh
ready and he played a different move a
completely different move than what i
expected i was looking at this bishop to
b2 which was played and after that just
simply develop the pieces normally right
how do you do that bishop to e2 right it
makes a lot of sense castle castle rook
to e8 right you play d5 to open up the e
file put some pressure on the square e4
and get this extra tempo right with the
move rook to e8 on the knight and i was
looking at the position
and it does seem like if white has to go
back to f3 black is most likely going to
be just fine knight to c6 comes on the
board whenever you go d4 that closes up
your bishop and also i get to place the
knight on e4 i have quite nice control
over the e file but
i have a lot more options than just
simply knight to f3 that's very natural
knight to f3 knight to d3 seems to
actually be the better trajectory but
this is not what i liked about the
position what i liked about the position
is that you can
sacrifice a piece
knight takes f7 take advantage of the
fact that there's no more pawns on a
df-file you got rid of that when it took
on e3 king takes f7 and now c5 check
this out i'm opening up all the
diagonals the a2 ga diagonal towards the
black king so for example if you take i
go queen to c2 in fact first targeting
the bishop then taking advantage of the
pin i'm going to take on h7 and then my
bishop is going to come to h5 this is
not looking good check this out the rook
is attacking the bishop is attacking the
queen is going to be very close to the
king and then the bishop is going to
come to attack as well the black king is
in big trouble with only a knight around
himself so
bishop to c7 for example again we see
this type of crazy variations bishop to
e6 queen to h5 everything is just simply
coming with tempo rook takes f6 i was
having a lot of fun with this variation
i'll tell you that take on f6 bishop
takes f6
yes you are a rook down for the moment
but look at the naked king right a lot
of things to calculate it seems like
none of this unfortunately is going to
happen or maybe it will but in a
different version because white played
the move a takes b4 which makes a lot of
sense as well
can you take back on b4 absolutely not
queen to a4 is coming and that's just
going to win a piece right so
how do you recapture the pawn from upon
down the bloomfield gambit
now i'm upon up right so
what just happened in this position
i guess
it's some sort of a counter gambit
right
full counter gambit uh a very
interesting development in this one
castle most likely were is going to be
seen on the board now you do threaten
take on b4 if i play the move uh bishop
to it or at least that's an option but
even though bishop thinks before it does
feel like you're losing a lot of
momentum right so material balance is
restored nevertheless after castle
followed by this idea of knight to d3
all of my pieces seem
ready and poised to create a vicious
attack against your king specifically on
this uh f6 point of contact in black's
position so
it's not looking good for black i have
to say and if you don't take back on b4
you're going to be upon down and
what's your compensation where is your
compensation in the position because i
have the center i have uh the flank
attack on the queen side and the king
side i don't like it for black
whatsoever and let's take a look i mean
christopher you dominating the event up
to this point three and a half out of
four well he could be entering uh our
rest day on four and a half a massive
plus four score if he wins today
against balaji pati and for balaji i'll
win
catapults him right up into the lead so
you're absolutely right a very very
big consequence
for both players
this game
takes on b4 i i've
kind of preferred bishop e2 and castles
speed yeah yeah
i like the development i like that by
the way in the game between alexander
shabalath and dimitri girvich shabala
i've heard you the bishop on he said he
too
needed some defending and uh
shabba played
rook on f1 to e1 inviting knight takes
d4 pawn takes d4 and then this bishop is
a little liberated and don't forget once
again that white's the one uh with the
pawn in the pocket and dimitri has to
prove his compensation
alejandro what do you have for us uh so
i don't actually check for the game so i
was thinking wesley
[Laughter]
the candidates man i'm still tasered
sorry wesley was not in the country i
think that's not even in the candidates
either wesley
i wanted to take a look at the game of
rochelle
i don't actually analyze very often with
engines
that was the
the trump right the trumpovsky yeah and
a couple of things first of all yeah we
don't analyze with agency we give it to
christian but we have so many games
sometimes i take a quick look sure at
what's going on
and i want to i like pointing out when
we're like that off
wrong right dead wrong
because rochelle played this move b5 say
what and the move b5 to me looks like a
huge
strategical mistake because you're
you're kind of weakening all of your
dark squares
maybe maybe even yeah
some horrible horrible things yeah
knight b3 somehow
they could be a dark square right but
that's not the point what you were going
to say what i'm going to say is that the
computer thinks that b5 is the best move
and blocks better
damn i know right right
you know alejandro
there was a time
when i was a young chess player when i
realized
i didn't understand chess
but
after decades of hard study
i now realize i'm no longer young
it's true i mean black's better yeah i i
just played around with the engine for a
little bit and it was explaining to me
i go castle and you go i want to we can
put this in the nozzle i want to play
what i
yeah no i i totally got it right and
then the engine comes up with this plan
and a5 a5 right okay
so that works somewhere
you're making a statement i guess and
then the defensive resources rook a7
rook g7
and once you get there white's kind of
stuck
so knight takes g6 it just doesn't work
it just yeah yeah i don't know i it just
doesn't work yeah clear okay
i mean i can win some ponds but that my
intention of course was
this and what you just said was that the
rook
does an incredibly good job at just stop
you're not going anywhere you're not
going anywhere and at some point i'll
get in a four b4 maybe i'll get a knight
e4
and your pieces look very pretty
all dressed up all dressed up
no break no sacrifice
wow no f3 g4
wow uh
i couldn't be more surprised yeah i i'm
not surprised as you are because i look
at this position i think white is about
to crash through right i fed it into
into the engine it's minus one and the
engine just says no no the defense holds
you got no attack forget about it
wow uh crazy right right and zoe did
castle by the way it's a logical plan
you can't blame that style of play this
is exactly what i would have done with
the white pieces as well exactly oh my
gosh
and sophie was i mentioning i was asking
about tromposky and i got a message on
my phone shout out to leonardo
he's actually here in st louis uh so we
hope to have him for the second half as
he's helping us with the dgt boards
great and what did leonard say oh he was
giving me the information of who the
brazilian
[Laughter]
thank you for that one um
sophie
how are we doing uh sophie
five five let's go
f5 whoa said that's a ln that's
committal i'm not waiting for you to
play bishop b2 to e5 f5 attacking the
queen queen went to c4 king h8
and men talk about a telegraph shot
alan is winding up for e 6 e5 followed
by e4 don't forget h2 could be a
potential target what do you think about
this
aggression i want to say by ellen can it
pay off her or is it too risky my
impression
again without using an engine right
right my impression is that this is
rushed
i usually find that if black plays f5
and e5
without already having the bishop on b
or d7
right and the rook supporting with aa a
e8 or d8 it doesn't matter but as long
as the rook is active before this
happens
white usually has more than enough
resources okay to gain an advantage you
trade off an important bishop you
establish a bind on c5 somehow you take
the oomph out of e5 e4 and what's left
behind is a lot of weaknesses right so
my first impression is that this is
rushed i would have liked to see
something like bishop b7 or d7 instead
of f5 i didn't feel if i was necessary
just back here just a moment ago after
the move b3 you kind of feel like bishop
followed by c5 or something like this
yeah if you're going to play f5 put your
rook on e8 first first right okay but
now i haven't said that yeah
you got to back it up with uh with
actual moves right with a move because i
i understand what you mean like the
knight could end up you know like let's
just put a move on the board for just a
second and the knight could end up
um
finding some squares queen could end up
going to h4 and maybe you've rushed
maybe you've rushed out yeah oh sorry i
did it the wrong way i wanted to go
queen to h5
and i wanted to do something like this
but i mean
maybe i've rushed right
yeah you can even ask for a move like
rook a d1 after e5 okay bishop b2 e5
rook ad1 yeah and i understand that i'm
losing a pawn after e4
knight g5
check are you losing upon i'm d4 i'm not
even losing
d6 is hanging i could play queen d4 but
i wanted to throw in yeah
justin just just to point in the the
idea
that uh
without development this is this is the
bottom line this is the bottom line i
haven't developed and
this could actually end up lost yeah it
could be it could not be you have to
calculate these things out but what ends
up happening very often is that since
you're not developed and there's a lot
of weak diagonals there's a lot of
there's a weak background there's a
weeknight f7 checks mother made hanging
exactly that you might
actually be in trouble exactly this is
the weak back rank smothered me that's
weird let's wait for the analysis board
there sure
guys just to give you kind of uh an idea
of how difficult chess is because we
always talk about that and
some of our audience might be like no
you guys are gm's i mean you guys should
know what's happening in the position
but
chess is so difficult for us for pretty
much everybody but take a look at this
after queen to c4 and you guys
for a good reason were looking at bishop
to b2 right bishop to b2 this seems like
the most natural way sure and after e5
try to make something out of these
complications right but
white has a much better alternative and
that is to focus right now that you
committed to this move f6 and you no
longer have
the potential of um for example let's
just make some moves like this f6 and
going into this position once we
exchange the dark square bishops where i
have a very solid center in the absence
of the dark square bishop so this is the
key difference between this position
which is perfectly fine for black and
the position with the pawn already on f5
that's why the computer is
recommending bishop to e3 and in fact
it's giving white a tremendous advantage
the plan is very easy i'm going to go
bishop to c5 followed by rook to d1 and
now that the pawn is already on f5 your
whole position collapses because the
bishop on c8 is going to be locked and
you're going to have huge holes on the
dark squares specifically this hole on
e5 so you have to go e5 yourself first
but once again bishop to c5 and now we
see in the absence of the dark square
bishops your pawn structure is going to
be an easy target for my pieces bishop
b3 bishop c5 definitely not something
that you're looking necessarily at after
you just play the move b3 right right b3
usually follows bishop to b2 but if she
stops and understands the consequences
of the sequence specifically the move f5
and the weakness that it creates on the
dark squares maybe this idea of bishop
to e3 bishop c5
will come
her way
that's a beautiful transfer of ideas
they're
the the long diagonal so compelling that
the moment you see bishop c5 alejandro
stop the presses i want to put the
vision on c5 i love that i love that for
uh
sophie
this could be plus five this could be
plus five we really like her position
already and she's shown
great prep she found this really
fun and interesting line to play against
rochelle yeah and and today i meant
sorry big one but also today i feel that
we didn't think much of her opening as
far as a theoretical value right but she
shows so far that she's understanding
this position is better than her
opponent and that's part of preparation
absolutely part of preparation is not
just memorizing the moves here and there
it's actually understanding where the
pieces go and what you're doing with
them and the idea is behind them and
there she is
sophie maurice suzuki
perfect yeah 20 years young from new
york 2017 new york girls state champion
composes music as well
fantastic uh outstanding uh as we get
ready to go to break uh what's happening
at cubeot what's happening is in front
of you baby premium 20-inch final
roll-up board very nice featuring the
official logos of the 2022 junior girls
junior or
senior championships you have them at
the h1 and a8 yes i got you done the
wrong
i got them on the wrong diagonal there
you go there they are there they are
they're standard squares perfect for the
on-the-go and travel you can help us out
and order them at q cubitiquestl.com
wonderful and we'll see you on the other
side of this break because we asked the
players what they they think of the
club's great big expansion and here's
their answers
the chess club is expanding are you
excited for what's about to come and
what do you think the impact of that
will be on american chess well it's uh
it's got a great
great reputation worldwide now um st
louis is a real chess capital
and um i'm impressed by all the
infrastructure and restaurants and
of the museum um and the general
awareness of chess around here
i'm pretty impressed
i think it's really nice because i mean
um in my opinion at least st louis the
same with the check club is like one of
the most prestigious events i mean it
takes really good care of its players
and i think it's a great thing that it's
expanding even bigger yeah i think it's
just it's really wonderful um the vision
um that rex and everyone that works here
has for chess um just growing growing
the game and you know the passion
and dedication that you know all the st
louis staff here have um i'm really
thankful that you know
i've been able to as a junior um
sort of rise with the assistance of st
louis and be able to play in such a
wonderful atmosphere i think you know
every time i come here
i always really look forward to it i'm
really excited to play here i think it's
really good because i think just with
this going on it's gonna bring more
tournaments here and they're gonna be
bigger and bring more attention and i
hope boom just keeps going absolutely
it uh
did already humongous effect on the
chest i think uh
professional chests in america would be
in completely different shape without
some bluish it's just basically
you know like almost the whole chest
life is concentrated right here
oh i love the the expansion of the club
it's it's amazing and it's it's
definitely very very good for for us
chessy the conditions here are amazing
compared to
other parts especially compared to other
parts of the country it's really nice to
come here and have great conditions play
one game a day a rest day great prize
fun i love it
it's fabulous and also that you're in
such a prime spot great places around
it's just a place anybody wants to be
even if they don't play chess now i'm
excited to see what the uh st louis
chess club is going to do with it um
because they've already done so much
with like um promoting us chess with
like all these amazing tournaments so if
a bigger space i mean who knows what
they can bring out here oh it's
wonderful i think it's great capital of
saint louis is great capital of chess in
the united states and i'm playing this
club and it's probably one of the best
places to play chess
players are taken care of and it's
atmosphere it's
where it just just selects it should be
always like that but it's very rarely
like that it's amazing the chess club is
beautiful the plant conditions are
fantastic and so i'm very grateful to
have this opportunity to be playing here
i think it's great for american chefs
like so many of our top tournaments are
held here at the st louis chess club
so i'm really excited to see what this
expansion can do in terms of
having more events
well it's really amazing um
you know it seems like i come here every
year and every year it looks different
um but i just can't wait to see the
finished product when all that space is
operational
and uh so i'm just really on pins and
needles like you know wanting to see
more
every time i come here it's actually
pretty surprising to see like
they've conquered like another place
like another square
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everybody we're here round
five the day before the red day in our
championships in st louis in the junior
girls section sophie moyes suzuki
starting with a blistering four out of
four is now facing ellen wang and we
like her position today very much so it
might be five for five can't you do it
just find out in the juniors we have
great matchup but our highlights i
believe will be
mishra against hong as well as
christopher you leader of the tournament
against balaji daku patti absolutely and
in the seniors in the senior section
larry christensen is our leader he has
three points and he is facing with the
black pieces an old rival of his joel
benjamin and at the moment i like joel's
position so larry
will have to prove himself as he stays
in the lead i wanted to turn our
attention as we're jumping right back in
anna marie uh has overlooked a nice
tactic and alice lee i think is about to
jump on the situation
um
it's a funny moment right here as we get
this position she did play knight c5 by
the way
knight d4
queen um
a6
and she's thinking that you know i'm not
afraid of the move e5 i'm not afraid of
the move e5 because i will answer it
knight to f5 attacking the bishop
on e7 so she played knight
um
d2 to f3 prepping her own e5 but she's
overlooked the tactic that alice is
quick to spot knight to c5 attacks the
queen when the queen moves backwards for
example queen to c2 knight d3 er
that's an important fork and there goes
the exchange so alice is about to win
material in her game after the move
knight c5 an easy tactic to overlook as
you're kind of myopically looking at
your own
e5 what do you have for us alejandro um
well that was a big update that was it
[Laughter]
something for us excellent well i i
don't think you guys talked about uh
more
sophie mori suzuki is that true
the move that she found we were talking
about this move bishop to e3 has been a
very difficult move to find
she found it she played it and she might
be going towards five out of five
because right now black is having a very
difficult position bishop to c5 is a
very easy move to make if you played
bishop to e3 you know you're going to
follow it up with this exchange of the
bishop's proposition with bishop to c5
can you stop that with the move c5 well
the problem is that right now we're
starting to see a lot of tactics in the
position rook fd1 or rook 81 for that
matter it doesn't really matter rook
takes d6 is going to come on the board
now we see the tactics in the position
for example if you go bishop to b7 rook
takes d6 queen d6 bishop takes c5 i'm a
pawn up i'm going to regain my exchange
and you're still going to have some very
weak squares around e5 and the central
dark squares are in your position so
bishop to e3
looking really good for sophie
right now and i was looking at
the juniors as well and what's happening
in that uh tournament and uh at this
point after rook two eight eight takes
before rook two e8 was played
christopher decided to go knight to f3
once again the most
probably practical choice in the
position because it is difficult to make
the move knight to d3 and allow this
onslaught that's coming your way
nevertheless it is actually just
completely winning for white right
because i have to move knight to f4
covering everything up and now
with an open uh long diagonal you still
have to lose a tempo to regain your pawn
and everything is coming in play
harmoniously for uh white queen to c2
bishop to f3 is going to follow up
you dedicated so many of your pieces to
the attack on the king side but it
didn't go anywhere so
right now unfortunately it does seem
like white uh is in full control
probably a winning position from a
practical perspective he did not do that
he played the move knight to f3 and
after bishop to b4 i have to say
with the knight on f3 instead of d3 and
coming to f4
the position is completely different
right now and also the assessment is
very different um it does seem like
white still harbors a slight advantage
nevertheless it's not as much as it was
if
he would have played knight to d3 still
i have to give it to christopher in
terms of assessment white is still
better exactly thank you uh christian
alejandra maybe we can analyze while
we're at the juniors the game between
abi manu mishra and andrew hung it's
important for the standings and some big
things have changed where is that the
second game okay
uh
white has somehow sacrificed a pawn
with this break on d4
all right and has obtained some kind of
immediate pressure
on d5 and i'm wondering how good is
white's position here this is the
current position
um i'll be mind you up on the clock by a
significant amount almost 30 minutes
he's down a pawn currently though uh i
assume that he can regain it in more
than one way but
show me yeah right well uh
one visual like my eye let me let me
just put it that way it was i was
thinking of c4 uh d4 queen c3 that was
the visual
oh wow that's pretty yeah i win the pawn
back so c4 i think is one choice but
then i start to think
well rook g5 bishop h3
am i giving my opponent a free hand on
the king side after c4
i'm assuming
maybe
i do that i don't know well how do you
how do you specifically do this like
okay let's let's find out right moves
right
exactly
i'd love to be able to play a move like
queen h4 but the only way i'm playing
queen h4 is if my knight's gone so
knight g4 i
don't think i want to allow knight takes
d5 okay sorry uh uh actual moves let's
let's make an actual move
bishop to g4 tickling the rook all right
i don't
really want to take on g4 allow your
knight to come in that's what i was
hoping yeah maybe knight takes knight
takes i i kind of follow it up
my my rook looks a little puzzling but
but if it ever does get to h5 it's
actually useful right so maybe you're a
little reluctant to capture my bishop
maybe i go rook d4
very attractive move by posting up
um
my goodness i i feel like i've
i got to get my pieces into play i try
to make it as awkward as possible for
you to win back your pawn as i'm tr i'm
trying to coordinate attack i don't know
what's going on i think white's got
i like play right yeah hard to say
exactly you'll get your pawn on d5 back
it's not even so clear what i'll end up
taking with there are so many situations
i just sidestepped the pongal queen d2
and d and c5 right yeah very very nice
if you can pick up the pawn positionally
now having said that i don't think
andrew did anything wrong i mean great
congratulations you should play d4 right
one second please just simply take on d5
after bishop g4 no just right now
instead of c4 yeah
that was a more direct way of getting
the bond back but
i don't we didn't know if we needed it
so why not i mean let's look at this
pawn yeah okay spawn
c4 sure and it's check on d8 so i don't
have time to do knight takes before or
knight takes e3 check is check check is
check you have to respect that and the
problem is that bishop b6 i can take on
d5 and you cannot recapture back because
of queen to c5 that's clear you're tied
up
but i thought if you take with the pawn
and i retreat with the bishop to d7
how do we feel about that with that pawn
landing on d6 i don't know i
i i'd sure like to make a uh
i don't want you to capture on d5 with
tempo
i'd sure like to bring my pieces out but
this knight on e3
it bugs me that i can't play a move like
queen here and bishop h3 uh threatening
mate the knight is very well and i can
just simply take with the rook actually
now weaken the pawn on e4 for yourself
as well okay
i'm not sure if i want to take with the
knight
bishop thanks queen e4
okay and now if you go bishop h3 queen
e4 is a problem exactly unfortunately i
have to play um
a lesser move bishop f5 yeah but you
start looking at
i like white i like white you like look
at the structure and just start liking
white exactly
i might even start to think you know
what i should just
play yeah like some kind of a bail like
this
where
bishop five there is a funny variation
actually yes if you get too greedy and
you play the move f3 and say that oh you
take on f3 i take on f5 and i win a
piece
no no no no
but it is a nice fork i mean and
unfortunately 97 first doesn't work
either because you go queen takes c7
oh man nothing works
nothing works that's not good bishop
takes but don't get too greedy right
don't don't get too greedy you don't
have to no also i think i can take with
the pawn i really like taking with the
pawn
i like the pawn actually i like this
knight on e3 i know this knight on e3 is
really really uh quinte c4 is still a
problem that you have to deal with so
exactly and queen e5 now i'm looking at
some forks after knight to c4
knight to c4 queen takes d5 knight b6
thank you very much that is a nice fork
of the queen and the rook no question
about it
whoops
okay so it looks very pleasant right
andrew is being asked some very salient
questions and that started from the move
bishop takes d5 which begs the question
should i be even capturing the bishop
great you've got you you won your pawn
back let me just
i don't know i'll make a move queen c7
looks like he's ready to make a move by
the way he's ready to make a move is he
ready to capture the pawn that's the
question yeah and there it goes bishop
takes d5 is on the board okay uh let's
continue this line for just a moment
queen c7
by andrew you you've won your pawn back
okay no harm no foul but i'm eyeballing
i'm going to keep my knight
and i'm eyeballing the move rook h5 and
yes i do want to sacrifice my bishop on
h3 but how dangerous is that yeah sir
let's go c4
wow okay yeah you threw down the
gauntlet and
boy i can sacrifice other people's
pieces as good as anybody
all right let's look at the cage i can
play g3 but let's go h3 i don't believe
in this no let's go h3 i'm i'm i'm
losing my my i'll give you everything
you want i'll give you everything you
want you think you can uh
you think i'll take on e4 you know you
you taught me well yes sir
just just take all the take all the
goods huh i mean that knight on e3 is a
brilliant defender bishop's not bad
either i mean this is just a check on h2
and that's about it
that's it just to check on h2
friendly one too
no harm no foul wow well i've in that
game of zoe i already had
gotten tasered and queen c7 is on the
board
okay okay he's intimating that he's got
threats whether they're real or not
well the problem is that okay queen 7 is
a normal move right right just getting
off the off the d file right but after
c4 rook h5 is already a very committal
decision right because you are moving
all your forces on that side and if your
attack is not successful then you're
actually in deep danger of losing the
pawn on e4 and just losing the game
exactly
i i don't like it c4 i really like this
move right now you guys may be
bamboozling me i i i i'm i'm surprised
that you would allow me to do this okay
and let me put my rook
i i i hear you loud and clear by the way
that bishop on g2
that's
that's yesterday
i'm going to make one what's the place
we're going to give up what's the plan i
was going to go rook h3 mate okay g2
no way come on
come on you can't okay h1 come on this
is nothing i don't believe you at all
right you have nothing oh wait wait wait
here no here no that i take with a pawn
that's fine you have nothing no no it's
nothing
you don't have any pieces
since he was defended you lucky
you lucky guy
he he almost said he almost
lost the thieves but i did it you did
but i didn't
mastery mastery chess mastery keep your
pieces defended the knight on e3
is doing a great job uh he he suddenly
oh no i forgot that because if you think
with the knight first you actually lose
a piece yes yeah exactly if you go night
takes then i do have rook takes intro
wow okay well we'll keep an eye on this
one i wanted to go to the game between
brandon
and a wonder because
again they were the number one and
number two seed coming into this event
if you would look at the pairings at the
start of the tournament you say aha
those two guys play each other in round
five and that could decide first place
what's going on
the funny thing about brandon as a
player is that he is a studious one he
definitely has a lot of interesting
ideas in the opening we saw it already
twice in the djoko piano he's finding
this idea that's very recent as well in
the catalan
but once he gets out of theory himself
it's like he just gets stuck he was the
one that proposed the variation he knew
the variation he knew e3 he knew h4
but he's down on time compared to a
wonder
and he was actually down only by three
minutes though right but i wonder i mean
he was the one surprised by the opening
and right brandon has to make has made
like two moves on his own
i mean i think rook fe1 was the first
move he actually thought of
up to this by the way where where is the
novelty in this game and that is
actually the one between justin wang and
david brotzky on the screen that we're
seeing right now not the one we're
talking about oh the the yeah we'll get
there this is good okay
i wonder not knight b1 yeah knight b1 is
an idea that i saw also in the other
game the one that i was mentioning
previously between theodora yuyangi yeah
um which is
basically where you get this idea from
knight b1 the idea is that yeah you gave
black a
better structure because now you have a
double pawn but because your pawns are
not on the way especially this button is
not on e3 the pawn and f4 i mean
you actually get access to some squares
you don't normally get access to like e5
you don't you get access to the e file
in general
um
and you're not so afraid of playing f3
sometimes yeah 95 is a move you can take
on d4 i with the knight with the knight
i think both sides have chances
uh but i like this uh bishop somehow
posting up uh
i see good squares for black's pieces
and i'm not uh
i'm not unhappy here uh alejandra i
think in general the
entire play is based on the fact that
everybody has good pieces except for
black's bishop on p7 and if you can keep
that
a little bit under control i understand
but it is supporting the fact that
it's not so easy for you to coordinate
an attack against my d5 pawn and uh the
bishop on b7 you're right it's a little
bit passive but uh
doing some good work well we'll keep an
eye on this game as knight takes d4 in
fact on the board and christian
any games caught your eye
well uh the game of talia uh versus
gracie prasanna is quite interesting
because we have some sort of a benoni
situation right now and a lot of things
are most likely going to happen in the
next few moves because
this move f5 came on the board setting
up a lot of tension in the center of
course you cannot well you can actually
in this case take on f5 but generally
you should be very careful about rook
takes e3 you cannot recapture because of
bishop to d4 of course in this specific
case if rook takes c3 comes on the board
then the e on g6 would actually win the
game for white so after taking on f5 you
have to take back either with the bishop
or the pawn and you still have to worry
about this move rook takes e3 a lot of
tension that i'm seeing right now in the
position rook 28 is the last move on the
board 48 minutes for gracie and talia
who escaped miraculously yesterday with
the black pieces against rochelle wu
right now with 49 minutes a very complex
position i like the way this game is
developing and i think we're going to
see a lot of fireworks in this one now i
was quite shocked i have to say about
this position's assessment i thought
that white has an advantage right right
but not
1.4
right now so this is a very significant
advantage not only that but after c4 if
you go rook to h5 it's starting to
already increase one point seven getting
closer to two this is a decision
h3 bishop h3 is nonsense right oh yeah
completely
bishop
you guys were falling for it i don't
forget about bishop
nonsense
i had you both netted no it's not great
i was about to surprisingly it's not
that bad okay
it's
it's still decisive advantage but it's
not like plus four or anything
complement it's not that bad it's not
that bad it's only plus two which is
it's pretty significant
nevertheless the point being that
if you don't go for this rook to h5 then
what do you do yeah what is your next
move exactly once again and we discussed
about this at the beginning of the show
this pawn on a3 simply became a
liability because your rook on a8 is
going to be tied after this idea of c c4
followed by queen to c3 setting up the
attack on the pawn on a3 the rook on e8
is stuck to the defense of that pawn if
you do give me that i will have a
dominant majority three versus one we
know those type of uh majorities are
extremely dangerous and pretty much
decisive in any end game
so after c4 i'm looking at the position
and i know abimanu is looking at this
move it makes a lot of sense it's a very
natural progression of your last uh few
moves
it's looking good for abby money he
might be scoring is this his third
victory if he manages to win this one in
a row he beat a wonder a wonder pedro
yesterday yeah and has the potential of
beating another one of the players that
started off blazing hot andrew honk two
and a half out of three but right now
cooling off significantly after
yesterday's defeat that's true right i
just have to say that it's funny looking
at the games of talia talia likes the
four pawns attack against the king's
indian defense and no matter what she
plays it seems to mean that she's always
getting a kind of a four pawns attack
against whatever it is her opponent is
doing so nice
just insight there uh i think
uh
in the game of alice lee
um
bishop takes dc6
what
hold on
i was going to say alice was winning a
lot of material
but i didn't think she was going to be
winning this much bishop takes d6
why can i not take this bishop right
that's
a very good question right e5
i can just take only one i guess you're
still up only the exchange anyway
gosh you but it's a full exchange but it
is a full exchange yeah but i was
actually thinking it was going to even
be like oh look i think it's just the
experience it's just the exchanges
you take on b5 yeah bishop b8
okay is this an exchange exactly i mean
this is an easy version of an exchange
here simplify the position so much true
i think you probably want to start with
queen takes a6 after bishop takes d6
i mean you can just to mess up my points
right fair fair fair queen takes a6
yeah this might not be the worst version
for white right you take on e1 you got
to take back on e1 agreed
and i'll move my bishop
and i'll take upon it it's still
decisive
it has to be decided right it's just an
exchange um let's just turn to the
seniors well before we do that i
don't think we should stay with the
juniors because this game is uh of high
importance the ones between karissa eep
and pedro espinosa and
you guys were touting the black lion and
it sounds dangerous but i wasn't
nothing i said i never heard of it
this lion is toothless hairless and i
mean without food he's not doing
absolutely anything right now i mean
check this out bishop to h7 finally you
managed to castle yeah and you spent so
much uh so many resources so many
tempest to get that point because this
battery was just accommodating you and
you had to go 90 to knight f3 knight h4
lost a lot of tempest to finally be able
to castle and now after rook to d8 the
perfect setup right that's what we're
talking about black uh d4 came on the
board e takes d4 knight takes d4 sure
let's exchange some pieces take on d4
bishop to d6 i'm looking at the position
and it is only black that can be better
clear you put a queen on d2 he's going
to get targeted with knight to knight to
e4 so what do you do next move actually
knight to e4 most likely comes no matter
what you do i just have so much space on
both sides and i'm looking at your
pieces this bish pawn g2 is going to get
closed up after the move c6 the bishop
b2 is already closed up by your own pawn
i have space advantage on both sides i
already have my rooks set up on the
central files and you don't even have a
good way to make the connection between
the rooks because once again quinto d2
is going to be met by knight to e4 maybe
after defending the pawn on a5
it's not looking good
neither it is easy for white to find a
clear plan in the position this is why
i'm a little bit um well suspicious of
carissa yipp's play and strategy all
together in this game
all right
definitely we'll keep an eye on that one
but i wanted to turn to the seniors as i
saw that dmitry gurvich had sacrificed
the pawn how is it going for him
aleandro looks good let's take a look at
the position that we have right now this
is of course shabala versus gurevich we
had gotten here we've seen
that's the wrong move that's not what i
wanted to do
uh we saw the move rook e1 that was
where we left it right yes
here it comes there you go
all right so now queen e5 we have a
bunch of moves let's just update what's
happened g3 bishop g4 looks normal
knight takes rook takes looks normal a
lot of space on the king side queen h5 i
guess you have bishop c1 okay right dca
looks normal okay a4 h6 loft i guess
luft
t3
what bishop takes h
rook d6 didn't work last move did it
no because the rook's not defended on e1
okay all right so he plays rook d3 brook
takes d6 ideas of e5 yeah but as you
were saying yes rook to d3 bishop a3
boom
challenge challenge
actually he declared it
is it um
wait a second yes it's kind of hard yeah
so you take on
a3 right then you take on e2 i assume
that i think with the cool
with what do i take well if you take
with the rook i'm going to take twice on
c3 that's horrible right yeah so if you
take with the queen i take on c3 and
you maybe take on c3 i don't know if
that's forced
what would you prefer
i don't know if i prefer it i just say
that knight g4 deserves being looked at
question mark exclamation mark
uh knight g4 okay maybe that's a little
surprise maybe it just doesn't work f3
knight e5 but you have bishop d2
yes yeah that's simple enough i'm just
uh
yeah
okay so i guess you take on c3 all right
take on h5 take on h5 take on c3 take
now i got an issue yeah you have to take
right right
um
it looks a little bit offside but
not the end of the world
no no not at all it could play
looks equal-ish
yeah i don't see the problem there but i
i mean it feels like
wait a minute you know why can't i take
advantage of this can i play f3 and
start kicking your pieces back
i always have a check right that is true
that is annoying you do have a check
okay hmm that is
i'm i'm i'm feeling kind of surprised
yeah i mean you just played this move
bishop takes a3 and you've gone
you you you were attacking on the king
side that looks disharmony
it's not in harmony with your play
but i don't see a refutation to it at
the moment
bishop f4 and that most likely is just
going to lead to an equal position right
right
i'm
i'm i'm trying for an edge but i i i
don't see it what a christian
either christian no there there's no
edge actually
no no so bishop takes a3 is a surprising
move though right i mean when he played
rook on the shocker come on you're
defending the knight and the guy takes
upon a3 anyway anyway right
it's definitely a shocker but it doesn't
seem like white actually had a lot of
good ways in the position okay to uh
give me the blackout compensation full
compensation yes okay and after bishop
takes a3 it just seems like it forces
simplifications um take on e2 so you
take on a3 you take on e2 i think by f4
maybe bishop takes c2 and who's better
at that point exactly um
rook takes c3 we exchange and then we go
into this end game and maybe you have
like a very slight edge for the simple
fact that you have
rook and bishop versus rook and knight
but
i do have targets yep to uh to worry
about as white and i don't think there's
any advantage just played a move but it
didn't look like it was a yes it yes it
did you can't capture it
yeah so it might be going into that
equal-ish ending let's jump to the game
of larry christian
and the standings for
the seniors as guruwicz is remember uh
on second place right now shabbat
bouncing back from a loss against
vladimir akkopian with a win against
nick defermion finds himself in third
place tied for with a bunch of people 50
just jumping to the game of joel
benjamin larry christensen for a moment
we saw the move h7h6
castles we had actually gotten here we
thought that uh black still had to prove
equality knight f6
94
but from the game position that i'm
seeing
i think
larry will be very pleased with the
outcome of the opening this doesn't feel
like
he's got any worries here after all you
know he's already
got possession of the open
c file nothing nothing he's uh
absolutely he
he's neutralized everybody igor novikov
versus um
gregory kaidonov the they too have
played very quickly this looks like uh a
catalan this was a great one okay where
you're somehow you know like i don't
even have to vacuum i don't have to
check the opening this is ironian's
favorite line of the catalan right you
just you can just tell from the
structure the rig landing on d7 the fact
that something just took on b6 this has
to be that catalan that aronian plays
all the time exactly and i'm just saying
95 and 62. and trying equality yeah
absolutely equality there um what do you
have for us christian well staying with
the seniors a lot of things have
happened in this game between vladimir
kopian and igor malnitsky uh this one we
said that black was just perfectly fine
after the opening right right we were
considering him to have solved all of
his opening problems but it's not the
case especially in the way he played it
with this move bishop to g4 very natural
by the way you do want to set up this
pin the problem is i really like what
the koben did
g4 bishop to g6 knight to h4 and right
now at this point black missed his
chance to take on d3 not an easy
practical decision because in the
absence of the light square bishops this
knight is perfectly placed to jump to f5
not only that but also the queen is
coming to f3 it does feel like i have a
lot of pressure on the light squares
nevertheless this move queen to d5 is
very very important in the position
taking away the light squares queen to
b3 is no longer possible to put some
pressure on my pawn structure queen to
f3 is no longer possible either and
knight to f5 i'm just simply going to
challenge
you on the e file and in fact black
doesn't have any problems you have a
beautiful knight on f5 unfortunately you
don't have any support for it to create
any significant threats against my king
on g8 so big moment
allowing this bishop takes d3 but he did
not play bishop takes d3 what he did was
queen to f6 but after knight takes g6
and f4
the two bishops are nicely supporting a
potential attack on the king side right
and after king to h8 right now
white has the opportunity to play the
move g5 with devastating consequences it
feels like because after taking on g5 no
i'm not going to take back on g5 and
allow you to go queen to f2 and then
bishop to d6 and create checkmating
threats against my king i'm just simply
going to go queen to g4 with the idea of
rook e6 exactly if you take on f4 yeah
well you're getting checkmated on this
side bishop takes g6 queen to h5 queen
to h7 the game is actually over so you
cannot touch the pawn on f4 if you do go
rook a to e8 well sure we're going to
exchange now there's no more queen to f2
i don't even have to hurry with f takes
g5 which is good enough i can just
simply go rook to f1 and by the way
as we were discussing this game despite
its flashiness it's just a draw
yeah the equal end game there was
actually a perpetual found by both
players their queen sierra queen f5 at
the end drop between shabala van
gurevich
happened very quickly and back to what
you were saying no absolutely guys i
think this one right now after king2h8
if white finds and you don't even have
to find the move g5 you can play this
one slowly i still have the two bishops
i have a better structure i'm gaining
more space on this side and without in
the absence of the light square bishop
for white it doesn't seem like you can
get to my king in any way shape or form
so
i'm really liking the progression and
the trend for white for vladimir akopian
who might be if he manages to win this
one get his second victory in the event
and go to plus one
he's a dangerous man once he uh started
getting those pluses i'm telling you
that move g5 sure has my attention i
like that move a great deal and i think
that uh big advantage for
a copy and should he find g5 and queen
g4
uh delugey
well somehow once again nick and max
have neutralized the position don't see
any advantages there
earlier i'd actually like nick's
position this just feels uh
tepid yeah nothing much to talk about
there
um let's just jump to good luck to the
girls
once again i want to go to uh sophie
okay because this game is that dead
c5 yeah sophie finding all the good
moves so far taking a long time to do so
only worried about that 36 minutes for
the remaining 24 moves that's a lot of
moves until you look at the position
oh easy moves bishop takes d6 rook d1
i mean i can play these moves with just
seconds of my clock i like it for uh i
love our tournament uh leaders looking
really really good right every dark
square in the position is going to be
hers yeah exactly uh the moves play
themselves here excellent excellent prep
here
we had mentioned talia
and
uh she didn't take on
not too many moves here she didn't take
on e4 she played the move bishop d7 did
gracie
looks like a normal move to me the
preparing b5 at some point connecting
the rooks at some point right it looks
like a double-edged king's
indian
four bonds attack four pawn slash same
whatever right right nice uh jennifer
used game that was the one where we uh
thought that it was going to be a static
i'm not so static anymore right she
happened she got black got in c4
a4
and she got to
i mean it's not like you're going to
take on c2 and get to the first second
rank as quickly as did white the rook
already posted nicely that being said
who comes in with some oomph to the
ranks right yeah all right let's say
that i i don't like releasing the
tension but i just want to analyze it
sure c takes d3 okay you take with the
queen right
do you think of the pawn it's not
automatic but yeah i think i do take
with the queen
not automatic i i saw sea takes d3 as
you know supporting the rook here i've
kind of
traded uh
the guards of the rook on e4 and how do
we feel about positions let's say queen
g5
are you walking into rook g5 or are you
sorry what
yeah that's fine i have a
check you have a check all right
go back i'll defend this pawn
somehow g6 let's say
it's not
it's a little ugly right it's a little
ugly my spidey spider senses should be
tingling right
something like queen b5 queen d7 might
be devastating
queen b3 as well but you know me i'm a
pawn grubber so i'll go for the phone um
i know what you're saying but uh does it
feel enough right for black to play so
chaotically well i like the move c takes
d3 but i would first like to tickle you
know maybe you know back the rook up
somewhere you know like something like
rook c7 just so that
i have everything defended okay well
yeah okay we'll keep uh
we'll keep a close eye on that how are
the juniors doing with the blumenfeld
gambit
that's been a little while since we saw
that one exactly where are you
christopher that's it yep okay
uh
hold on what's going on it was like
bishop b2 this is a remember yeah uh
this is where knight d3 was christian
was advocating for knight d3 right
exactly knight c6 knight c3 bishop g4
and there's a reluctance to try to even
go d4 just place queen b3 um
first question yes
why can't i
take a ball take the pawn
let's see so if you take all right let's
say i take with the rook so that
queen takes d2
will be met by rook d1 and i don't have
to worry about losing the pawn on e3
and we guarantee the truth of that
statement
no game really right no warranties
nothing
nothing you can take on c3 knight e4
i can take on c3 i can go 94 also
immediately i mean i could go queen d2
on knight e4 but i don't i think it's
just insufficient say what you can do
this and then go knight e4 but i don't
think it works out
you don't have enough pieces at the end
i was hoping that at the end i could
take e3 or something but okay but that's
two
queen and knight for two rooks right but
i do get two pawns and i get to take on
e3 and i i like it's kind of dumb
but then again it's not that though i'm
not
completely dumb but now why why do this
right right right i mean it feels like
you're you're you're forcing uh matters
for no reason exactly yeah
so queen b3 does as you say ask the
question let's suppose for the moment
the question is
you can't take the pawn uh from white's
point of view is white threatening the
desirable knight d5 is this something
you want to worry about knight d5 is
very annoying right because the threat
on f6 is so devastating i don't have
time to play bishop takes d2 for example
exactly and the the thing is is a move
like knight d5 exposes the bishop
opens up f6 so uh something that
christopher is
eyeing definitely is the move knight
d5 um
so it's
not that easy
for black first impression is i like
white a lot of central a lot of central
control the knight coming to d5 is a
pretty big thread right again it's
because you have all these pawns in the
center that you can jump around with the
knights black doesn't have the same
capacity in the center also this half
open f5 it kind of feels like there's
vague threats towards f6 as well as f7
uh christopher you uh would be in great
shape could he if he could score one
result
so far only in the senior section
alexander shabollov drew his game
against dimitri grier which he was up
upon was shabbalov but gurevich seemed
to have compensation from start to end
and the game finished in a natural
result yes i feel so
in the game by the way between justin
wang and david brosky a game that we
haven't paid two attention to it almost
looks like a dutch defense reversed
these pawns on f4e3
very
well this one is a semi-closed position
i've always thought of closed positions
as positions with eight pawns
for both sides
and a semi-closed position is one where
seven and then an open position is when
you have six and i have six because then
we got files everywhere and diagonals
would be open so a semi-closed position
one of the great practitioners of
semi-closed positions was michael
bodwinick if you want to learn how to
play
positions with seven versus seven
study his games rook takes b4 uh
evenish
white's got an edge
space this bishop on eight is so bad
that i'd rather be white but okay
but it's not it can't be that bad right
no not when i've i've i'm controlling
the open powerful moment but that is the
you you you immediately put your your
thumb right on the issue uh
strategically speaking the bishop on e8
needs a a role a life
and
until black solves that i would think
it's easier to play white as well easier
but
you know that's there's not a lot of
targets in black scam you do have the
control of the b file the toothless
black lion
hairless toothless hairless dude
uh when we left i mean i like black okay
uh
hard to argue especially after the move
h5 i don't see any reasons whatsoever
that white will be proud of her play
bishop could even come back to f5 and
you could set up once again those
ideas of trying to
use some light squares i don't think the
black is that much better but
no i'd rather take black any day right
easier easier to play definitely
definitely
uh let us continue with the juniors
well guys um okay maybe i can give you
some uh ideas at work because this one
is getting spicy okay that is against uh
sophie morris suzuki versus ellen wang
and we've seen this bishop land on c5 we
knew that we loved it once the bishop
lands on c5 and we see this uh trade of
dark square bishop white is most likely
going to be better but
e4 came on the board and now big moment
right now
because if she finds this next move
she's going to fully take over the
initiative that is the move rook f to d1
right
if you take on c5 i take on c5 i target
the rook on f8 then i'm going to have
enough time to either choose between the
square d4 or e5 for my knight depending
on where you move the rook
that's not going to look good for your
position you have the bad bishop you
don't have enough
resources to get any sort of an attack
on the king side against my king it
looks like white is borderline winning
at this point so what can you do after
the move rook to d1 if you cannot take
on c5 or if you take on c5 you're much
worse if you take on f3 obviously after
bishop takes d6 it's resignation time so
the only move seems to be something
along the lines of bishop to e7 by the
way bishop e7 is not an easy move uh to
make and knight g5 comes
continuing with the spiciness in the
position right if you take on g5 i take
on the fade and once again this is
completely losing
by the way rook fd1 is on the board
she's a boss she just played this a boss
i mean she just played there's a reason
she's four out of four she's playing the
best moves in the position right now the
best plans the best moves she's not
falling for these ideas uh residual
ideas of uh bishop to b2 after the move
b3 very nice
play by white sophie maurice suzuki is
on fire right now oh absolutely that's a
great move for gt1 and when you think
about ellen's moves
she's played f5 king h8 e5 e4
and all she's got to show for it is that
her pawns on e4 and f5 but she's got
nothing
uh white is the one who's taking
advantage of all of the weak squares i
love this move rook d1
lazy man's chess bishop takes d6 with d1
also better but this is more precise
and one of the games that is most likely
going to be over soon uh still in the
junior girls section is the game between
anne marie valia and alice lee and i
just wanted to point out this very
classy move because
we notice this sequence and we said that
after bishop b7 maybe white has
something right
bishop to a3 check this move out very
nice very classy move just pretty much
shattering white's pawn structure which
was the only source of counter chance or
counter play or any sort of initiative
in white's position after this is pretty
much game over take take take we
exchange i pick up the pawn on c3 i
exchange everything
yeah the game is over for uh for a wide
rooked way
can be played rook to c1 and then focus
on the knight on d4 there is absolutely
no compensation another one that most
likely is going to be finished anytime
soon is the game between igor navikov
and gregory kaidanov nothing has
happened in this game that uh lion
that you are mentioning alejandro
aronian loves to play this unfortunately
it doesn't seem like white got
absolutely anything out of this one
we're expecting a shake of hands in this
one thank you for that and uh mishra
versus
andrew uh hung that was the bishop takes
d5 and we were really
looking at the positions after queen c7
and rook h5
well
mishra said okay let's go go ahead
put your rook on h5 i challenge you to
try to do anything by the way don't
forget i'm going to play bishop takes
f7 check like for example let me just
put this one on the board this is i
think the trap
that mishra had in mind you know
a puzzle rush check
and if you interpose rook takes thank
you for the pin and a decisive win of
material so he played queen b3 to stop
rook h5 and andrew
played the move king f8 intimating that
he's still interested in playing the
move rook h5
and challenge go ahead if you like play
the move rook h5 rook d4
and uh we're up to date with the
position with the players times
seems to be very favorable for mishra
right yeah 24 45 minutes from misra and
28 for andrew hong still 16 moves to
play
that position looks really good for me
sure exactly central control
bingo central control that that and it
almost kind of feels overwhelming
especially when you start thinking okay
you still got to get these guys into
into the act
uh they they've been off the battlefield
uh up until this moment so
bring them in again christopher you our
tournament uh leader
uh bishop to
f8 f8 well that's tepid
right is that not inviting knight d5 i
mean
you just like blast open this long
diagonal you start thinking that the
rook on f1 the queen on b3 might
coordinate
um
i'm liking what i'm seeing here for
christopher he's he's humming right
along
this feels very bad for uh
for black i wouldn't say something
christian in this game between
christopher u and balaji dakupati we'd
love to move knight d5 and we're having
trouble
even coming up with the response right
i'm stuck
knight to d5
yes uh knight to d5 is a very decent
move yes but why not just pick up the
pawn
which pawn on b7 i assumed there was a
rook b8 or something exactly i stopped
there and then
we can continue with queen take c6 rook
takes b 95 is a very good move also
[Laughter]
[Music]
well thank you very much thank you
you're welcome
knight to d5 knight to e4 probably is
the best move for black
knight
yeah but living this night on d5 like
that is
it's scary it's extreme yeah
it's hopeless almost right because the
knight on e4
if you look at the balance between the
knight on d5 and the knight on e4
they're both centralized but the knight
on e4 doesn't do anything it's actually
a target for my pieces because i'm going
to drop with a queen to c2 follow it up
with bishop to d3 and you're going to
have some huge trouble on the b1 h7
diagonal so
it's the difference between the pieces
right that
makes the difference right now and
it is in white's favor knight to d5 is
looking really good for christopher you
who might
be able to move all the way to four and
a half out of five with a victory and
pretty much take over this tournament
right that sounds great yeah right again
i just uh drop in on the wonder game for
a moment because this is the number one
versus number two and we have a result
that we expected uh igor navikov and
grisha kaidanov have simply split the
point not the most fascinating game no
no that game never got underway i'm
gonna go to the game of brandon and i
wonder for just a second because we were
looking at 94 and bishop f6 and i was
saying i was beginning to like a wonders
game
knight b5 on the board
queen
e7 knight c3 queen c5 bishop takes pawn
takes
knight takes and this is where i was
having trouble right here because i had
it in my mind that
something was hanging bishop takes e4
and rook d8 and rook takes d1 right
bishop takes e4 rook d8 and you have to
play with this rook otherwise i take on
d8 right or there was a maybe a knight
d6 or no rook after queen takes the
eight wins
i'm sorry yes because then i have to
take with the bishop bishop right and
defend against mate sorry that's a very
important point that uh the
move rook d8
actually
whoops queen takes d8 and now bishop
takes d8 allows rookie 8 whereas in the
game continuation
wonders move rook
on c8 to d8
means that queen takes
bishop takes is an awkward answer
uh
isn't white losing material after this
move because what about knight descent i
think with the google knight d6 right
well precisely i mean
knight d4 is an awkward pin but knight
d6 is also a terrible pin
i mean besides the fact that can take
this pawn no no no i'm sorry i'm not a
i thought it was even material no yeah
yeah yeah i picked up a pawn on e4
gotcha i gotcha but knight d6 uh
why not why not well
uh
why not is because it's a very awkward
pin
how do i exploit it you mean yeah
okay uh i obviously i want to play rook
d7 and rook d8 and h6 and take the
knight so let's start with rook d7 kick
out your queen just how b4 or something
just to defend the pawn b4 yeah get your
pawn out of the way
um
where do i end up with a lady
okay let's stay
let's oh rook c4
this is annoying why are you
why am i getting kicked around
um
why isn't it easy right
why is it just easy why is it just easy
yeah okay queen h5
uh i haven't you don't have enough
attackers right that's the problem i
feel it too
but i i mean i still it may be slower
than i like but i do have
h6 rook d8 on my agenda i want to say
banking everything on this pin
much at this point and by the way the
queen on h5 does have a use
i mean if for some reason you were able
to play queens e2 at night right here
let's try to get fancy yes
fancy play syndrome i probably shouldn't
do that i can't go to d1 i think
rook d1
to e1
okay let me let me make
no let me make love the other way you
can do whatever you want rookie 8 38 i
think anyway
rookie eight
um
once again how am i exploiting this yeah
it feels like white has their own play
as well right
well whoa whoa whoa i'm not giving a
rookie seven which rook uh one p7 rook
one e7 take cake take
now white is just much better here right
now really check ah yeah or queens
yeah no the desire i was trying to
exploit the pin
couldn't do it not so easy knight d6
how does the engine assess this position
because at first i thought ooh
brandon had walked into a uh
an issue
i didn't find it supposedly still within
the margins of equality in fact after uh
rook to d8 which was a good move by the
way knight to d6 rook to d7
probably the best move but also just
simply picking up the pawn maybe from a
practical perspective a better
alternative now at the same time if you
do take the pawn
queen to b1 and then my knight gets out
it does seem like he's going to peter
out or to drive a draw uh the best you
will get is probably two versus one on
this side and say that
my majority doesn't count on this one in
a rook end game but i don't think that's
going to be enough for black so what you
could try is rook to d7 as you mentioned
b4 and now queen to c7 okay seems to be
the best move you want to hide the queen
all the way to b8 and then ask white how
are you going to stop me from taking
advantage of this pin one way to do so
it seems to be let's take a look
i saw this move rook to e5 appear on the
board at some point just to
let's uh let's take a look at uh rook to
e5 yeah rook to e5 is one movie doesn't
seem to be very good after bishop takes
e5 not enough compensation perhaps
visually it looks like i have enough
knight on d6 i don't think enough to me
right right
but from an objective point of view it
doesn't seem like it's enough
nevertheless i have to say rook to e5 at
least from a visual perspective it looks
like a decent move um
my question was what if i go here after
to e5 though right
because rook to d5 once again bishop to
e7 you still didn't get away from this
pin
you would love to have the rook the
queen on d1 and the rook on d3
unfortunately that's not the case
a difficult position difficult position
and
keep in mind these moves are all engine
moves right engine approved but not easy
moves to make especially this idea of
hiding the queen all the way to b8 not
easy also you're running into knight b5
at uh at times h5 seems to be the move
that in fact maintains equality wow this
position and the idea being that after
rook to d8 i have this idea of rook to
d1 and now with the pawn on h5 this g6
is going to be met by h6 yeah a very
hidden idea very very nuanced idea and
you are mentioning you are trying to
find the right way of making a loop you
cannot make a loof with h6 because my
queen controls that square
the only way to make a loof is with g6
and if i have my pawn on h5 i'm ready to
go to h6 very very difficult concept to
see from afar but uh very useful if you
manage to get to this point so
rook to d8 is on the board let's see
what brandon will uh come up with well
we
think knight d6 is forced but d4 seems
to be a move as well but the more you've
been discussing this position the more
i'm thinking bishop takes b2 and just
say you know
give me back my pawn and then uh let's
call it something else
as we prepare to go on break we do have
a nice uh
alice lee looks like she's uh putting
the finish she's
done
the hard
work already uh
she's an
exchange upon it she's won the queen
side pawn that's the point she's ready
to
to uh play rook a1 check in the near
future i'm expecting king
i was going to say king e5 she decided
on king f5
it's the
last place you would have put the king
right right there's there's a thing that
grand masters do eventually where you
put the king just the furthest away from
the night
so you don't get
tricked into a fork
but no this is this is
for sure over
uh rook check
and the a pawn goes so fast
uh a little bit surprised that
annie is playing on here because there's
no chance she's down too much material
yeah that's a lot of material exchange
and upon uh jennifer you let's see if
jennifer hold on we might see
she plays king f1 she's not resigning
anytime soon
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa jennifer might
have some
what the heck is going on
we'll wait for one more move in this one
and we'll switch nope that's it
and marie does resign against alice lee
an unfortunate blunder for her just
gave the game to her opponent i mean
that's how it works in shas
let's take a look at then at the rey
yong yang against jennifer you game you
were mentioning that you're starting to
like black right because you had meant
you you you had wanted to take on d3 and
i was kind of hesitating could i
recapture with you
yeah and i ended up recapturing the with
a queen well
um jennifer set a position now this is
the current position and by the way she
did capture
where uh
white was forced to recapture with the
pawn and now it was like whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa the rook is making a very
nasty introduction
along at the second rank with rook c2
and that's going to force
white to drop back with her rook rook to
e2 to defend the f2 pawn as well as the
b-2 pawn
and you know it was really funny the
moment i saw it i wanted to play e4
yeah just hang the rook no not not that
good yeah sir not that good
do you feel do you feel that black is
playing for the advantage here well
because if you are i mean i can just
perpetual you i don't have to play
rookie too that is true
no i i i didn't know i yeah it was just
that i saw rooksy two and i went
yes by the way this is the perpetual
that alejandro was talking about check
and check yeah you never want to run all
the way to like the c file or something
you'll get made it
no no no no so perhaps start with h5
at a temporary
exciting excitement uh unjustified on my
part h5 i like you make love sometimes i
still like black a little more than i
like white you you you get out of the
background perps perpetuals
and you are setting up for example
yeah too
okay uh jennifer might have something
she can work with yeah i i feel it right
mm-hmm
okay it's gonna it's still a lot a lot
to uh
a long way to go and they're h5 there
you go h5
uh just checking in on the game between
zoe and rochelle that was the trompowsky
game that had us so excited it's an
unrecognizable position
[Laughter]
right rochelle i i think has
uh
improved
whoa whoa whoa g5
that was a big decision by the way that
was not necessary not only g5 was an
option but also you have the move knight
to e4 that you had to consider chad
chuck right and
there's this sudden discovered attack so
this was a big moment and i'm not really
sure if she made the right decision
nevertheless
you still look at the position and you
think okay black is definitely in
control exactly what what is actually
the more i look at it the more i'm
wondering what what is white supposed to
do here
you're kind of losing g3 aren't we but i
mean that's f4 is coming f4 is coming
yeah i i was thinking that i have to
play knight h5 yeah but then i take on
g3
fearlessly
fearlessly take on g3 it's not my it's
not my pieces but i don't see i don't
see a problem no i don't either i think
bishop takes g3 is an excellent move
yeah that's what i was worried about
rook g1 but you have bishop f2 and just
finishes the game there is no
rook takes g5 that knight on b3 is so
useless
well at least one moment i mean you
would love to get it to c5 but for the
moment is completely useless agreed yeah
the tactical complications come in when
the knight is still
not playing out
out of play yes exactly it just looks
great for black very very much so
oof
zoe uh
as we get ready for a guest uh coming
into the studio a couple of results uh
alejandro yes we had this result that
was very big igor novikov and gregory
cardano both reach
that's
not right yeah igor's like two and a
half yeah he lost yesterday yeah sorry
yes they're both at 50
you're thinking yeah
the production's never wrong our
graphics are always right always a
hundred percent right america half a
point out of five rough start for her of
course is very strong tournament alice
lee certainly the more experienced
player despite the younger age exactly
and she wins an important game for alice
honestly as alice is with us in studio
with christian
alice first of all welcome back to the
show welcome back uh to st louis we
haven't seen you since the american cup
how does it feel to be back uh it's
great to be back here st louis is just
like it's so nice here and it's just one
of my favorite places to be
what were your ambitions coming into
this event because we know how well you
did in the american cup
did you want to win this event uh well
that was certainly the higher goal
although
my goal now is just to do better than i
did last year
well a difficult start for you two
losses in uh the first four games but
finally you broke through let's go uh
through today's game okay
tell us your critical moments in your
opinion
oops
so let me get uh
i think that
um the main
turning point was
when she allowed knight c5 to d3
that was
later
um
yeah so i'm not i wasn't sure about the
opening but i thought that it went okay
i was able to
sort of get her to develop her knight to
d2 before taking on d4 because usually
she wants to do like c takes d4 and um
and get the knight to c3
yeah
so
um
i made some weighty moves um
that are kind of useful just to
make her kind of
move her night before i take on d4
and she did and you timed it well and
now were you surprised by this move
knight to f3 and how quickly did you
spot this knight c5 knight d3i uh yeah
so i was planning a knight c5 to d3 um
with queen a6 like i think that was my
main threat before she played knight f3
because i can't do e5 as it runs into
knight f5
um and then i should be much worse
so if you don't have the knight on f3
yeah yes
um so
after she allowed this
i thought that here i should kind of be
winning because like i'm gonna win some
material and i don't see um that she has
too much compensation
excellent let's keep going and i really
like this move
bishop to a3
did you see it from afar no uh i was
thinking here like what i should do i
thought uh like maybe bishop takes e5
maybe bishop e7 or bishop c5
um
so i would be up in exchange but i
thought it would be cleaner to play
bishop a3 after i saw the move
because
now
my pawn structure won't be too much
worse than hers like
i was expecting b takes a3 in which case
i'd play knight d5 and there's not a too
easy of a way for her to get to my pawns
but um now i'm trying to play work day
c3 takes a3 and um also win the a2 pawn
and that should be winning also
and after that it felt like the
conversion
was quite easy alice congratulations
your first a victory uh in the
tournament a rest day is coming up what
are you going to do during the rest day
um i guess kind of mentally
prepare for the next four rounds uh i
think i'll be playing salia um as white
that's a big game yeah um hopefully i'll
be able to end well
alice congratulations uh for today and
we're looking forward to see you in the
rest of your games thank you
our congratulations as well alice uh
enjoy well-deserved rest day absolutely
it's important for all of us
where would you like to oh we were gonna
actually take a break yeah i think it's
a good time to take a break we'll be
back in a few minutes
as
we come back and we asked some of the
girls how they prepared for the u.s
junior girls championship let's take a
look at their answers
how did you uh prepare for this event we
know it's a very prestigious event what
was your training routine coming into
this event i've been actually very busy
this summer i've taught a couple of
summer camps and
overall just you know spending time with
family but i've tried my best to still
do some chess work and play some
training games and things like that and
hopefully
hopefully my training shows at the right
moment during the tournament i've played
a few tournaments before this to like
kind of get back into in-person chess so
well i'm trying to be physically and
also mentally fit fit so not only um
like solving puzzles reviewing openings
but also just exercising and relaxing so
that i'm ready for long tournament
that's ahead um before this event i
played in the world open and right
before that was philadelphia
international both in philadelphia
so i didn't really have that much time
to prepare so basically as soon as i got
the invitation i started like
researching my opponents and like trying
to see what openings they played um i've
just been looking at some of my
opponents games trying to figure out um
sort of how they play what their style
is what their openings are that kind of
thing i've played two tournaments before
this they didn't go that well um so i'm
just not thinking specifically about
preparing just for the tournament i mean
when the field when the parents come out
i'm obviously gonna prepare as much as
they can but i just really wanna
try to play the best chance i can
just the usual preparing um making sure
that i am ready to start my games
it's been a little erratic
because
i had college this whole year except for
one tournament that i played but it did
not go well i mean i've just been
playing games and checking what my
opponent played my opponent's place and
stuff well i mostly just worked on
reviewing my openings i've looked a bit
at the players but not too much since we
don't know the colors
of what order i'm playing the players
until tonight
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
welcome back everybody we're here round
five of our championships we've got the
junior the junior girls and the senior
for you 15 games of chess couple of
which have finished in today's round yes
we do a little bit number of uh results
already we do but let's take a look at
some of our most important games yasser
where do you want to start well i was
looking at the game of rue yang and
jennifer you for just a moment because
again i had just one of those like
moments
and uh i stopped myself because i saw
rook check and i said oh my gosh did
rooyang miss has begun brooke
in the region game against jennifer you
right because uh she played the move
queenie one e2 just as we were returning
from break and i like it flashed
this is the moment she just played the
move queen and i thought oh well wait a
minute i can play rook check
force the king away
from the protection of the f2 pawn and
crash through and take the pawn and if
you take my pawn on h5
rook takes
g2 check was one of the things i was
about to investigate
until
you cleared the cobwebs and say well
wait a minute yes sir throw in the check
first
very important before taking on h5 and
you'll be able to take on h5 with a gain
of tempo
for example queen king h7 or queen h
king h7
check
and that changes everything so no no
blunders
no blunder alerts i wanted to say queen
e2 is just fine and that game goes
uh onwards
yep um christopher you
oh let's this is actually the uh
i
you had asked me the question how did
how did black get his rook to b6
[Laughter]
you don't want to take the rook i said i
set up a discover check
so but what is the rook actually doing
on b6 i'm not exactly sure
and we have caught up with the players
right now and it sure feels to me
like vladimir is doing very well
rookie six i know like why would you put
your rook
on a be sexy creativity
sometimes sometimes too much
nice nice all right larry christensen
and joe beniman again larry our
tournament leader
and
wow i just call it a draw yeah yeah
precisely so that looks uh even stevens
all around and uh max
again not too much has taken place here
either
looks like both players are content to
wobble their way towards a draw yeah
and again how is uh
oh he didn't take on b2 oh this is the
game between brandon jacobs and anna
wonder
thought that a wonder would take on b2
at this point bishop takes b2 but
restoring the material equality but
giving up
ideas of exploiting the pin and a wonder
is playing let's call it more
ambitiously a little riskier rook d7 b4
defends the spawn which is very
important no moves yet before it was the
last move as wanderer is considering
between queen c7 and isu queen c6 and we
like queen c7 the best the best yes we
we we did analyze that but that is such
a complex game that yeah i think the
most important factor actually will be
the time situation of the players okay
and that is what is the time 14 minutes
only for the next 14 moves for brandon
jacobson and he has a huge problem to
solve over the board and that is uh the
knight on d6 and the pin on the d file
right so if black finds the move queen
to c7 and now wonder still has 28
minutes right on the clock double the
time of brandon queen to c7 is a big one
if he finds it he's going to create some
difficult problems to solve over the
board for brandon and all the action i
have to say is in the junior section
because take a look at what's happening
in the game between carissa hip and
pedro espinosa a lot of things have
changed we were looking at the position
and we're like okay
symmetrical pawn structure it does feel
like black has the better placed pieces
but nothing is going to happen at least
immediately that's not the case knight
to e5 bishop takes c5 came on the board
followed by queen to b6 it might look
like a single attack but it's actually a
double attack i'm also attacking besides
the pawn on b3 the pawn on g3 because
i'm setting up this nice pin on the a7
g1 diagonal the pawn on f2 cannot
recapture back so these are some serious
problems that white has to deal with
queen takes b3 bishop to d4 rook to c8
i'm getting close take advantage of the
open file rook to c4 to c2 is on tap and
queen to e1 was played which
i'm looking at this move this last move
and i'm i simply don't understand it i i
look i get it you want to take the pawn
on a5 but what outside of that right
what if i just continue with my usual
plan rook c7
rook to c4 attacking the bishop on
d4 i mean do you want to go to a7
probably not then by the way none of
this will happen because he played the
move queen to a4 still
the point stays the same the position
has evolved in such a way that i have uh
to give black
close to a decisive advantage
yeah
wow absolutely it just seemed like rhys
is playing uncharacteristically
seriously
yeah this is the ongoing will
no no no bottom of the compensation i
wanted to jump into the game of
christopher u
uh for a moment because when we left it
we were just like
banging the table for knight d5 come on
christopher knight d5
improve your score to four and a half
out of a five
h2h3
and
black seized his chance to
capture the spawn on d2 because in the
game position i was thinking to myself
aren't i missing a pawn there shouldn't
be a pawn on d2 but black did capture it
knight d5 now
but this gave black the time he needed
to be able to bring his queen back into
the game and uh well there's a lot of
defenders
and attackers too though yeah because
how are we gonna let
i was about to say what if we just push
up on a5 a4 and i was going to ask you
to prove it but he played bishop
to
d6 in order to
cover
uh g3 square and maybe bishop e5 so
let's go with rook f1
i guess is kind of forced yeah just have
to respect the threat
rook
bishop f6 works though does it work
what what no it doesn't work good yeah
that is that is kind of funny that uh
i defend the bishop that way but yes
you're right i do have queen g3
maybe c5
not quite let's try c5 sure uh
bishop
pack i guess let's go queen h4
that's an unusual tickle
it's also an uncomfortable tickle um
bishop e4 do i have bishop before now
yes
that starts to hurt uh great activity
for the white pieces by the way in this
position do i really have to respect the
threat i guess i do rookie seven i was
thinking if if you play bishop takes f7
i i'm not unhappy but i think it's rook
takes place
is the one that i'm unhappy about
it's gonna okay well let's say rook of
faith is probably going to be way too
passive right it feels uncomfortable at
the very least right
okay well we'll definitely keep an eye
on that one and what happened in the
game of mishra
and andrew
we left it
here
bishop d7 rook d1
rookie 8
b5
and sure looks like mishra is
enjoying the position
more than how do you survive right the
queen before knight b6 check is quincy
five fours i think so right right then i
go rogue c4
okay queen
where am i supposed to go because 97 is
coming against most things
i guess there's a bishop how do you
survive this hold on
how do you survive for two moves
that's a good question
maybe queen a5
i mean yeah a5 there we go uh well
it's not pretty but you're alive even
here knight f6 knight f6 bishop e6
that's the point okay
let's see if he finds it notice when a5
is on the board
queen if i only move right yes yeah okay
9s6 bishop e6
that's
fortunate yeah unfortunately otherwise
you actually resign right the queen a5
on the board
i suppose if uh white doesn't find
anything else uh that's still c4 trunks
strong enough you you've got all of
those threats that you mentioned
and uh black and this is another game in
which uh well andrew will have to keep
an eye on his clock because
they're going down to the last 14 moves
with only 13 minutes to go and the
previous one by the way the one that we
looked at with uh christopher well
christopher has 20 something uh minutes
but bellagio only 12 minutes
for 20 for 18 moves
12 minutes for 18 minutes yes so balaji
in some sort of a time trouble situation
as well
you're there i mean i just wanted to
check in on a sophie
and she's upon up now and it's even
better and doing
very very well she's got
this game
yeah this looks great sophie
pulling in another victory here looks
like just cleaning from her when we left
it she had played that very
almost precision chess move rook to d1
and let's just see how yep that's how
she won the pawn
oh
beautiful play by by white
say uh could she have been even more
ambitious here
she played the move rook d2 which i
think is just fine
uh
but you also started
yeah okay
good good good good
and we caught up to the players it looks
like sophia
she could cruise into the rest day 5-0
that's insane i mean
wow what a start i don't think we have
the bobby fischer prize we have the
bobby fischer prize for the u.s
championships
which is very very very nice of course
but there is a big prize in this
tournament guys let's not forget the
winner of this event actually qualifies
to this year's us women's championship
right and this is huge development uh
huge news that we
uh just hurt today
yeah i don't know if the players know i
think they think that they will qualify
to the next year's 20 u.s world
championship but it is actually no it's
these regulations
yeah so
that's a big that's a big item yes yeah
no that's bad that is a big eye truth
and in case they didn't know it it might
be not be in the regulations uh but it
is
dwayne and susan
dwayne and susan barber also uh
uh gave 5000 scholarship
which was matched by the u.s chess trust
the united states chess federation's
uh
trust
um so that 10 000 in scholarships go to
the two winners of the girls and the
juniors that's not bad at all that's
very nice no scholarships for the
seniors
you can fix that
and you let me in yeah
let me in there coach when we left it by
the way i we thought zoey was in real
trouble with rochelle and i think it's
still the case i don't think she's in
trouble anymore i think she's
bad or just kind of lost right yeah i
think that if this pawn just pushes yes
i don't think you're stop it actually
that kid it's true uh i'm more worried
even that you might win the f4 square
like h5 h4
boot the knight and then go
there it goes
all right your ellipse
there it goes
very very nice so we'll keep an eye on
that and
anything going on in the seniors
christian well absolutely vladimir
kopian as you guys mentioned not a long
time ago is taking over this end game
the bishops are looking beautiful i have
full control of the e file i have a lot
of initiative coming your way on the
king side with this pawn majority and
yeah the position actually is completely
lost
right now after rook to e4 rook to e4 is
one of the moves you can also go b5 trap
this rook almost right
visual move now at the same time even if
you do take that rook and you probably
will
you are giving up the dark square bishop
so maybe you don't want to go into that
uh type of situation to be honest at
this point i would value the two bishops
and the two bishop advantage uh more
than just an exchange right so i would
play the move rook to e4 or maybe even
take on h5 f5 is also a move f5 actually
visually it kind of looks good right
because yeah tactical yeah you take i
can go g5 i can also just take and then
follow it up with bishop to g5 and h6
and open you up on this side very nice
follow with the invasion of the rooks on
the e file it just um white has a lot of
targets while black's pieces are not
doing much look at this rook on b6 what
are you attacking with the rook on b6
the bishop on d6 not much tonight well
if you move the knight i'm invading on
e8 so you don't want to do that either
so
it just looks extremely extremely good
right now for white the game between
joel benjamin and larry christensen this
one is not going anywhere it's going to
be a draw anytime soon and maxime
deloogie versus nick defermion
definitely white nursing a space
advantage
but no targets and to be honest i don't
see it uh going anywhere but in a
drawish position after a potential rook
to e5 let's exchange some pieces and
this one most likely will be over as
well so the only decisive result it does
seem as we are entering the rest day
could be vladimir akopian
against igor melinitsky who uh well
unfortunately
well for him he won a game yesterday but
again
yeah in the event against joel benjamin
this would be a huge victory and a very
important victory for vladimir kopian if
he wants to stay in contention for the
title
agreed christian uh in the juniors i
want to drag your attention to actually
uh christopher against dagu patti i was
just looking at this move by uh pedro by
the way queen e3 he retreated the night
i i couldn't understand and then it was
like f3 and then knight retreated some
more it was like
what i was expecting this rook c4 rook
c2 stuff
uh where are you going pedro yeah
exactly like wasn't the knight i guess
he wants to go to e6 i think it was 36
yeah knight f8 and you put it on e6 okay
now we're talking fair make some sense
okay sorry you were gonna take it
somewhere uh the christopher you game
against balaji da gupati because it's
such a huge one for our standings the
tournament leader after all and bishop
e7 was played instead of what we
expected the move bishop c7 actually
move rook f8 instead of um rookie seven
as well to begin with bishop e7 and
spider sense is tingling right can i
play bishop g7 or rook kg does something
work here exactly because you think
yourself uh rook g3 i'm killing you on
the g file but bishop h4 turns the table
yeah absolutely because unfortunately i
take your queen you take my queen with
shaq
and oops i lose the rook so then the
question is well can't i
change the move order and play bishop
takes g7 yeah how do i feel about that i
feel very good about that give me gift
me the pawn
i guess i have to take this
well if you played rookie rook e8 to f8
you don't want to so take it with the
king get off the dangle
i guess
g3 and i see a bishop g5 right so let's
go h4
right and i'm assuming h6 or f6 no f6
you can take the recon face
precisely f6 would be uh whoops
that would be very very unpleasant so h6
is box forced
take on g5 take on g5
it's max mac
and how do i improve my position
well
check is going to be met by f6 that is
pretty clear
so can i play bishop e4
i was thinking i was just thinking that
i think you can i think it's just me no
that's
not
not by rook h3 right
ah
that's nasty it's starting to look good
it looks like it's starting to unlock my
christmas yeah
yes uh wow um
that's just the activity of the pieces
and the rook on a8 and the knight on d8
are really not contributing
bishop takes g7 perhaps to finish that
variation uh the the one that we were
just gonna by the way this game has
ended in a draw we called it some time
ago between joel benjamin and larry
christensen larry will go into the rest
day feeling very very good without his
first five rounds undefeated plus two
and uh
again
leader what can you say peter you're
very very happy sorry christian you you
said you would like to continue this
variation yeah
just finish it up your bishop to e4
what is the mate after you take on e4 i
take on g5 and i go king let's say
i mean what what did you want to do
christian king 7 first king h7 first or
h8 i don't know exactly where it's
better
so you give another check yeah
why not
king jesus yes
at least no no king g6 king g7
king g7 that's queen f6 i see i keep
forgetting seven queen f6 is made in two
yeah right yeah
i was gonna do this but maybe i'm not
maybe i i i also thought queen takes c4
queen f6 i thought it was just much
easier but whatever guys
yeah that's watching you you're probably
right yeah yeah i mean simple yeah
simple chess lazy man's chess as
alejandra would like to say and practice
very well practiced
uh bishop g7 uh looks like a
clincher or where
um it's not recommended by the engine by
the way it's not it's not no no it's not
so bishop takes g7 queen takes g7
rook to g3 bishop g5 let's go through
the variation and after h4 knight to e6
seems to be the only move okay okay and
how do you continue
i was going to take on g5 yeah but
now i don't have to take back right
right now i can just go rook c8 or queen
e5
um i don't have to take back anymore so
that might be a problem how do you
continue maybe queen to f5
okay then queen g6
it's not as much as i would like it to
be right so perhaps bishop to hg7 a bit
uh
rushed
rash
yes
and what is
ah so it's not chuck no no no queen
queen to e1 yes oh red just don't shut
up he's just throwing his rick g3 yeah
yeah actually rick j3 is hard to stop
but this is a very difficult move to see
no but i think anything right king h1
king is too quick king queen you want
anything king h2 h1 i go knight d6
and what's the difference after direct
g3 rogue gg yeah
oh
so now you take i take and not that easy
anymore
in fact actually you're not even better
anymore yeah yeah yeah
we will accept so you have to be careful
um the queenie one
and i guess queen to e1 the big
difference is that after 96 rook to g3
bishop to h4 you can just take take take
on e6 with the rook on e6 that's just
nice and the bishop is no longer
protected after you take on f2
wow
oh man these engines are so strong
right
yeah they're pretty good
yep it's kind of crazy queen e1 or king
h2 and there's a huge difference so this
one after rookie six you take and then
the bishop is protected on f3 yeah so it
is actually black
which is better right now so wow big
moment
is one of them that would be really
remarkable because that's not that's not
suggestive whatsoever no whoa no not at
all
i understand king h2o kind of right
taking on g7 i understand
queenie one wow alien chess good stuff
uh i just want to check in on justin and
dave justin wang david brodsky
we mentioned that this bishop on e8 was
the issue
well white hasn't made that much
progress i think uh
david is uh a favorite to make a draw
and that's one you think so right i do i
think so too it's too it's too locked up
yeah it's very hard to break through
still by the way he did not find queen
to e1 he played the move rook to
and
f4
the big one he's human
right but
after looking for i go 96 how how do you
continue just a second let me catch up
with you there rook f4 you're gonna go i
i beg your pardon it's pretty much the
only movie so in the game of christopher
you and
96.
yes
there you go
knight e6 i i well i'm assuming uh
christopher
wants to play the move of rook g4
i think we did i heard crickets i mean
just uh
all right sequoias
i mean there's a great chirping insect i
hear it late at night if you you guys
picked up on that on your walks the
secretary yes yes
very very loud all right so what do we
do now guys
well well
yeah no no forget about the engine we
have to find it ourselves uh
this is the task right now we have to
find it ourselves yeah all right let's
go bishop g5 right
okay
without 96. no no no no no no 96 night
night oh my gosh you want to walk into a
pin
okay uh i'll i'll fall for it you'll
fall for it me first
what if i go
you go h5 i'll take your two i got two
gorgeous bishops it's just dead lost
i don't think it's enough yeah yeah yeah
especially with the c5 phone wow
yeah this is dead dead
wow
yeah
i like the two bishops in that position
so rook f4 puts the challenge uh
uh to black what are you gonna do and
the times uh we
uh let me take a look sorry uh we have
13 minutes for christopher and 7 30 for
okay guys you you bamboozled me again i
did you bamboozled me i did all right
all right with your very confident ideas
yes rook g4 bishop g5 h4 you're worse
after bishop take c3
guess you are yeah
actually you were watching that hard
yeah it wasn't that hard no much worse
and this was not that hard but you guys
go so fast i know we're just h4 by the
way i got you on it's over you said 96
was only move and bishop g5 was played
so there was clearly another move
bishop g5 was playing bishop g5 yeah
yeah well decisive advantage after rook
five but
once again nothing actually happens
immediately because you're working for
your players you can't play knight 96
yeah 96 yeah rook f5 you can't play
ninety-six games i i think we're going
to see it and he played rook g4 almost
immediately yes i think we're going zero
i mean ever just a transposition right
it makes no sense not to play rook g4
now balaji is shaking his head that
means that maybe he did not see this
idea of knight to e6 right now
well he doesn't have much choice
he's gonna find it i can tell you that
it's a
wait a second
h five but then i just simply got rook
g3 back
three bishop h4 no
i know no not anymore because it's spin
because there's nothing thank you
exactly
oh that is nasty and rook to g3
reinforces the threat of h4 now it sure
does same idea this the the
the um
the pawn on f7 spin once the pawn
on
h7 went to h5 there goes the queen
exactly
and now if you go you no longer have the
move knight to e6 after rook to g3 i
think because of h4
and is that true same reason as before
yes
well
no because when you take on g6 you don't
have h takes g6 anymore yeah you have to
think with the f when you're just dead
you take with the f pawn i take on e6
and if you take on d4
that allows the pin to get back in into
play so if you take on d4 i just simply
take back on d4 that's a nice
reinforcing the pin that's nice oh wow
don't so after rook g3 i think
bellagio is in big trouble
guys
by the way like we have to go to a
wonders game like we should like asap
number one versus number two change
dramatically what we left it in that no
it didn't change dramatically he just
blundered okay look at that queen c7
rook let's look at the noun so we can
see what happened yeah queen dropped
back to b right brook c6 holds the
knight
but now we're in this nasty pin
and how did brandon deal with it oh he's
looking to play rook c8 and he captures
okay
so oh f7 that's okay you can take that
this is not going to help you it's not
going to help you king 8
wow okay i mean
all right well
it's just visual
rook c8 and he's thinking brandon is
that go ahead take my rook i'll take on
d7
did he just miss rook takes c6
i mean rook takes d6 he looks so shell
shocked right now if we did
he's just down the keys right well take
on d1 it's over that's a check
and this is sure rooks and a bishop for
a queen it's not even a contest
that's material
what are we missing
no we're not saying anything oh no
he just he just forgot about rook takes
d6
not like this
oh what a painful loss
let's give it to a wonder because he did
find and put a lot of pressure on that
queen to c7 by the way this game is over
yeah he resigned yeah oh look oh what a
blunder by brandon wow incredible and
for one for a wonder this is his second
win in a row he knitted it as he climbs
back remarkably to 50 i mean we're
talking about the number one seed here
uh remarkable remarkable and the juniors
as well i think pedro espinosa is
putting those final touches
against chris carissa he's up two pawns
oh my goodness what just happened here
yeah
what a day at the fourth one yeah
pedro espinosa the lowest rated player
in my beginning the field
is taking over the initiative against
i've already been the initiative he's
well we left it at this point and you
guys were mentioning that uh black has
pedro has this idea of establishing a
knight on e6 but rook d2
he said you know what
i'm i'm a pawn grabber too
let me just take that one
i don't see any compensation is it your
time
to either play b5 or
no
fancy play isn't needed just b5 i don't
see the issue
yeah two pawns they're just rolling down
the board pushing baby yeah
looks over
uh
what else do we have oh how is android
doing by the way i'd be mind you misha i
guess andrew hong since where are the
juniors uh are we going to have five
decisive results in the treasury no i
think justin wang
we gave that i don't know about that
justin wang is
has a lot of space there's a lot of
space okay
okay h2h3 we sure like mishra's uh
position against andrew we think
andrew's on the back foot well oh h2h3
uh
no
sorry he needed to make luft
capturing the pawn would be too rash
bishop here h3 on the board
okay uh andrew definitely on the back
foot and that one yep okay let's see
what else we got in the ladies
oh i think rochelle is just cruising to
victory right really and now she's got
ideas of rook takes e2 and
knight g3 this looks really really
one-sided it's resignation yeah
what about zoe zoe oh pardon me
king h7
what is going on i it's
tough jennifer well two minutes for
jennifer to find a way to break through
oh wow white's defense but is there a
way to break through if white is able to
get in moves like h4 and f3 she's going
to be so who's better safe and secure on
the king's side
when yeah i think so when you play rook
takes b5
with your king side
so why isn't she playing a rook to c5 to
defend the pawn on b5 you have to defend
that pawn right otherwise you're using
both b5 and e5
right and
you kind of start thinking that you want
to get rid of this rook on e4 too right
so rook cb5 what's the time situation
alejandro the class 15 minutes for reed
young and two minutes for jennifer you
did you say two two minutes two two how
many moves a lot i think eleven
two
two
game in fact twelve moves for jennifer
wow yeah this is not the uh cool common
collector that we saw yesterday right
yeah
oh
suddenly i
you oftentimes you can walk into a
tournament hall and feel the players
tensions right yeah
there is a very hidden resource that
jennifer has okay tell us at her
disposal right now queen to c1 which she
played
yes
rook to h4
which was rueyang's response and instead
of going to g5 just repeating the
position king to g6
okay now the idea is clear right if you
do spend some time on taking at this
point
might be problematic clear
but what happens after g4 right right
because g4
seems like i'm going towards your king
your king is getting checked as well
rook takes f2
damn queen takes f2 and now rupert
okay and this position looks pretty bad
for white
the king is just simply too weak at this
point okay so
if she does not find that
she plays she
won
she played queen cy that's fine
instantaneously a whole minute she
burned half her time
they were already here
yeah and rook h4 was played the last
time they were here not a lot of choices
now you might think us really young
though you're up i guess the player with
one minute right you're right you have
to play rook h4 but on the other hand
rook c2
is rocking the
the the white king i mean rook c2 comes
in crashes on the f2 pawn but
g6
right yes after h4 you have to find king
g6 and it's not an easy decision with
only one minute on the clock
no
certainly not she hasn't found it with
five minutes on the clock a couple of
moves ago
let's see if she decides to go for it
with one minute on the clock it's not an
easy decision right could i ask a
question after king g6 rook takes h oh
queen f4 check
i think that answers the question sorry
queen f4 check because uh the desirable
rook h
whoops i'm getting my rook back but
queen f4
ends the game instantly ruined has to
play her move fast
no other options right now
rook c2 is a big threat yes precisely
you don't have time to take on b5 you're
going to get
slaughtered after rook to c2 she's done
it
okay the question is what does jennifer
do in this precise moment because she
could just repeat and call it a draw
right and i think she's counting she's
looking at the scorching error score
sheet right is she going to
ask the arbiters for a draw right yeah
but with one minute i think
you kind of do it right
right
it's a practical choice
but it's funny the rook looks so awkward
and oh no age four guys she's going for
the king that's yeah jennifer with 30
seconds she's going to go for audition
she's she's going for
[Music]
we
kings
see that what's the difference king
eight not king g6 it's good it's good
it's a good move it's a good move it's a
good move engine approved engine
approved
usda approved not as good as king g6 but
to be honest the next move is insane for
white
the only move in fact in the position to
defend this one is insane queen g4 no
queen g4 is completely lost after queen
to f4 yeah that end game is lost my rook
is just crashed
that's hilarious okay so hold on it's
not queen g4 just rook e7 uh
i want i want to start punching maybe
don't tell me f4 that would be that
would be ridiculous again that makes
sense you only have one move and it's so
difficult to see is rook f7
get lost rook f7 is i was not on my
radar seriously to stay in the game
exactly it's not on your radar because
you've been focusing on the b5 now we
know where the king belongs get out of
here get out of here come on don't allow
rook f7 in these situations
rook f7 right well with the king on g6
rook f7 doesn't work i can also take i
can also take with a rook right because
my king goes to f6 all the time so what
is the follow-up here like if i go rook
c2
and now the end game is not that easy
right
because after queen f4 i could actually
take it a moment ago exactly and i can
take on f4 right
remarkable jesus
let's see if she finds it no no it's
it's a difficult move to find um
i feel she's going for g4 the way her
hand gesture no way if she comes
here
i mean that's
that such a hidden that's a shocker yes
actually if she finds rook f7 i think
jennifer might be in trouble no no no i
mean there's not that many moves right
you simplify into the end game but
here's the problem that uh
ru yang is facing it's sort of like
what's another
playable move there's so many moves you
want to play g4 yes but you're falling
into rook f2 and c2 and that's pretty
clear and that's very clear i think
rookie seven is an easy trap to fall
okay
very normal
that's a very logical looking move to
mike it is it is and it all comes down
to the assessment of the end game after
after after rook c2 rook e6 yes g6 yeah
and then queen g4 queen f4 she needs to
understand that this queen g4 queen f4
transition with the rook steel on h4 is
completely deadly okay harukon h4 is
just going to die there exactly
that's not as easy to understand no no
far
no we don't have that on our analysis
board we're going to just keep a look
at uh
well
the tournament board yeah
but you're right uh christian rook e7
is a very tempting move right yeah you
you
you want to throw some
punches at your opponent's king and
certainly
rook e7 takes e6 check
all right guys your prediction she finds
it or she does no way no this is not a
move you're looking at right away i'm
i'm going to go with she finds it no
f7 would be
it's remarkable remarkable
all right no she's reaching for
something
that hesitant what what a tense
situation right now one minute for your
opponent your kings are both hanging
exactly and you know that a transition
for an end game might just be deadly for
a white exactly
and you're thinking about g you're
looking at your your mind's furiously
calculating oh no no no i'm furiously
calculating all the forcing moves so
this is the same i assume
because and to keep connection with the
b5
this makes a lot of sense to me that
movement
is a very logical move
outside geez but rook f7
get out of here i know uh rook b6 i
assume the main line would be the same
or if she has to go ruxin right now
there's no choice right there's no good
way it's a very forcing one
right you can go rook c6
but that's not conclusive at all
no no no roxy too makes a lot of sense
here that would just encourage me to
trade rooks and then i really start
thinking seriously about g4 is she going
to go for it or yes
30 seconds
by the way is jennifer like a thrill
seeker i mean she's like she loves it i
mean time pressure's always controlling
her it's pirate part of her chest oh
[ __ ]
how could you not play rook c2
it's not so easy to allow the pawn with
check the capture we check is not it's
easy not to give those pawns up a check
right yes but rook c2 was so attractive
but yes sir it's all about that queen f4
move i understand if you don't assess it
correctly
then you don't have any other options
you cannot take on f2 because you get
checkmated correct
if you go to g5 then probably the uh
the position after that is not as
conclusive well queen takes g5 and then
i go to not that one queen g5 i
understand that yeah but rook g5
actually that's a nice three yeah yeah
that falls for a checkmate wow but she
plays rook c6 since that rook what do
you think about this trick c6 but now i
can just take in rookie four and i'm
never losing that anymore right
yeah i think i think
once you get rid of that extra rook
you're so much safer
on the king side than you were before
oh yeah i mean it's like an enormous
sense of relief but sorry excuse me why
do i have to play the move rook e4 when
i do have g4
uh as well
that's a good question
cricket think it's a good question as
usual
uh
okay so how is the end game after rook
g5 rook g5
gift me the pawn right but
i mean you're not right no no i i just
uh
one two three four five one two three
four points
well these queens and ex
let's let's go back to the game position
because this is uh
um
[Music]
wow
uh with time tr time trouble looming
well we're here what am i talking about
looming
it's right there yeah we we we've
achieved time trouble yeah maybe we can
take advantage of the fact that it's
really young to play and update quickly
without moving from the video actually
she's taking on c6 sorry oh it's already
done it's already taken c6
jennifer happy to get in one more move
uh of the time control now over one
minute but still eight moves to go right
i must say that rookie four so tempting
just bring that rook back into
civilization and just but which side has
the easier player right now is the
question i
neither from my perspective it's white
for whatever reason i don't know why i
cannot explain to you why but i just
feel like white has an easier one the
double pawns on the
it's a x and by the way you always have
to worry about g4 it's a very serious by
the way this game has ended in a draw
just in wagga and brodsky they never
went anywhere not real reason to go i
didn't think it was going to be a 5-0
well christian did
you've got to take his predictions with
the grain of salt and no i was thinking
two pounds
not a pinch
but a lot
two pounds it's like a ginormous amount
of salt exactly
let's go through some results while
we're waiting for these moves
five reasons joel benjamin did draw
against larry christiansen larry he's
cementing his position on the in the
lead with three and a half points
and then we have
brandon jacobson who blundered over two
very badly against i wonder liang and
allows a wonder back in the tournament
with 50
for both players for both players that's
right and in the last result that we
have recently justin wang has drawn his
game against david brodsky both players
now
well they reached a halfway point three
draws in at the seniors uh tournament
two games remaining in the seniors we're
expecting max and monique
to us share the point and by the way
christopher you is just dominating right
now
is he yeah okay yeah let's go i was
going to say also i think that vladimir
is equally so dominating igor but i
think we're just going to see a
resignation even the first game very
soon
can we pull up the board please
yeah there we go
uh
one minute and 40 seconds by the way for
balaji tagopati what's going on in the
position materials even that's the
andrew uh versus there you go there we
go
um
but
we're that's the end of the equality
material
sure yeah but uh i mean it's just
falling apart truly queen h5 played and
where's my mate there's must be all
right all right all right guys guys guys
queen h5 check this out queen h5 bishop
g4 yes all right rectangular
bishop takes h5 guy g3 no knight g3 you
have queen h4
pt i mean then it's over i was going to
play gave me zombies myself but queen h4
is underwhelming i apologize dirk g3
which is easier calculation no queen h4
also oops um there's nothing i mean it's
over it's a bishop before just like like
let me get a piece of christian
you have your style
i'll bring you guys after the rest of
packs of salt
and salt bishop g4 is just when he's
reaching and he's reaching for it he
knows it yeah a couple of simple but
easy to calculate trick they don't work
no
there's no life in this position it was
it was really that h5 move
uh by balaji that really uh turned the
position south
uh right
i think we should go to pedro's game i
think we should stick to bishop g4 guys
just a second see he's about to play it
i want to see the reaction
whoa
that wins as well well it instantly
ricocheted
a little suggest everybody
let's suggest everybody queen e7
threatens mate rook g8 instantly on the
board okay how do we finish this off i
think rook g5 right g5 followed by
bishop g4 is one way but no that's not
that clear anymore rook g5 queen h6
bishop g4
it looks like you've got everything
under control but knight g3
defends h5 and hits the rook
at least i don't have to resign on the
spot
i yeah what you're saying yes sir but
there must be a cleaner way right well
he played queen e7 with
some very clear ideas of a follow-up and
he's
g5 queen h
okay footage says box yep and then what
i mean i expect there to be a completely
finishing blow
why can't i find it
by the way do i have to go queen h6 yes
can i go queen e8 no why i can't because
i
you don't have a threat
i take no no i take on e8 i got five
bishop h7 guys cannot allow me to be
pretty mad right we need bishop g6 and i
was gonna go check man
g6
and he did play queen h6 uh bishop g6
instead of bishop g4 so
i mean rook h5 is still a humongous
threat that's huge e8 square also it's
very important there's no more rookie
eight yeah that means that the queen
remains very very powerfully placed so
on e7 definitely
just rook f4 that's it rook for even
rook f5 i think is oh this is actually
no rook four is just simple this is good
enough this is nice
yeah yeah yeah this is game over i think
i think uh we can we can put this one to
rest well you just simply don't have
moves right agreed everything's frozen
on the queen side the king side i guess
you can go rook d8 all right where's the
finishing touch
just play with rook d8 just play move
well uh
alejandro alerted me to the idea that
the knight on g3 is going to be
undefended by the time you get to play
rook h1
and rook h1 oh it's a little bit
embarrassing
that's probably it yeah yeah that's
simple good enough
uh
probably other moves win but requests
is the easiest right total number four
followed by g4
[Music]
that should be enough
just going to check on the game of
carissa for a moment did pedro yes he
did
he's pushing his pawns and now carissa
after the move b5 carissa said look the
only way i'm gonna save the game is by
to creating some threats against your
king she's played the move g4 oh i was
almost certain she was going to play h5
you know once you play g4 and you you
you're in that desperado mode
you know
you have to be yeah exactly you start to
think h5 is almost four she took
recaptured
and
actually
move 40 for carissa and it'll be move 40
for pedro so okay not really not a big
deal but christian has a guess for us
we are indeed with rochelle wu after a
very important victory for her rochelle
welcome back to the studio yesterday a
difficult game against alia what
happened there um i was like
completely winning the entire game and
then
i decided to like
not win
did you spot uh after the game this move
rook to d7 did anybody show it to you
yeah i was okay like i s i checked it
myself and i saw it and then my mom
texted me saying she saw it now she's
like really annoyed already
but yeah well today you uh came guns
blazing with the black pieces uh did you
expect this uh choice of opening by
white
um
i mean like kinda was one of the lines i
expected
um i thought she would go like e3 first
instead bishop takes f6 but i looked at
this too
and one thing that we had actually
problems with we thought white is doing
perfectly fine and then we looked at the
engine and the engine was saying no no
no black is more or less okay maybe even
better did you feel that way i felt like
i was doing better like after b5 i was
like her bishop is pretty immobile and
like i thought this would
be like a lot easier for me to play than
her
like e4 and g4 are pretty weak i just i
didn't know what
she could do other than like throw her
pieces at the king side but i felt like
i was pretty well defended anyways well
definitely assessed it better than all
the gm's on the panel hey speak for
yourself
[Applause]
see what we have to deal with rochelle
it's a it's a rough crowd
let's keep going and uh when did you
feel like you're taking over the
initiative rochelle i mean i already
felt like i had the initiative here like
um i thought that e3 was really weak um
i played bishop d7
pretty quickly because i just thought i
could like double on the
e file and i had threats of like rook
takes e3 and bishop takes f4 and i
thought it was just like
like really easy for me to play here
let's keep going and
just
one thing rochelle one of the nice ways
of doubling rook sometimes you can play
a5
a7 to e7 too not just moving the bishop
but okay
uh yeah no we liked your position too
what you did was very very good
and this was the critical moment after
g5 yeah so i was like what did you
calculate here
uh after she played c3 i regretted
playing a5 like immediately because i
was cons i was gonna go g5 here
um instead of a5 yeah i was kind of like
i was scared of like the ship takes f5 i
think
uh
and i was looking at like
g takes f4 immediately
um g takes and then i was thinking i was
like wondering if bishop takes f4 here
works
uh
so like e takes
bishop takes
f5 or no rook takes e1 sorry
bishop takes f5 but then i can take only
eight right
with the chat wait what did i even look
at
i could've okay i
um
so maybe you can start with bishop takes
f5 first
yeah i was looking at stuff here
i was kind of scared of
um just like
instead i could have um
instead of taking on f4 could have just
like taken on f5 i guess i was kind of a
little bit worried after queen takes
i think just take one f
yeah
i was definitely like pretty worried
here um that's why i didn't go for it
originally i was like i thought i was
just gonna slowly play it out with like
a5 i was expecting knight c5
which i was going to play like bishop c8
and then i have like
i could either go like knight d7 or
bishop takes c5 and and then knight d7
because b2 is also hanging
um
i thought this was
just like i thought i was going to win
this position definitely looks good for
black right it doesn't seem like white
without the g-file open has any
any initiative
so let's go back uh he she played this
move c3 and you followed it up with g5
yeah
now she took this passive route with
knight g2 after which it just feels like
you're yeah i was really surprised you
played that actually knight h5 felt like
the only way she could continue knight
takes h5 knight takes h5 takes g3
yes and i think at this point rook to e2
i mean yeah i guess i thought i always
had like if i needed to i could play um
f4
or like maybe rook takes e3 at some
point
right and i think this was the critical
line rook take c3 rook takes c3 bishop
f4 and now bishop takes f5
oh wait what i did not see that um
and this allows white to uh come back
into the game it seems like
i i literally did not see this at all i
did not consider bishop takes f5
um
but she played this move knight to g2
which uh yeah i was really surprised she
played that actually pretty much i
believe though open the gates for your
attack
to flourish and uh
yeah beautiful victory
thank you rochelle congratulations
you're going into the rest day on high
note what are you going to do during the
rest day
i don't know probably like sleep
[Laughter]
get some rest re-energize and we'll see
you
the day after tomorrow as this game is
over uh christopher you takes a full
point against balaji da gupati and that
means that christopher is a huge leader
with a massive four and a half points
out of five excellent start there for
this young man that's going to be
one and a half points ahead of his
nearest competitor that does not sound
right because we think mishra is also
winning yes mishra yes
yes congratulations
to rochelle as we see on our screen she
did
play a very clean game a very nice game
against zoe tang two wins for black in
the girls uh championship there with
three games going and i actually expect
another one to finish if not soon well
as we see it christopher you four and a
half points now that he won against
balaji who stays on 50 percent
topsy-turvy tournament for balaji but in
the girls section talia is
doing great
i think she's just great waiting for her
opponent to resign right indeed because
i'm i'm looking at queen g6 check and
i'm looking at knight e7 check
guys have you seen mishra's position
recently not recently this is uh we were
just looking at the italia cervantes
game that we think against gracie
this is over yes um no but take a look
at mishra's position all righty
because i think we're going to see two
queens on the board
oops that's the seniors i'm sorry and
this one
andrew oh
yes takes the one we're going to see a
second queen what land on the board very
soon
and i can't go oh well rooks if i just
the worst version
but how do we assess that position okay
let's say queen to e5
g3 is forced yeah let's try to transfer
our bishop to e6 yeah
how easy is this position
uh
i don't think it's a play on one goal i
still think three results uh is possible
here well
three results might be a bit too much
because i think i do want to exchange
one pair of queens
[Laughter]
easy for you to say yeah
i want to exchange two i want to
exchange a pair of queens i want 25
million bucks yeah but i don't see
anybody giving it to me let's go queen
c7
queen's uh one of the queens to c7
which queen christian which queen what
do you mean i'm not gonna go queen b7 to
c7 and give up a queen in one
nice
it's not as early um
so just a second so we are in this
position
uh why did we reject rook c5 right away
by there's squeezy six by the way on the
board uh not c8 queen first but queen c6
right just putting the king maybe in a
worse square i like this one quincy
sucks a very important inter intro by
the way
and after king is it a war square king
g5
it feels like a horse square i'll tell
you that much well i queen
with the threat
should be worse but
wait
wait five on the board wait
because i'll do the same thing yeah and
do that queen e5 and bishop five i'll do
the same thing right let's have a
look-see
queen g5 check g3 again as you said
absolutely forced bishop f5 right guys
you go h4 i'll go king g4 i'll try to
checkmate you with my king yeah it's not
so easy actually
h4 check you'll try to check me with
your king
those are some very bold i'm joking i'm
joking i'm not going to check you with
my words christian can there be some
fighting
i don't know what's going on here it
still feels like white is uh to be
preferred right quincy right maybe not i
believe you but
i wouldn't be able to guarantee that
queen c3 but that's the thing i'm
forcing the trade of the queens i think
this is key
okay otherwise you can create too much
initiative as white as black yeah
the moment i get in something like rook
d2 and or e well e3 in this case would
walk into f4 but yes
uh
white's king is also a little bit
vulnerable i wouldn't
it wouldn't be so dismissive
there
um i'm just wondering just a second
man i have a hard time here i'm thinking
about h5 and trying to hide my king to
h6 but we have a special guest oh
thankfully thankfully all right
christian take it away
christopher a uh brilliant uh four and a
half out of five brilliant start for you
congratulations first of all how does
that feel great
going into the rest day uh one point it
seems like if mishra manages to win this
one against andrew hong how would you
assess your chances
to take the title christopher
i feel like my chances are pretty good
obviously
absolutely yes oh let's uh discuss
today's game in that case
christopher uh take us through the
opening phase
you came up with this blumenfeld gambit
how did you come up with this strategy
i just wanted to get a complicated fun
game so i thought it made sense to do
some sort of gambit or something
but the blue and felt gambit usually you
see a couple of games at the top level
and then it just disappears for the next
five years you wanted to bring it back
into the mainstream
yeah i guess
and it seemed like it worked were you
surprised by this movie e5 because we
were
yeah it was it was definitely kind of
funny because right after i tried to
gambit it's like he wants to get a bit
back just to
be on even grounds but i didn't really
think it made that much sense to gambit
his central pawn
and let's keep going with the next few
moves because i think not as much has
happened after that another big decision
after bishop to e2
rook to e8 you put the knight on f3 did
you consider at all knight to d3
and keep the file open for it
potentially your rook
i did i think i was slightly concerned
about 94 94 and castle
which definitely looks a bit dangerous
yeah queen to h4 knight to f4
i thought maybe g5 g5 and you were
worried about this yeah
makes sense makes sense well i i think
perhaps g3 you can take on g3 right yeah
yeah complicated position definitely
after this vicious attack coming your
way but you decided to go knight to f3
what was your assessment at this point
of the position
did you feel like you're in full control
not really but i think i preferred why
preferred white of course always a good
idea to be confident in your position
let's keep going
tell us the next critical moment
christopher
um
maybe
h3 was a critical moment
h3 yeah how come
because knight d5 looked very natural
but i was slightly concerned about takes
on d5 and then knight before
and i took b4 and now
it's not that easy to defend this d5
pawn it seems like yeah
okay
h3 critical moment uh let's keep going
let's keep going and uh i think we
we were analyzing your position and
trying to understand
how you should break through at this
point rook to f4 you came up with this
idea to transfer the rook on the g file
root to g4
now
this was probably his
last chance instead of h5 knight to e6
did you consider this move
yeah i thought i can just take the pawn
on b7 oh bishop we did not even look
that direction
bishop txb7 guys
the training is not working yasser
we did not even consider this bishop
takes b7 what's wrong with us
nothing's wrong with taking upon
christopher i don't know what your
problem is take the fun listen to
christopher
i like it
bishop takes b7 probably would have kept
an advantage in uh this one he played
the move h5 and after that
you converted nicely christopher
congratulations big victory for you big
start in the first five rounds
guys any questions no congratulations
christopher four and a half outstanding
result keep it up and uh we'll see on
the other side of the rest day
thank you
welcome
thank you christopher what a way to
start the tournament four and a half out
of five but there's only one better way
to start a tournament five out of five
let's take a look at see if sophie's
putting her finishing touches on that
game so we left it she was upon up and
doing really really good and i don't
think and nothing's changed actually
something has changed she might be a
second point she stopped two points in
the grade right what's better than four
and a half out of five five out of five
and what's better than one
sophie i mean she's a
girl after my own heart i can tell you
that look at her go it's over yes
absolutely she's got this game wrapped
up
boy sometimes everything goes
just like perfect then you're good you
ask yourself what did i do
to deserve this yeah right like like and
how do i duplicate it again yeah what do
i do the next time exactly h5 that's not
no i don't think it does actually h4
rook g4 so i just pushed
h
d7
it's time to do it exactly d7 looks like
it just it's gonna win she's gonna win
okay great well done but guys please
jenny for you is keeping close
to sophie because she is taking over in
this game right now time trouble too as
well right
no no i think they already were young
41. it's only one actually we left it at
rook c6 what happened christian
well let's take a look queen to d2
all right f3
this was the position where i was saying
white has secured her king side
g
three i'm not a fan
b5 and b3 always
introducing the ideas i like this bush i
really like this push for a block it's
like having a pawn on h3 against the
king right that you can always uh it's
it's close uh
jennifer for choice oh absolutely not
only for choice jennifer right now
objectively is completely winning
completely winning that's more than i
expected more than two pawns advantage
minus 2.2 right now wow
okay
wow
well how do you defend against this move
queen to c2 so why do you play next what
but why is quincy to a threat
uh let's say i pass
but i'm not so easy how am i going to
pass
okay let's say i go queen f2 you go
queen
gonna
seat
back yeah let's pretend then you go back
and then i make a waiting move look to
g5 let's see it's not a way
this is this okay
a waiting room a waiting move it
threatens me
[Laughter]
i mean okay some obscure h4
did you hear that obscure actually
that's not funny i'm scared
i'll make a waiting move but i promise
the waiting move i'll make a waiting
it's takes takes if i come back with the
rook e4 i'm afraid of this uh
breakthrough e4
takes
five
and not looking good guys that's just
over yeah and now i'm stuck
so you're telling me that
white's basically zug-zong mm-hmm
tom loves it
that's the one concept in chess that
he's got uh
nailed deadly sue's fun
wow okay
what a turn of events and
with the victory right now jennifer
would be on four out of five only one
point
behind sophie mori suzuki you start with
five out of five and you expect that
you're going to have at least one point
and a half two games cushion right you
don't have that you only have one direct
encounter and we will look for that
pairing between jennifer
and says is it happening in round six
is it
i don't know producers
do your matches
all right very good
we'll check uh for you there christian
as uh we see this game i wanted to tell
you let me just
let me just see
every time i check in on tell you like
it's it's weird things are going on in
her games i
it's around six months round seven round
seven is a key matchup of sophie versus
uh jenny for you
and i'm expecting that talia will play
the move queen f6 which she's just done
and that is a real clincher
and jennifer will have black in that key
match up between sofia and jennifer
talia's winning
let me go to the um
uh seniors just for a second
nothing happening there nothing is
happening in that one and this was the
game where i thought igor was in deep
trouble and wow it's just over that's a
lot of fun
and you're getting checkmated if you
move the rook away if you move the rook
away from the e file i go king g4 h5 the
game is over probably the game is over
so just go c6 c7 c8 and then king g4
kind of surprised that igor has oh i
guess what he wants is a stalemate so
yeah some kind of d3
somehow you get rid of this bomb so c6 b
takes c6 b takes c6 d3 and now if you
take on d3 i go rookie three and that's
the crazy rook right and now after king
g4 i don't take your bishop but i go
rook g3 oh
and then i take your bishop
and it still might be long
and they're still losing i'll be very
happy to go with my pawns right i mean
just to make sure i don't make sense no
i'm not sure about it
i don't want to make
this game is super dead right yeah it's
super dead
but it's just nice that there's a
stalemate uh trick it just answers the
question why is he still thinking right
right he's just trying to make sure that
he's not going to fall for i was
actually wondering why
nick defermine is still thinking do we
have a relay error there somehow because
he he's been thinking on rook takes e5
for what now feels like forever this
might be already a draw right right
can we get the camera on this two
players takes e5 well i guess he's
thinking he might be better after queen
takes e5 he might be better after d
takes e5
well he actually played so i guess she
did take that long all right
okay queen c1 only move exactly
queen c1 only move why would you be
better
well
well no well the question was queen c3
if i could get in queen b4 or not i go
rd5 i don't know
i don't see it
d5
no it
okay i don't see it guys
i will
give it a rest well to be honest taking
with a deep one doesn't make a very good
impression on me queen c1 queen c3
followed by rook d5
and once again i'm starting to feel like
it is white who has better chances i can
follow it up if you allow me with the
move c5 after that i don't know this
change of structure doesn't inspire me
at all
well it was based on the idea i was
playing queen b4
and that doesn't work yeah right yeah
and i was trying to get
to target the pawns but actually c3 does
it work
so maybe just go there and then
after b1 rook d8 and rook to d4
probably that's
a simple equality
and now i guess
i do have a plan i don't want to get my
kings
what is this come on there's so many
interesting things
fine
i want to go back to the carissa game
against pedro espinosa just because
things happened and i'm not really sure
they happened in the favor of black you
still
you still have two extra pass pawns on
the queen side i assume black's winning
but the queen's got cozied up over here
yeah this queen uh you got more counter
play than you think
also at some point i remember black's
request on like a2 or something
pedro
what are you doing pedro the rook was on
a2
oh but it got traded it got traded uh
not sure why i'm trading it on purpose
but whatever
this is not easy this is a three result
game right now it's kind of a mess right
it's a complete because right he played
rugby
because bishop takes g4 bishop g4 i take
i go probably maybe e6 six yeah
okay
this is a complete mass
okay let's see what's going on here to
be honest
i think arisa has great chances to win
this one you think so i'll call it right
now you're gonna call it no
she has great chances i don't know if
she will be able to win it but she has
great colleagues
okay so so go ahead so the idea is that
if i play g5 what you need to do is put
the bishop on this diagonal right but
that's pretty lethal yes exactly um
right so i i'm saying the the these are
the things as black that i'm fearful of
but if i go knight f eight just how
how do you know this bishop
he did play knight f8
but what if i reroute the bishop bishop
g5 yeah
this way makes perfect sense to me
uh
whoa
the desirable queen c7 has a flaw
[Laughter]
it's life flow right as well
it's time
bishop i don't see anything super clear
um can i
if i could treat that question by the
way yeah oh knight of hate played yeah i
was about to say if i could trade queens
i would be over over
joined but how do you trade queens i was
going to take i take on g6 exactly no
time for queen g5
not only that but i have a feeling that
i have some ideas with rook c7 yeah at
the end like this
this this never mind not really seven
but none of this should take c5
actually bishop c5 already played
none of this has been played he went
queen h6 which is a c5 let me refresh my
board i apologize
bishop c5
that's a decent move
well the threat's obvious
how do i get rid of the threads less
obvious
maybe queen d8
queen
ah yeah it is written it's queen h4 yeah
and and it protects against bishop takes
f8 because you take with the queen with
which is a game of tempo against the
queen
okay i like this but i love them i love
them
great defensive move queen d8
you see
the blind
chicken finds the seed
is that the expression goes yeah no that
that's that's victor korchner
but he was describing my moves sometimes
the blind chicken
finds the the the corn i think is what
he calls you see the bullied kids become
uh the guy become the bully themselves
guys can we go back to the acopian game
and it's fun i guarantee that it's
actually winning
oh no no no no don't tell me i have no
idea if it's still winning but he did
fall straight into it did he really yeah
the hair straightened through the one
the one trick that exists in the
position igor played the move
instead of designs no no no but king d4
guys
oh wait never mind rook to e3
what is this move king to e4
so the game end can we maybe can we
switch to the camera view of akopian
against khalmanitsky
no no that means white one so one
white king is on e4 i don't get it he's
on defense i am why did he resign more
than confused about everything that's
just happened
guys why why did he resign he just got
his record e3
the one good cheapo in the whole
game what
i i don't get it i i don't know i
wouldn't resign i don't know what
happened what happened
because we're a little confused that's
what this is when the game starts
finally is king takes e3 as a stalemate
and this is the whole thing that black
is playing for
is please take my rook so you would have
for example
shacks and we call this the mad rook
where
you know you get some kind of perpetuals
but in the game the final i know but in
the final position he has king g4
as a way of avoiding the mad rook
because you can't go here
oops but yasser is not a mad look after
king f2
can you have two rook f3 king rookie
three king d2 if you take on d3 i take
back you can take on g6
ah thank you you're right no but you
just take the bishop right yeah after
king f2 you just take the bishop and the
game flares anew and but we're assuming
king g4 is why he resigned rook g3 king
f5 and i mean okay sure maybe you're
winning but i mean is it based on rook
c2 and c7 is it based on i don't know
unless you try yeah you make that guy
you played up to this point right right
you played it out to this point you
didn't recite it afterwards like three
it was like the the the the the girl who
resigned in the drawn position
yeah oh
yeah i mean okay
it's raining strange
bizarre well i'm sure we're going to
have
one zero
on the
relay we do we do so we are assuming
vladimir has got this sorry uh christian
you were perhaps that was just guys
maybe that was just an analysis on on
the board
i would assume that was just some sort
of an analysis maybe malnitsky was
showing him
what could have been
that's the only explanation that they
can come up with we'll have somebody
soon here to explain it to us it is
played at the same level as chess club
and we are at the seniors justin
tell us in a second queen d8 is a good
question
this is definitely absolutely 1 000
not the finishing
if that position is illegal illegal
thank you producers uh but let's let's
take
let's take a look at the cursor game
against pedro bishop e3 no that's the
queen h4 check yeah
then she's misplayed it the move bishop
c5 was false that was a false step she
might have been but i have them with
queen eight not queen d8
on mine uh yes sir okay i don't know if
it makes a difference but well let me
refresh in any case if the queen is on
your right it is on e8 not on dna but
that makes a big difference because
that's why we were we we were eyeballing
um with the queen on d8 the h4 square
we're not longer does it change anything
like do i have a threat here
i'm wondering can i
somehow play bishop
to d6 and rook to c7 you can play bishop
d6 i just don't know if i care like if i
play b3 and
i was going to go rook down anyway
b2
yeah
and bishop here will maybe be met by a
queen sacrifice
yeah yup
wow
holy smokes um
it started a little more suspicious than
it should be right
it feels like there might be some tactic
in the air but i if
not no
guys i think uh sophie might be putting
the finishing touches right now so okay
you can look at that game sure
i think uh our resignation will arise on
the board very soon
oh rook takes g7 that's another point
but i tell you i i think it's not only a
pawn yeah that that unveils the uh black
king as well
and after queen takes g7 d8 i think
they're that just kills
nice
very nice
take on d8
queen takes the e8 it takes the e8
followed by rook to d7
to d7 as well as queen takes h4
so
let's keep an eye on this one yeah and i
think am i about to promote resignation
may be imminent after the move rook
takes jesus oh she's already playing
queen she already she played queen takes
you seven and she already promoted to d8
all right
and this is yes just game
five out of five guys wait a start
please it's amazing i haven't seen this
since fabiano carrana
okay but this game is over exactly yeah
i'm still impressed also by christopher
used four and a half guys remember the
rule we have to see the handshake we
have to see the pain
uh i tell you uh watching that one game
of a wonder liang where he he
he turned a win into a loss
that was the pain
i mean that was tough to watch
and she has captured the queen on d8 and
very quickly sophie said i will take
your rook
she's having the tournament of her life
right
it's been it's incredible everything is
just everything works yeah you get your
prepping you're playing the good moves
and your opponents resign and your
opponent's reason that's very nice ellen
wang loses then to sophie morris suzuki
our miss perfect simply unstoppable
nothing seems to be
working for anybody else the moment you
play against sophie
jennifer you will play black against
sophie in round seven round seven who
will sophie play in round six
well aren't you full of excellent
questions yasser and i have the answer
for you that's a surprise she's playing
ree young yan with the black pieces in
round six okay a challenge and we have a
guest with christian
thank you yasser we are here with a
newcomer into the u.s seniors
championship vladimir kopian welcome to
st louis welcome uh to our show how does
it feel to be playing here in st louis
very well i'm very happy to play here
and in general it's a very good
opportunity of course for
players over 50 like like me
and
i would like to
thank of course everybody here uh who
made this possible and especially of
course uh rex thinkfield for this
opportunity now take us a little bit
through your tournament after this point
you started off with the white pieces
you got a winning position out of the
opening in that one but unfortunately
weren't able to convert
how did you deal with that loss
yeah by now i'm just i'm losing uh very
good opportunities not not only the
first one of course was very striking
but
also in my game with gurevich i missed
yesterday also it was a very good
position
okay what to do yeah as a chess player i
mean i'm used to this so it's normal
losing a
winning position winning lost positions
uh yeah of course it's somehow very
painful when you uh get this but
actually i can't
i can tell you what happened i i had to
play of course on this on the 39th move
of course being b5 it was much simpler
but somehow i felt about the z5 move
that this is wrong
because this was uh
such a move bishop on d5 was
standing there and now e5 so i somehow i
figured out that queen a7 should be
right move the only of course the thing
is that you should of course um
calculate the 40s move at this point
40th movies
yeah but what i did i i just i did not
see at all the queen d7 move but somehow
i saw knight f5 and i thought okay after
knight f5 at least i keep a draw so
there is draw after knight five only to
discover after uh rook f7 of course is
the move that i will calculating and my
intention was to play queen a6 of course
not queen f2 and this is what i had to
do and it's still it's uh
yeah it's still a game it's
i mean it's it's probably draw i mean
it's impossible to hold but the point
was after rook b7 my calculation was 97
check and then i have this draw
everywhere only to discover already
after 40th move that king f7 and when
calculated i had calculated queen g6
king take c7 coming to hg7 and just
completely forgot about bishop
yeah yeah and and somehow i discovered
this and at this point i you know i was
very disappointed i thought that this
just lost position yeah any move would
lose i even saw after when i say rugby
sound b3 c takes b3 but for some reason
c3 only calculated not c4 and okay i
decided that okay i just i miscalculated
i'm just losing so queen f2 i thought
okay i had to do something or resign
immediately yeah and this is what
happened actually but after that one you
did bounce back with a victory against
shabalov in round three and now finally
with another big victory with the white
pieces take us uh through today's game
actually uh yeah today's game um i mean
i i analyzed this line of course queen
takes d5 and bishop c4 is mainline i
analyzed this uh some time ago and i
conclude
my conclusion was that uh somewhere in
the end game right it was much better
but i just could not remember
i mean i of course i did not expect this
today this line and i just couldn't
remember and if you you are not
remembering this you can't afford going
into this line right with my king
somewhere on e2 or d1
and i tried to remember but i just
failed and then i decided okay probably
no advantage but i can't say that yeah i
just play safe probably nothing i mean i
believe black is just in total control i
mean any move uh
i mean i don't know d4 should be played
or not it's possible i believe without
d4 after d4 say
knight h4 queen f6 was strange i thought
just bishop take d3 and queen d5 next i
believe it's it's also normal like that
i don't this is actually what the engine
was also recommending bishop takes d3
and uh potentially queen d5 try to take
it uh yeah that's where d5
centralization i mean i i don't know if
something but it's probably it's
probably just black black is a
normal position i thought maybe queen f3
i have to play but okay this just but he
played this move queen to f6 and this
allowed you to uh take yeah this should
be better for white but somehow i
believe i was not playing well and i
just i was i mean i have everywhere some
some additional opportunities many of
them and i always i was choosing
something bad i believe
uh
yeah this this i calculate something
my main my main calculations were like
rook e4 for some reason but then 97 95
93 quickly i did not like this
again maybe some were miscalculated but
king g2 another move that i was
calculating here but king g to g5
somehow i did not like
uh and then i decided okay maybe queen
e2 i just keep this position i don't
allow rook e8 maybe queen g2 at some
point so that i think that's a very safe
and
precise move in fact uh g5 maybe would
have been a bit more decisive but
queenie two
maintains a pretty yeah here again i
didn't know i mean i beat xa4 probably
possible i just i i was
i don't know i
uh mean is also possible and then a5 i
secure this uh winning end game
everywhere
but then okay this before i mean i don't
spoil my position yet but somewhere
around here i i started
spawning i believe this all i mean h4 b5
very unfortunate i believe i think h4
was fine as well
yeah but b5 b5 is different um
g5 rook e6 uh
here somewhere i don't know something
happens here i don't know if this is
all right or not it's still more or less
all right yeah you're still winning
completely winning
yeah here somewhere already winning but
since b5 i did not like i mean i was
just cursing myself or this b5 move a3
is always hanging i mean any move would
do here i believe
g5 rook is six maybe simpler
especially already like
approaching time trouble playing
something like b5
vera
i mean
this anti-positional move
but i just uh somehow i i i could not
actually understand what is going on
here and just
i think you're too much of a
perfectionist vladimir because this one
was pretty good as well
after that tell us what happened at the
end we were a bit confused because
let's go all the way until the end
and uh this is the position we saw on
yeah king g4 our broadcast okay okay
okay so we saw the position after b b
takes c6 rookie three and then a king on
e4 and we were like okay what happened
no no btx is a king g4 yeah this was uh
but you played king g4 first yes yeah i
played king g4 here after b take c6 i
can't play king g4 yeah uh i mean black
can take first bit xs and then d3 but
then maybe rook d2 something like this
and then after b5 i'm still winning yeah
yes yes but probably spoiled already
something no no no not yet still still
very significant edge congratulations
vladimir guys any questions no uh
vladimir nice game if anything uh the
critical moment for me was i was
surprised by queenie 2 which doesn't
spoil anything you have a very big
advantage but i was really surprised you
didn't go for the very forcing line with
g5 h takes g5 queen g4 because this just
looked like you know you were just
taking
a complete
control of the game if he takes on f4
beside rook e6 you can also play bishop
takes and it just
wow
very very very impressive yeah
definitely probably g5 should be played
i mean i was calculating this um
every move the g5 is possible but
somehow i thought just uh
i mean i was afraid to spoil everything
i thought that okay
as long as
white's position i mean positionally
very good i should not spoil this so if
queen e2 keeps
some edge then i
this i mean my g5 possible but again i
was concentrating on this rook e4 mainly
king g2 and queen e2 move yeah queen
f395 something
so i always comes with g5 possible but
again i don't know
i just probably yeah probably this is
right yeah this is like decisive way to
treat this position
congratulations uh you're fighting your
way back into the game after
this hiccup i want to say uh but uh
looking forward to the free day
yeah okay what to do
are you tired after five rounds vladimir
uh not put much pressure uh on you but
you were my pick to win the event so
keep it up
okay
thank you vladimir and
we will uh prepare ourselves for a break
but before we go a couple of results uh
aleandra as we have seen talia cervantes
did win converted that position against
gracie prasanna very nice
well she's now one point away
from she's keeping contact with uh
sophie yeah and in the
and by the way when will tell you also
play against all your favorites and the
last round the last round
and sophie as we saw did win against
ellen wang right
that was the five
the perfect
and look at sophie's score look at this
five out of five and
she's with us
cheers indeed uh sophie maurice suzuki
the only perfect player in the event
congratulations what a dominant
performance
you know it's funny because um the first
time i played in this event in 2018 i
lost all my first five games and this is
like my last time i'm playing in the
event because of um because i won't be
age eligible anymore after this year so
it's only fitting that i won all my
first five games
let's take a look at this last game
before the rest day
let's take a look at this one tell us
the critical moments
sophie uh yeah so i think the first like
critical moment was after
um
i think after
queen c4 it was and then
queen c7 yes knight to f3 oh yeah we'll
get there
yeah
yeah so she played this move f5 how did
you assess this move what
did you understand the consequences of
this move f5 what was your thought
process at this point
um
well i
expected black to go for like f5 and e5
uh because i thought that was like
that's just kind of what you do in this
position so i i was you know i was more
or less expecting it and i was at first
like i was planning to play bishop b2
um
and then maybe like rook d1 and like
this is what we thought you were going
to go for calculated a lot of things
here and none of them seemed to work for
me um and then i
so because of that i had to i thought i
had to come with something else so then
i found bishop v3 which is actually i'm
kind of proud of myself i think that's a
pretty good move it's a great move it's
it's the best move by the engine and the
best plan in this position it's so
difficult to find because you just play
the move b3 right you feel like you want
to put that bishop on b2 but then you
change course perfectly change course
and take over the initiative now
any other moments in which you felt like
maybe she has enough compensation for
the pawn or you just felt like you kept
control of the game well um there was
around this point like and like for the
next few moves i mean for a while i was
just kind of like shuffling and i was
like i don't really know what i'm doing
but
i i guess i managed to like arrange my
pieces and um
you know some good squares that i liked
especially like 92 i thought
once i was able to get this i was pretty
confident
at first i didn't play at first like i
was really hesitant about this because
um well i have i hesitated to play 92
because i always thought it was rick f3
but then i but then h4 queen g4 rick
takes f3 wins
so
i only was able to play 92 once i saw
this
absolutely and that was pretty much the
last critical moment after that
you converted precisely this game sophie
five out of five you are watching the
game i would assume right now the game
between rue yang and jennifer because
these are your next two opponents in
round six and seven how do you feel
about
those two
games um i
i hope the rest day is gonna help me you
know just like
just
i don't know just chill out for once and
then
you know hopefully
i'll be
informed you know do you have any
favorites in that game that's still
pending right now uh
hmm what's the position currently like i
think last time i checked it was kind of
like i thought it was a little scary for
white but it is it's a rook's end game
right now the queens have been traded
off there's a pawn on b3 it looks really
scary
but how would you assess this one
oh this is looking like closer and
closer to uh i
think a
draw uh maybe i don't know i
but but oh there's also okay black and
playback ga and rick
ca there's i don't know still feels
quite complex right maybe not i don't
know
i have no idea um
well you took care of business in your
game sophie congratulations for an
incredible first five rounds
look at that score lineup i mean this is
just dominant
congratulations sophie
we'll see you in the rest of your games
and right now we will be taking a
commercial break we will be back shortly
stay with us
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
united states
the st louis chess campus in the heart
of the vibrant central west end has
established itself as a premier global
destination for chess and is comprised
of two unique non-profit institutions
the chess club and scholastic center of
st louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world and plays host to
all major tournaments including the us
chess championships and the sinkfield
cup one of the strongest chess
tournaments globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries led by an expert
commentary team of grand masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess with a specific focus on
bringing the benefits of chess to
children throughout the st louis area
research shows children who play chess
exhibit improved analytical skills and
increased confidence the chess club is
highly engaged with the local community
bringing scholastic chess programs to
more than 100 schools providing hundreds
of classes each week
directly across the street from the
chess club is the world chess hall of
fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the us and world chess halls
of fame
cutting edge exhibitions feature rare
historic chess artifacts paired with
world-class art innovative programming
explores the intersection of chess art
and culture
visitors can enjoy interactive programs
designed around the exhibitions and
monthly music in the galleries
the world chess hall of fame is nothing
you expect and everything you love three
different galleries and a premier gift
shop highlight the culture history and
creativity behind the game come visit
play chess leave enriched to learn more
about the st louis chess campus visit
stlchestcampus.org
[Music]
so
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everybody as we return
round five of the championships in saint
louis the junior the junior girls and
the seniors as we are entering what
should be our fifth hour of play we are
still have a bunch of games left we sure
do it seems like every day where the the
players some of the players are playing
to the very very last drop
this game
of um
mishra is going to be
a long game still i mean i've got a
feeling uh you i know
in case uh not everybody knows that this
is alejandro's last day of broadcast
he's on his way to zagreb because he's
got to get ready for the grand chess
store
we're going to miss you
uh but we're not letting you go
easily
you're not escaping uh like that
alejandro you know
for
is making sure that i will be here for
another couple hours let's take a look
at the position right now because we
have a situation
in which we have a queen against a rook
and a bishop exactly certainly the rook
is the uh sorry the queen queen is a
stronger piece than the combination of
pieces but
i don't know you can actually win this
no i've i have
i'm quite confident saying that black
should uh make a draw here uh you could
play uh for ideas of g6 king g7 h5 uh
that would be
my approach to try to get in the movie
the problem is i think you lose a pawn
if you do that okay if i go g6 queen d4
sorry queen queen d4 david four queen g7
okay and i go h5 and then i take
and should i check you first that's okay
i was okay i'll take
queen g5 uh-huh
and
i take
and check f3 f3
f3 of course i'm blind sorry
i was blind what i'm saying is that it
probably is a draw but your king is
still not in the best position right and
it's not as easy to bring it back if my
king was on g8 it'd be simple yeah i was
thinking about getting g5
for a while let's switch the jennifer
game because that one is over
in um
we can actually put that on the
live screen maybe we can cross the shot
of the players
jennifer did bring her rook all the way
back yeah we're expecting
she brought her rook all the way to c2
and that's where she's
uh
forced the trade of rooks
got herself into a king and pawn end
game wait a minute king it is just over
yes
oh there's a pawn on d4
i didn't see that part
that was a very important part
and that should do it that should be a
queen d3 check yeah it's a big victory
for jennifer and there you go young
resigns against jennifer you complicated
game start to finish all five games in
the girls championship were decisive wow
wow everybody swinging for the fences in
this one alejandro yeah no doubt about
it riyang yang two and a half points
against jennifer hughes surging four she
started very slow only two draws but
she's bounced back with three wins in a
row she was seeing what sophie was doing
to the field she said my goodness i've
got to keep pace
and she's come with abrasive victories
uh hat trick in fact three in a row for
jennifer and i think we should uh
probably take a look at what charissa
and pedro are doing as
well it should be over soon right that
one yes i thought there's
in the position she had been fighting
back but then
she actually fought back all the way to
equality i was checking this over the
break
wow which is very impressive and when
she just had it in her
she let us she let it slip she blundered
it away and this is the current position
now with the move rook f6 i don't know
if there's an actual threat in this
position exactly the question is
is she going to well you might have to
try something right you have to rook
rook takes e6 is kind of hoping the
black ghost b2
okay which actually doesn't win
really yeah because
no this i don't think has the thread you
just promote right but that was what i
wanted to do
actually does force you to take and
because of the major g7 kind of
shockingly i actually take out c2 uh
oh
yeah and then i not only that i actually
also capture the bottom oh which is the
only way of blundering the position but
he's playing the move queen eight which
i like a lot i mean that's a safety move
it's a safety move you cover both
e6 g6 even the potential of
rook takes f7 and i think this is
by the way the white queen is trapped
that queen is so sad yeah he's such a
sad queen i mean allowing black to have
played the move g5 was
very just very wrong yeah well i also
think that bishop c5 move it wasn't
convincing in my eyes i really like that
idea of bishop e3 bishop g5
she had a big big opportunity there to
put some serious problems
i even thought that after the move uh
bishop d6
if we can go to move uh
yeah i thought rookie rick takes c8 is
actually fine for i have to take with
the bishop no you can't
oh i was a i was afraid to allow this
well that's fine but if you play bishop
takes c8 i think i play uh bishop 665 or
ah
yeah
e6 i know it's an incredible shot
really nice shot i can't play queen
takes e6
queen takes fa check oh and if you go 96
you go but if i take with the rook i was
afraid of bishop here well yeah scary
position perhaps this is what you have
to defend and that's not h7
but now you and then it's just a drawing
and i think it's just a draw yeah you
take it
so maybe
yeah rook city was rook c8
yeah oh my theresa
she didn't do it she went rook h1
and actually rick h1 was fine i put it
in the engine as well really yeah with
the idea of opening up the h file knight
h7 is best which is also shocking okay
you want to open up the h file i get
that okay but now you have to take on g6
i mean
the time has passed to do anything else
because this was the moment yeah
allowing g5 just traps the queen oops
she forgot about i forgot about g5 yeah
and this is how they got to the current
position
oops we're not going to play a queen e8
pardon me that was on the board
let me just refresh my board for just a
second and b2 played and i think that's
pretty much it right
this pawn
hard to stop when you don't have any
counter play and a queen
yeah
wow
um
i don't know uh
carissa's approach to this game again
she's just playing against the lowest
rated player in the field so she feels
like like she has to win but she also
feels like i'm gonna win by not playing
any theory yeah no no not how it works
not exactly and
black got actually very good opening um
pedro but we have to give it to pedro he
he played a pretty good game he did
maybe he missed his chances his best
chances and allowed karissa back into
the game nevertheless he did find a lot
of good moves he got into a winning
position after that i know it wasn't
easy to handle right right and still
none of the players handled it perfectly
and now he's still making the last
mistake and that's the most important
thing in truss
b2
a move
she really does anything
isn't it as quiet as is queen a
four
time
take your pick yeah
yeah because i'm kind of ding ding
[Music]
uh this night on h7 is
of
beastly is trapping
the queen
covers f8 covers g5 what an awesome
knight the pawn on d5
stops never mind the fact that bishop is
already pinned it stops bishop e4 the
knight on h7 is just holding up the
entire fort
great
yeah beautiful position and uh beautiful
conversion by pedro i have to say
and
once again the game of mishra let me
just bring this up you were saying that
the king
on f6 is awkwardly placed
christian that makes
that that's giving white
uh
some chances some chances uh how does
the engine evaluate the position
therefore the engine doesn't really
understand very well what's happening
right now it's uh close to a two-point
advantage nevertheless it doesn't find
the exact way in which to make progress
i think that would confuse a lot of
people yes
your comment that you just made like my
mom if i said to my mom the engine
doesn't understand the position my mom
would say but aren't the engines the
strongest
chess players
aren't they the highest rated chess
players yes they are so how could the
engines not understand the position i
don't understand i mean that i just
understand the position what are you
saying chris
what do you mean they don't know well
because of the fortress it's a fortress
so the engine is saying the engine is
saying by the way not after the move h4
before the move h4 it was giving a plus
to advantage for white now we consider
that as an objectively winning advantage
nevertheless given that this is a
fortress that means that the engine
doesn't see far enough to understand
it's a fortress therefore the engine is
wrong
does that make sense alejandro i get it
but it's was it actually a fortress like
do do we get there because every every
line well after h4 is definitely a
fortress yeah after h4a because i can go
g5 and and this seems to be the main
difference because i was playing around
with it
and it does give plus two which is not a
winning advantage right but you also
have to shed the h-bone as black like
straight up shattered no not even for
the h point of white oh he's and then
those positions i'm not so sure our
fortress okay
but at this moment yeah i think this is
just not so difficult and we have a
guest with christian
we are indeed with a lady that won her
third consecutive game congratulations
jennifer welcome back take us through
the feelings that you have right now um
thank you so
i honestly don't really know how to feel
about my game i think um i was
definitely pretty happy with my position
out of the opening because i mean she
kind of just gave me a pawn and it was
like okay so it's like a kind of like a
plane for two results
um and then at some point i like i think
i made it a little bit too complicated i
was missing some details here and there
so i tried to like fix it with like
teenage seven um i played that but
i don't i gave her some time i'm not
exactly sure what the evaluation
position was it was really complicated
and i like i spent too much of my time
so then i was just like you know what i
will just play this and i think the
first surprise for us is that you chose
the real opus instead of your usual
sicilian
how did you come up with that strategy
um no i do play this like more often but
i don't play like the um this knight f6
very early because i looked at her um
when i prepared her she always plays
like d3 right away so i was like okay i
mean i didn't have anything that special
but um that's what i was expecting and
said she did um
yes she did
well she did d3 after
um castles and well i wanted to
well my prep was i was to play some like
prayer but i don't think there's like
nylon c3 so then i wasn't really sure
what to do but i think this was okay i
also i don't know um exactly the opening
but i thought like knight f4 instead of
h3 might have been just like
pull up like i like that better for
white but maybe it's just the idea being
that you go h3 now and you don't have
any squares for the bishop yeah because
i was afraid of getting uh um bad bishop
versus goodnight
right and then she kind of um made sure
it didn't happen so which really was
really nice for me and she gave you this
pawn with e5 but you took it with the
bishop and now
instead of taking with the knight did
you consider a queen to e2 first yeah
that was my um that was what i expected
uh so i was really surprised when she
took on e5 and also when she played
rookie one because i thought queenie two
i mean here rookie one makes sense it's
not rookie four
but
i i
the opening of the queen side um did
help me a bit because otherwise i think
she could just take the pawn pretty
easily
so this was just some counter play
now you're upon up but obviously there
is some clear compensation and quite a
difficult path at work towards making
any progress at this point um
were you playing for uh for for a win
right now yeah um i mean i did like my
position i mean it's definitely a little
bit difficult but like when you um if
you go back a few moves and when i
played king h7 that was just because
like i i wanted to play um queen c1 but
uh there i think there's rook takes e4
um
and then like i was looking roxy too but
i just don't have enough time rook to e8
and then queen e4 i think
and then white just stops everything and
let's show that maybe queen to c1 rook
to d4 no no at that point
instead of king h7 quick c1 yeah rook
takes d4
yeah because it just works out perfectly
for us
yeah rook c2 rook d8
king h7 and now queen to e4
and uh
yeah don't get to her
to her king yeah i'm just thinking move
too slow i think because then rook d7
yes that looks very conclusive after
rookie seven
nice calculation and you decide to uh
prepare that with the move king to h7
now
i want to take you to this uh moment
rook to b7
queen to c1 king to h6 so you repeat it
once and then with one minute on the
clock you play the move king to h6
were you worried that she has something
at this point and did you see anything
um i i think i saw some things uh well
even after she tried the works off i
think white is okay there there should
be some moves did you see this move rook
f7 right now no i wasn't expecting rook
f7 does it
yeah what is happening
um
so i guess the idea is
uh
rook
rooks
yes and then i think you have to force
this end game with queen to f4
queen to f4 which is still
probably slightly better for you but
very much close to equality yeah i mean
that was kind of like a worst case
scenario if queen g4 ever happened i
always have queen f4 um like i couldn't
figure out like obviously i couldn't
figure out for sure if whether kh6 was
safe or not but
i mean
i have this position and i just if i
took a draw here i would just feel
horrible so
yeah i mean i i think it was worth the
risk even though i definitely should not
have done this with like one minute on
the clock
no i think it was a good decision
practically um
king to g6 was indeed just because
you're not allowing rook f7 was the more
precise move but king h6 still
a fighter's move at this point rook to
b6 rook to c6
we were surprised by rook to c6
yeah rook to c2 it seems like it would
have
won the game right now
um
i would assume you calculate the drove
to c2 yeah but i wasn't sure so rook
takes e6 um g6 and then i think queen g
going to g4 queen to f4
queen f4 oh and then just now the work
on h4 is stuck
wait i thought i looked at this
what did i do
yeah
oh right right yeah this is right i
played rook c6 because i was planning
this right away and then um i just
played rook c6 because i was like i
can't figure out for sure if i'm not
missing anything well you also had like
30 seconds on the clock yeah but yeah i
remember because i thought if she played
rook b8 um i would do
what can play roxy wait no that's a
different thing she played r8 here
i think you can play roxy too there's
rook h5 right
oh rook h5 king g6 queen g4 yeah this
works
yeah so i would have to play g6 after v8
good point
yeah and once again whenever she goes
queen g4 you go queen f4 and you go into
that winning game game
very nice but
it seemed like she was getting close to
achieving equality did you feel that way
yeah i did but um i mean
here i'm not so sure about this g4
um i mean the second she let my pawn to
be three i thought i just much better
chances
i don't know
objectively what it is but also we were
both getting low here on time
and after this i think i think this end
game has to be winning it's winning okay
definitely nicely done yeah jennifer
congratulations now four out of five in
a convention
a conventional tournament would be a
pretty high score but there is one lady
on a perfect score five out of five
you're going to be playing her in round
seven are you already looking to that
forward to that matchup
yeah i mean she's playing very really
well so i think it'd be an interesting
game um
but yeah i mean i
kind of believe in like
like making your own luck so like
if i have a shot against her then i'd
have to take it
perfect congratulations uh jennifer
we'll see you after the rest day
our congratulations as well jennifer and
this one is over pedro with the big
upset a win against international master
karissa yip
and that is huge for our top seed bottom
seed of the event
wow pedro wow
and what a victory of
crazy developments are going on in the
game between max and nick when we left
it it was just a major piece ending
equal material we had been expecting a
draw
but
nick got bamboozled
and somehow uh
he
uh he's given his opponent i mean it's
still equal material but white is the
one who's got
the uh outside passer and uh
nick is suffering
maybe he's not suffering that much but
uh i would prefer to have the white
pieces
he's suffering for sure i mean yeah work
on e6 it's not very active
right not at all but this one is going
to be a long drawn out enemy that's what
i'm thinking as well let's uh
go to the remaining game abi manu
against andrew hong
right we have a bunch of new moves we do
and we have a very pressing question on
our hands big decision right now right
yes
yeah h5 do you take this pawn you have
to
you what i think you have to i don't
know if i have to what else
king f6 just feels like something could
go wrong right yeah queen different
cringey summon okay
if i have to let's say i have to
uh this end game is an easy draw right
no no no no no rook g5
sorry what's that
you just take on e6 and go rogue d5
no but that's lost i i i sorry what
should i do take on e6 and go rook do
you think h5 by the way but this is lost
what do you mean it's lost with an e or
a d-pawn it's a draw with an f or a g
pawn
that's why i was trying to keep oh yeah
so i know if the pawn is on g7 it's an
easy easy draw yeah with the pawn on g7
it's an easy job but with the pawn
already all the way in g4 g's i don't
know h6 and g4 i might be losing this i
mean okay like for example what does
that say i have a table base it's a draw
it's a draw yeah
but it's losing with the pawn on e6
it's losing with the pawn on e6 yeah
which we kind of thought by the way uh
he did take on h5 f5 played
quickly
andrew the capture on g4 yeah king f6
doesn't work which is funny
so rook to g5 is uh the big move right
king f6 oh excuse me uh that is funny uh
you want to play rook to e5 and win your
opponent's queen
you're welcome
thank you
and let's go
push him um
so yes we want to take on chief rook e6
what that
feels a little dangerous suspicious
why did he play that no no no that
cannot be he wants to keep the pawn on
f7 but
i'm thinking i i have the time now to
take on h5 you can't
move your king
can i go to f8 no but queen d4 is a
tempo
and then check ah you have a check on b1
ooh
actually not so easy huh
okay oh no never mind you have queen a8
after king of f8
yes
check that's a check
ten seconds ten seconds for mishra
what's the what's the israel what are
you doing now with the bottom h5 take on
h5 what do you
f wow
i didn't see that move coming check you
can't take it because of queen d4
but is he sure
that he's going to have enough
checkmating threats f6 a very committal
move
the bishop
the bishop could not move i was
expecting g4 takes h5
andrew how much time does he have he has
20 seconds
oh boy
uh
what's our evaluation now i like white
but
i don't think you want to know
no
f6 just spoiled the advantage oh did it
from what to what
from like plus five to zeroes
wow tough justice stuff
and then you die
yes that's a check that is a check
but
doesn't this give us a moment that we
need to play r86 yep that's yeah that
looks like it
he wants to take on h5 with the queen is
that what he wants to do but that
doesn't make a lot of sense because you
want to yeah you actually went to i
thought you wanted to take with a pawn
yes yeah yeah it doesn't make a lot of
sense
well uh andrew's really getting tested
here as his clock is ticking down as
well on the other hand the maxim deluge
versus nick defearing game is about to
be over because it's just dead lost now
is going to
capture all of the of all of uh nick's
phones here next bonds king says six
six i mean it might be a good move but
what an insane move
hard to guess right why not keep the
rook around the king right it's still a
draw it's still a draw still a draw okay
20 seconds for mishra
oh my by the way that's the one of the
things that the seniors know they see
they see a wounded uh
animal and they say okay nick you lost
uh against shabala but what is the point
of giving all these checks it's not the
flag
not the fact that
it's a pretty good point the guy had six
seconds he needs to make a move
now king b7 kind of like asks you how
how are you going to check me now i have
g2 well you still have queen e4 right
and this is over actually maxime de luca
did beat nick defermin in a long game
ooh i think nick is not going to be
pleased with this when he realized
that's a tough loss he absolutely
spoiled now king d7
i like that move i think that's just
perfectly timed actually and if i take
on h5 and just play on
yes i'm expecting that and i was going
to go rook to b5
and maybe try to stick my rook on on f5
i'm sure it doesn't look completely
settled actually
that's a check answer is your question
queenie for check
okay
so how do you do this
well i tell you to make these decisions
with only 30 seconds it's tough it's a
starfan game as it is
even if you had a day or two
so the dream for mishra is
wow
i would have never considered this movie
that would not have been on my radar eye
now you have queen a8 right
seriously good enough to meet queen aide
it might not even be a big deal right
it's just strange
exactly why don't you go
right you kind of put your king way out
of civilization but i guess as long as
i mean i'm so close as black to make a
draw right right
queen a4 king b7
gaining something
i like i love that move
played it a little slowly but i love
that
i could have come faster
and i think we're going to see queenie
for check as well oh
and then a little slower look at andrew
now he's picking up the pace sounds like
borderline not okay to do that right
yeah
i mean we're not going to see a
repetition right now no forget about it
no no no no
i think we're going to see a capture at
long last on h5 no it's fine and then
you take i think
right maybe you throw queen eight no
all right so we begin at the end game
this is kind of the beginning position
right
and now we know i think you want your
king
at c5 your bishop on d5 so your rook
will be attacking the pawn on f6 i'm
worried about queen h8
captures h6
i think it's a winning threat so you
know
very
and by the way we have uh a winner uh
with a christian uh let's sneak in uh
pedro as he um
as we keep an eye on this game as well
christian thank you yasser we are indeed
with pedro espinosa who scored his first
victory at the u.s junior championships
first of all pedro congratulations how
does this uh victory feels to you uh it
feels really good uh so far it's been a
rough tournament i missed a win against
bellagi i missed a draw against
christopher and then i kind of got mixed
up out of the opening against obi-wan
you kind of got crushed in that game so
it feels good to win the game finally
today against karissa with the black
pieces a difficult opponent every
opponent is difficult in this tournament
were you surprised by her
opening choice definitely so i spent a
while prepping like some e4 lines and i
had to actually like really good
preparation there and then she just goes
like one g3 and i was like okay i mean
whatever just play chess like
and jesse you did play you actually set
up your pieces nicely let's take a look
at the game tell us the critical moments
yeah so out of the opening it was sort
of like this weird position where she
just puts her pawns on like g3 b3 a3 h3
and i wasn't really sure like what my
plan was but she doesn't have like a
clear plan either so we're both just
sort of like waiting around and then
eventually she goes for like d4 and we
sort of
you know simplify a little bit
um i think at some point she missed that
i had like this queen b6 resource and i
mentioned like went upon and then i was
able to sort of consolidate
um
how did you assess the position at this
point after d4 and all these
simplifications i wasn't really it's
probably equal i mean it's very
symmetrical um but i mean there's still
a lot of play behind of course did you
feel like uh you're on top though the
piece placement is a bit better i mean
the bishop
on b2 was like a little bit awkward i
think because it's kind of being blocked
out by the d4 pawn but it's probably
still like equal i can't imagine black
being like much better here but i think
she got a little bit too ambitious
and like takes takes or f1 i think she
missed queen b6 and the points that i
can hit b3 but i also have knight takes
g3 because there's a pin on the uh on
the king on g1 exactly and there's no
way to defend queen f3 force for knight
d2 i'm not sure if this was like a
blunder or a sacrifice or something but
i managed to win a pawn and then i won a
second pawn and you know i thought it
was going to be easy from there i was
like i'm going to win this game right
right but she had like this counter play
i mean from what i've seen chris is very
good at like creating counter play and
like being very tricky so
even after i won the second pawn it was
still very very tough and i um
and let's go all the way to the point
where you played that move queen to e8
and then she started sneaking that dark
square bishop in your position
were you a bit concerned at this point
yeah here i mean i i was getting lower
on the clock and i was like am i gonna
like lose this position because like i
really wasn't sure like maybe she can go
like h1 and king g3 and she can go for
some sort of like h file attack um the
bishop on d6 is very good and my pawns
aren't like that advanced so i wasn't
totally sure here but i wasn't able to
find i mean like direct like win for her
or any way through and if you can't get
through i just go like b3 b2 and but you
must have been playing for a victory at
this well yeah yeah of course of course
so let's keep going she did not find the
right moves she played this move to h1
so just uh what was your intention just
uh pedro after rook takes c8
um if she takes on c8 i'm not totally
sure what the point is like queen c8 and
like
uh like maybe like we should
oh we should be seven i missed that
which what's happening here is this it's
still equal it's probably just a draw
like you have to go knight h7 and then
it's going to end up you know perpetual
yeah
take on g6
yeah bishop f6 perpetual just perpetual
and she did not go for this one she went
for a rook to each one because rick was
like very intuitive because you don't
want to trade peace like you're
attacking so i think she just like i
didn't even consider it so you actually
think that she was still playing for a
win at this point i mean i think she's
playing for counter play like she's just
trying to like like if you like sit
around you're not like you just like
lose so you have to go for something and
then as i'm like a g5 and kind of like
trap the queen and then from there i
think it was pretty easy i just like
pushed the pawns and she can't do much
you have to be like a little bit careful
because there's something like a five or
six ideas but
you stop those tricks and you win pretty
easily
just queen
and
nice conversion
after uh this one pedro congratulations
a big victory for you
with the black pieces just before the
rest day how are you going to spend your
rest day um
i'm probably going to go hang out with
some of the friends i've made here i've
been hanging out had a lot hanging out a
lot with like brandon and andrew we're
doing some preparation together and it's
been really fun just you know being here
and just um being in st louis and
getting all these people and play all
these great players so
do some preparation have some rest and
hopefully uh
keep playing well
go get uh your hangout go get your rest
and we'll see you in a couple of days
thank you
well done pedro our congratulations as
well
it's always nice to go to the national
championships and get a whip absolutely
and we have one game remaining guys this
is that key matchup between abi manu
mishra and andrew hong
and queen e7 would be an immediate
perpetual but of course abby manuel is
not interested in that he is playing
from the side of strength absolutely and
queen b5 check laid
i'm not really sure how that changes
much i assume king xi7 right i mean i
want to kind of get my king back to the
king side maybe not too close that i
will walk into a man how are we doing on
time guys um it's 54 seconds against a
minute like just under two minutes he
has plenty of time to think about it
right two minutes for andrew uh what's
the uh computer eval it's zeros for a
very long time zeros for very long since
f6 excuse me money you play the move f6
nothing has changed in terms of uh
assessment yes that's not shocking right
well
was there a reason why
why black didn't pardon me why white
didn't go queen h eight takes h like why
did he just play queen b5 check help me
out here i'm i'm i'm a little bit
uh befuddled quinoa queen h8 i think
just go right d5
and i tend and then bishop jesus
the problem is i take with a bishop on
h5 and then i defend the rook with my
king and that's it that's clear yeah
that will be an easy easy fortress
aha
so you're just simply not in time no
gotcha well if you're not on time to
take h6 there's like no plan at all here
exactly
you have to somehow win the pawn on h6
without losing the no you're not ever
happy that's never happening
no because of what you've just said yeah
rook to rook to d5 the rook is beautiful
therefore yeah
it's protected yeah actually yeah as
soon as you play rook d5 this game might
just be over right exactly yeah
in fact that's [ __ ] that's the move
rook to d5 is a threat yeah
what a save for andrew this would be wow
right this felt he was some pleasantly
young from the beginning for the opening
he was in big trouble but he really was
but guys
with this
result christopher you is going to be
going into the last four rounds one and
a half points
ahead of abi manu it's one one point but
yeah
one point yeah so if i've been up abi
money would have won this it would have
been only half a point it's very good
goodness
true yeah but what you were saying when
you were like you when you go plus five
yeah you're expecting you're like you're
lapping the competition not that they're
only a point behind you two players that
point behind you but i point this a lot
yeah with four with only four rounds to
go that's a huge advantage right
and two categories have been finished
for today's championships guys as
karissa yip did lose her game against
pedro espinoza pedro getting a full
point actually leapfrogging over
charissa right and in the
uh senior section we have maxine doulugi
winning a long game against nick
deferman perhaps a little unnecessary to
get into those complications i think so
as well for nick
yeah and uh we only have one game
remaining
we have the standings this is the junior
girls miss perfect sophie mora suzuki
five out of five impressive but she's
followed closely well not that closely
gender for you antalya cervantes are a
full point behind but going into the
wrestlers they're gonna try to sharpen
their skills because both of these
ladies will be playing sophie in the
second half of the event what's next
in the seniors we have a larry
christensen i believe should still be in
first place right and he is and he is
yay uh dimitri gorevich vladimir kopian
and maxine bluge are now on second as
trailing at plus one while trailing on
plus one as both vladimir and maxime won
today absolutely and that leaves once
again just this one
game remaining i'm sure it's an empty
playing hall
did you like playing in an empty empty
playing hall i hated it because
every time you're in an empty playing
call it feels like somebody's trying to
set up for uh
for something for the night right
they're trying to put the flags out you
know somebody's got a backup
cleaner came out by this point
do you hate it when like the vacuum
starts oh yeah absolutely yeah oh my
gosh and there it is a very very empty
playing haul
by the way guys there is one trick in
the please please
just don't go to c7 with the king
because if you do go to c7 for example
with the queen on the fourth rank i can
go queen to f4
and the rook's and attack the pawn on h6
so that's the only trick in the position
and is that winning
probably or maybe not
in other words
in this position that we have on the
board king b7 is fine we can't see the
analysis uh queen b4 check is is fine
what christian is saying is just don't
go to c7 because queen f4
uh
stops you from playing that rook
d5 and bishop this is a little too right
you're probably like king d7 this one i
know is a theoretical draw king decides
from one f6 bishop from a practical
point of view
and then because the pawn is on that so
it's a draw it's a draw yeah right on f7
on f7 it's a draw on
i don't know on f6 an f6 that's a lot
but the problem is you can get the
behind me right right right i think i'm
from behind yeah okay but uh sorry let
me refresh my board only to say that
that was the trick and we see we see the
move queen e3 i guess it's rook d five
time right definitely rook d5
you've got to play rook t5 followed
immediately after queen takes h6 he's
going through four okay there's another
logical move here and he's done it
all right you might as well take
no
but there is no more there is no more
tricks yeah i think that's the this is
right this is it i'm going to defend the
rook with my king and even if you manage
to get the queen to e7 i'm going to go
king c6 there's no follow-up
and do the computers understand now that
it's a fortress uh oh since f6 then
since f6 f6 it's been uh about twenty
five well what was the giveaway and
there we go queen takes h6 bishop g4
very quickly played
by andrew
andrew is saying why isn't there a pawn
on f2 that would be so sweet
with the threat of rook d1 mate
nice save by andrew oh it's huge yeah
and it's huge for us it's huge for the
standards it's huge for his chances to
stay in contention because andrew starts
blistering strong but lost yesterday
remember that
with the white pieces against
christopher you that was a huge victory
for christopher as the those two players
were tied going into that game
so christopher
thinking about right now what is he
still trying in the position he can go
queen e7 check but it says that's what
he checked
bishop takes h5
the bishop will eventually
find an anchor square on g6
and there's nothing you can do the rook
will keep out white's king along the
fifth rank
so i guess the cleanest is to just put
the rook on d3 right there's nothing
that's more clean than anything else at
the moment it's just very dead right
right
you just don't like you don't attack the
rear cover right well i'm thinking you
it doesn't really yeah okay i'll go king
c6 i'll put the bishop on g6 and i go
rook f5 rook h5 forever
just keeping the rook along the fifth
uh white's king can never cross
the fifth ring
i would put the rock on d3
i don't want you to cross the third one
i'll take your bishop on g6 and my king
will be uneasy you're tricky you're a
tricky [ __ ] get out of here get out
of here
yeah this is uh
bishop to g6
and i would be so
pleased with the move bishop g6 because
then you know i can't be double attacked
i can't be tricked yeah it's um the
reminds of that ray robson game in the
american cup he just puts the queen on
g1 the pawn on h2 you're right do your
worst yeah you died your horse
yeah that was good that was good
by the way i i really want to say that
uh i've called so many tournaments but
the american
cup format the double elimination that
we did earlier this year it was really
one of my most favorite formats i've
ever well that was the bond fabulous it
was long days every day but every day we
had action exactly
and look at andrew andrew looks like
he's just like spoiled something when in
fact this is his best position
that he could get i think
i think that's a little bit of relief
yeah the understanding that this game
there's no more tricks exactly well
there is a trick though group d3 check
that there it is a trick here rook d3
qf4 rook d4 and if you go to e5 rookie
for checkmate
[Music]
i did not see that one thank you for
inviting me
you don't see those very often
checkmates
but you're making a good point rook d
three check king f4 rook d for check
really you go down you drive all the way
to g7 i don't want to allow you to go to
the gym
you go to g7 you might no no
there's nothing still but i don't want
to allow you to go there uh-huh uh-huh i
think it'll go back like king air force
i think it'll go back so you think king
f4 rook d5 i think so what's the over
and under on that weight i got i got ten
bucks in rig d5 and not rig d4 i'm not
taking that back
ah
understanding great understanding
alejandro he's ready to give mishra a
scholarship
sandra but yeah both of them i think are
good yeah
when do you guys start recruiting do you
start recruiting when they're in
early high school or even prior to that
you have your eyes i'm sure thinking
keep their eyes out for a while but
usually the about a year for me about a
year before they start because they're
eligible for
yeah like their senior year basically
senior year high school how about you
christian
um pretty much at the same time yeah uh
there's so many prospects out there and
there's a very limited amount of
scholarships so
you cannot make plans too far ahead yeah
okay you also don't know how strong they
are
right especially the last few days
right right especially in the last few
years with a pandemic and everything not
a lot of players have played a lot of
games
so it's oh okay first of all don't take
on f6 yeah yeah yeah don't touch it one
trick for white please don't touch that
yeah
so uh
roughly the same time the senior years
of high school
yeah i think it's the more logical time
to do it
but nothing earlier than that i mean you
kind of give you i mean you keep their
eyes on them right i mean i know i'm
miss talent i don't know for the problem
with me sure is that he's going to be
2700 before i can offer him his card
he'll be in the candidates
please please come and see he's going to
say louis university he's like bobby
right right
right
we'll have fabi is one of our assistant
coaches at the university
mishra i'm not sure
are we expecting king david sexier
no no we're expecting
rook d5
are we what why not
rook d5 no rugby okay
i was trying to force the queen back to
e7
no with king d6
he understands the junior players wow
you guys have too much experience for
the juniors i can't compete
king d6 that's too complicated you're
being fancy yasser
i was gonna go over and play rook takes
f6 you're trying to make things happen
there's no reason for that right
nothing has to happen right now
and a reminder that we have upcoming
tournaments guys grand chester croatia
rapid and blitz will be starting july
i'm going to croatia tomorrow so i
actually have to set up early uh grand
chester will continue with the st louis
dropping and blitz here uh august 25th
will be our first round 24th is dayton
arrival right and immediately as soon as
the grand chest to rapid blitz uh
finishes we have the sink field cup wow
and remember for both croatia and for
the singh field club we will have magnus
carlsen participating in the event great
stuff there and immediately after that
does not end guys champions showdown
starts chess nine lx that is just
official random september 13th to the
16th and the u.s and u.s women's
championships will be on the fourth to
the 20th and remember that the winner of
these events in the junior and the
junior girls
qualifies for that last tournament that
you see on your screen u.s and u.s
women's championships october 4th
through the 20th wow
nice
king to season 7 c7
see there i would be more inclined
myself to stay in touch with the rook
kingdom
yes i agree with you on that one yes sir
right
not that it makes that great a
difference
it makes zero difference
[Laughter]
well if you were gonna play king d d4
king e5 and try to grab the pawn on f6
which is what i was trying to do i i
think he's starting to make a draw guys
right what do you think thank you
mistral what do you think come on bishop
okay i'm gonna play hey let's go bishop
h5 check black
play for the trick bishop h5 sorry watch
tricks i don't know man
i don't know what tricks uh michelle's
playing for but
you can play two moves very quickly now
check and back to g6 right
would you do that i'd do it quickly i do
it
instantly right
like there's no reason not to right
right yeah
how about you uh oh absolutely yeah
yep
don't go bishop f5 to allow king g5 but
bishop h5 bishop g6 makes the most yes
what you're looking right now is to not
change anything in the position like
don't shy away from the path that
already you know is going to take you to
uh to a draw exactly
rook c
slim understanding
slim
slim
that's why social media
they will take this out of contest
context and uh
they will argue that i'm hating on the
players when you're not well i'm not of
course not
but have you ever had those games like
this one where obviously your opponent
is it's just pushing the pieces around
but
they sometimes overdo it
and then you know like you end up
winning the pawn on f6 for just no
apparent reason and then you start
playing and then you start thinking like
i should be playing for a win right
that would be that would be that way
like the way the game should go yes
right
the best
well the worst actually
um that my opponent did was
losing a rook and knight and four pawns
versus rook knight and three pawns
and i had the rook knight and three
pawns
ah you had the weaker side right then
and i managed to win that
on time or on no no on the position in
the stream wow understand
game understanding against alejandro's
student actually who
akshat tran chandra oh my god
[Laughter]
nice
okay look at five that's a check that is
a check king has to move
loses
everything else true
king e4 loses yes
king e3 and now the rook d5 looks like a
repeat of the position earlier where
there was a rook d3 i think king was on
on g3 at that point okay but okay i mean
yeah i think bobby marion needs to
finally accept the fact that this is a
draw there's there's no coming coming
back from this
no
and also the next wherever you put the
without the check uh the queen without
the check i will go d3 followed by rook
d5
that's another repetition by the way the
50 move 128 move 128. boy were you ready
with that yes
you like that
[Laughter]
i got this
nice
okay does that loose a queen nope no
guess it's okay
it doesn't rub g3 rook d5 fast
yes
uh i might put down rook d6 just because
my opponent's tiredness
is a factor no no
of course not
isn't this the same checkmate by the way
king f4 rook d4 check games
yes so this might be he played rook d5
before right yeah this might be the
second yes this is the second second
repetition right okay right yeah not
that i have any idea i mean i guarantee
you they have zero idea there's a
repetition
it's almost impossible to keep track of
these when it's not consecutive
repetitions yes it's almost impossible
that happened actually to a certain
linear dominguez he actually had a
threefold repetition against judith
pogar okay in one of their world cup
blitz rapid games whatever right he
didn't notice it was three-fold he
continued to continue to play and lost
because because they were not
consecutive right and it's they were
sometimes very difficult to remember
exactly
bobby fischer had an example exactly the
way you described but he did understand
it was a three-move repetition
and
yeah i mean he had it he had to
visualize in his head
the pattern
i'm glad we have three commentators for
this
crickets as we're waiting for uh
i just don't even see anything there is
nothing there there has been nothing for
the last 25 i mean there's just no
tricks here there's sure what do you
even
yeah
i mean i i understand playing for
cheapos but but there are no cheapos
give me a concept of give me a way in
which somebody blunders something
exactly guys sometimes silence is the
best path forward
especially for common theory
this is what tom teaches us every day
right
quaint to e7 followed by king to c6 will
not change anything in the position not
at all
there's he's still trying okay king e3
is that all right
d3 d3
king f4 rook d5
so in snooker
um the crowd applause
the moment you make a hundred points in
snooker that's a century they call it in
chess
they beat you up
and bring out the pitchforks
at least the commentators king e2
this banana was completely yellow fresh
fresh before the game started
and it was slightly untouched
you got to feel bad for the banana
really
what is the banana doing in the cup
what do you mean
that's not the place for a banana where
do you put your bananas if not a cup on
the table
right
boy you know the chess game is
talking about bananas in the cup i
appreciate all of the audience that's
still watching this we really very very
much so we really like you guys we're
doing this we're feeling loopy
but yeah my god we are losing it look
guys i wait wait a minute is this an
opportunity stop four and two
king d6 kingdom five
king d6 king e5
king the sixth king
king d6 king e5 dudes
all right
king the six queen the e8
yeah
look at him go that's fine
yeah here it goes another he's going to
win the pawn we could be here for
another two years not winning the club
yes or no no he's not winning
i like how you solve that i like how you
saw that yes
the
[Laughter]
what do you mean queen d8 uh christian
king e5 yeah you go right five queenie
seven king f5 let's go and rook e5
rookie six yeah you win the fun by force
i i i don't believe you i mean mom is
excited i i think i think you do
potential uh
victory in the i think you win the palm
by fours guys i do too
yeah i don't believe anything
but miesha was looking at the scoresheet
and going what okay maybe maybe it's
time to call it yeah
wha wha what what
misha is the beginning i'll tell you one
thing after queen the eighth he's not
even going to go for king six
queen
no he's going for king e6 baby
not a lot of choices here uh i don't
think so he's going i think he's just
going to go he's going to try to win
this game no absolutely absolutely yes
yeah baby
six come on and
and he's gonna look at the camera and
say christian this one's for you
let's call it today andrew you know you
want it
you don't deserve this victory no
don't cross your
no he's crossing his hands he's thinking
about
for it four minutes to think about it
why not why not he's actually going to
go ah
[Laughter]
what did i say
about 20 minutes ago have you ever get
those games where your opponent's over
right over presses this is the ball and
then you start thinking i should play on
no yes baby
[Music]
you
wow
coach i told you christian you know
you know your stuff my goodness king c6
the correct move in this position
he's not looking to play for a win let's
just put it this way it's it's it's over
in his
so that eyes change uh
matters broke to d2 or f hey work five
understanding
and yes he's not going to take on f6
no that's the one thing
not to
no
rook takes f6 queen a6 blunder
check another check nice good stuff
every legal move is a draw one hundred
and twenty eight
twenty eight i think well there's no
hundred
twenty eight a move yeah another check
yes quickly we
really rook to already
quickly
this is also a draw
good find
boys we're only at 102. still 26 moves
to go i'm breathless we're almost
halfway there i am
breathless with anticipation your
longest game again alejandra i'm sure
i've asked you this question yeah i
think it's like eight hours 127 moves
dang it yeah that's pretty long that was
uh
that must have been really old but it
did not feel as long as this game
and for you christian um i cannot
remember exactly i think it was
something along the lines of seven hours
i don't think i've gone beyond that
right i've crossed eight but it was only
once
you know they can't they they do we
found the advice we draw we found the
repetition somebody tells you up to 30.
in the rulebook we found the repetition
yes
all right guys excellent this was a draw
between abi magnum mishra and andrew
horn you can see it as the players quite
the tiger the titanic struggle 107 moves
and of course six and a half hours of
play
but let's go through the standings in
the juniors abby mayum mishra is now in
second foot well this is the junior
girls sophie murray suzuki still in five
points doesn't change from the fact that
the star game ended jenny for you and
telling you still one point behind right
and the juniors now in the juniors we
have christopher used you know well
pretty four and a half points right
abimanu mishra with three and a half
andrew hong three and a certain
wonderliang they're searching through
the standings in two and a half but he's
still two points away from christopher
absolutely he's looking forward to that
game
and in the seniors larry christian
citizen first there's three people
trailing on second dimitri gravity
i'm
maxine is having quite the roller
coaster right here wait's here this is
there close shop for us your final
thoughts of this game 5 rest day
tomorrow christian
well everybody needs their rest day but
what around it was and i have to say
once again i'm mightily impressed by the
race that we're seeing brewing in the
junior girls section right between these
three ladies jennifer i you sophie
maurice suzuki and talia cervantes
this one is going to be a fiery uh
finish and of course in the seniors and
juniors as well the battle is still
ongoing but i have to say alejandro we
will miss you here in the studio safe
travels to croatia and uh we'll see you
at the beginning of the grand chess tour
once again next time i talk to you guys
lots of interviews lots of fun photos
remember magnus is coming to our
tournament in zagreb so i'm going to be
very excited to meet him there and bring
you all of those interviews fantastic
it's gonna be a fun event good night
everyone
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited
you